I I had five copies made so I could try
uh good morning folks just give me one
minute and we'll get started here
foreign
good morning
um time being 903
um
I would like to open up the first
hearing of the day
House Bill 62 relative to adjusting the
road toll
and I would like to call the prime
sponsor forward to speak introduce
yourself we have a lot of business to to
do today so I would just ask those in
the audience with so many to speak
try and limit your conversation to five
minutes or less
um and uh do your best not to repeat any
subject man a matter that was done if
you have any written testimony please
pass it to uh
um representative on the answer and she
will pass that along uh for the clerk uh
it's nice to have written testimony
where we can so with that sir please
introduce yourself thank you Mr chairman
I'm Andrew Prout representing
Hillsborough County District 13 the town
of Hudson
the most recent increase to the gas tax
known as the road toll and the rsas is
from SB 367 in 2014 when it went from 18
cents to 22.4 cents
this increase is due to automatically
expire in 2034 after the bonds for
widening the southern part of Interstate
93 are paid off
the premise of this bill is let's move
that timeline up
this bill would replace the missing
Revenue with a transfer from the general
fund for the 11 years between the
effective date and the existing law
automatic repeal in 2034.
there have been many ideas of gas price
relief loaded in the last two years men
most of them have suffered from being
described as gimmicks because they are
temporary or too expensive in the long
run
the change proposed in this bill can be
described as permanent
once the Gary goes down to 18 cents it
will stay there
however it's really only an advancement
of an existing automatic repeal so the
cost is temporary
one of the things that I thought was
really unfortunate about the 2014
increase to the gas tax was that it was
done right after Massachusetts also
increased the gas tax to 24 cents
coming from a board town I know that
having that difference between the gas
taxes can give New Hampshire gas
stations an advantage when people make
strategic choices about where to fill up
it is my hope that if this bill were to
pass that we'd see this Behavior play
out in increase in volume sold in New
Hampshire
when you look at the language of the
bill you'll see that there's more moving
pieces than I just described
this is because the 4.2 cents surtax and
RSA 260 colon 32-a from 2014 is written
into the Tifa Bond contract so we can't
touch it without getting waiver from the
Federal Highway Administration which I
consider unlikely
so I worked with the legislative budget
assistant who looped in the New
Hampshire Department of Transportation
and developed the language in this bill
that reduces the base rate in RSA 26032
to 13.8 cents for an effective total
rate of 18 cents until 2034.
then in 2034 the 4.2 surtax will
automatically repeal under existing law
and this bill would have the base rate
automatically reset to back to 18 cents
at the same time
thank you Mr chairman and I'd be happy
to answer any questions the committee
may have
thank you representative for your
testimony
um member members of the committee any
questions for the representative at this
time
seeing none thank you sir thank you
I'd like to recognize Alex
um
kutabas
please educate me on your name please
looks worse than it is
Alex katrubis I'm here uh good morning
Mr chair members of the committee my
name is Alex katrubis I'm here
representing the American Council of
engineering companies uh we are an
association of about 70 engineering and
related firms
who employ about 1500 individuals in
offices throughout the state many of our
members work with Dot and municipalities
in the state to design roads Bridges
Traffic Safety survey and other civil
engineering Transportation related
projects I'm here today to oppose this
legislation
the road toll was enacted as a user fee
in the early 20th century
at the dawn of the automobile age
because of the need to build and
maintain roads and it was affirmed in
1923 by the New Hampshire Supreme Court
as a user fee
in 2014 a bipartisan bill was signed
into law Senate bill 367. it was
sponsored by a republican a senator from
Derry this committee house Public Works
and the Ways and Means Committee jointly
voted 26 to 11 to modestly raise the
road toll after not raising it for 23
years
and that legislation among other things
as you just heard enabled the dot to
finally finish widening 93 from Salem to
Manchester which as I'm sure a lot of
you know was an unfunded Transportation
need for many many years
and if you look at the
go to gasbuddy.com or any of the
websites out there you can see that the
price of gasoline after that small
increase was adopted actually went down
quite a bit and it stayed down for a
couple of years the cost of crude oil is
the number one factor in the price at
the pump
according to the U.S Energy Information
Administration it makes up 61 percent of
the cost of a price of a gallon of gas
that was an analysis that was done in
February of 2022
according to the American petroleum
Institute the primary factors impacting
gasoline prices are again Global crude
prices Refinery costs distribution and
marketing costs and then federal and
state taxes and the taxes are generally
reflected in the wholesale cost of the
gasoline that the retailers pay the
Distributors and that's true in New
Hampshire
uh this that very topic was discussed in
April of last year it was front page of
the union leader a few at State House
revved up about gas tax holiday Senate
GOP bails on gas tax cut that if you go
look at that hearing it's on YouTube you
can see that the retailers and the
wholesalers came in and they said
there's no way to guarantee that this is
actually get passed on to the consumers
and uh representative umberger came and
spoke against the legislation and
several others did and
um that that issue didn't get any
traction
so we're opposed to this bill uh it's
all it's going to do is violate the user
system user pays for the system
principle it's going to make things
difficult for your colleagues down in
the finance committee because now we're
going to have to take General funds to
backfill the cost and it's really not
going to have any impact to the consumer
at the pump so we would urge you to itl
this this legislation thank you very
much thank you sir are there questions
for Mr gertruvas
seeing none thank you sir you're welcome
I would like to recognize uh from New
Hampshire dot Deputy Commissioner and
Andre Brier sir Maria thank you
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee
Andre Briere Deputy Commissioner of Dot
we're speaking today in uh in opposition
we have three primary concerns with the
legislation has written uh the first is
a uh unknowable but but non-zero effect
on our uh on our bond ratings uh anytime
guaranteed sources of revenue are
altered that goes in it's factored into
our our bond ratings we don't know
exactly what that effect would be uh we
just uh based on our our experience and
judgment uh think that there will be
some effect the second is uh
some modification to our Tiffy alone
that's that's already been mentioned
that was taken out to uh to finance I-93
widening the terms of which will have to
be modified if this legislation goes
through the effects of that could be
anything from uh you know a simple
amendment that has no effect on the
overall agreement to
some effect on the agreement we just
don't know what that would be we'd need
to get lock and lowered our experts to
uh to evaluate that that risk if if this
legislation were to pass the third
objection we think is is actually the
most Salient though uh road toll
is gathered from our our very large
tourist uh population that that travels
the state transient Vehicles the net
effect of this legislation would be to
place more burden uh on on New Hampshire
taxpayers for maintaining our roads and
less burden on those who use our roads
for tourism and travel
and those are our primary concerns Mr
chairman and standing by for any
questions
any questions for the Deputy
Commissioner
oh please
please yep
sorry about that Mr chairman I'm not
sure you can see me when my hand is up
yeah um go ahead I've got a question or
two for you
um
has your department figured out and have
an estimate of how much revenue you will
lose if this bill passes well as written
it would it would technically be Revenue
neutral the only change would be uh with
regard to the source of Revenue these
would be General funds that would be
applied to the highway Fund in lieu of
uh the the change you know the the Delta
that would be uh
that would be uh taken out of the road
tool
yeah and you mentioned that it could
affect your bond rating how much of
your department income
is uh
with this effect and I I don't
understand really how it would affect
the moderating much
I would I would uh
get back to you on a full treatment of
that question sir but but based on our
experience whenever uh there is any sort
of change in dedicated Revenue that's
taken into account
okay thank you thank you represent Boger
thank you Mr chairman
um
the question is if we take this money
from the general fund to cover
something that
anybody who buys gas in New Hampshire
pays for currently then coming out of
the general fund then it would only be
then covered by people who live in New
Hampshire
correct that's right and if I may add
continue
um please so as we move the money the
34 million dollars out of the general
fund would that have an adverse effect
on future Highway projects that that we
would be sourcing to do as we try to
improve like uh Route 16 going north and
stuff because that has been on the radar
I do believe to expand it and if we're
taking money from General funds and
stuff to Now cover Highway projects
would that have an adverse effect trying
to do that no thank you for the question
sir I guess I would answer it in
with the general sense that whenever
dedicated revenues are taken away it
just makes it less predictable right we
we have to reassess every biennium uh
whether we in fact would get those funds
appropriated it makes long-term planning
um
potentially more more tricky uh
again as written this bill would would
guarantee a replacement level for those
funds in which case it would be neutral
but like I said the source of that
Revenue would be less from from
out-of-staters or those using our roads
who aren't New Hampshire taxpayers and
unless for them I with regard to
specific projects and the impacts on
those that that's a bit unknowable at
this point if this legislation were to
pass we'd continue to assess that and
would update this committee
one follow-up please one last follow-up
certainly thank you
um with
currently is the highway fund for making
Highway improvements
above
at PACE or below where it should be at
this point in time in a year well thank
you sir for that question uh I think uh
Pro probably many members of this
committee are familiar with the fact
that long term our Highway fund
has a structural deficit and that's true
with every Highway Fund in every state
in the country right now and that's
mostly due to improving Cafe standards
greater efficiency in the in the uh
fossil fuel powered vehicle Fleet and
also the onboarding of more and more uh
electric vehicles onto our roads that
all has the net effect of decreasing
revenues to our Highway fund and that's
that's every state and that's also
nationally our national U.S Highway fund
also is suffering from that long-term
structural deficit so any decrease in
Revenue to the highway fund just
exacerbates that that long-term
structural deficit
thank you
um yes representative Juris thank you
Chad
what uh
how much from the road toll goes to
maintenance yearly maintenance of state
roads and highways
but what you can gather
we can catch an exact figure for that
sir uh right after that happy to provide
that but does
currently there are those some of those
monies go towards maintenance yes
absolutely on a yearly basis okay that
yeah that's our Paving program our
betterment
um
potholes God reels all that stuff LED
signs yep well
yeah I mean I'd have to check out LED
size but yes you're you're generally
there's yes okay thank you yes sir thank
you
all right
um seeing no further questions thank you
sir thank you sir nice to have you here
um I also have uh Jennifer Hall from um
Dot
welcome thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee
um I'm here representing Department of
Safety Road tool Bureau we're opposed to
this bill for many of the same reasons
that
um Deputy Commissioner Brier just
mentioned we question the long-term
sustainability while the general fund
might be able to support this currently
is it going to in the future and that
could put local Highway Aid at risk in
future years
um additionally this bill does very
little for the consumer based on 12 000
miles per year average at an average of
25 miles per gallon about 480 gallons of
consumption on average per user per year
so I would say if the average consumer
about twenty dollars a year
and as we've heard there's no way for us
we have no price control so there's no
way for us to guarantee that that
savings actually gets passed down to the
retail level
there will be challenges with
implementation including how we're
supposed to handle the higher taxed
retail station inventory that will be on
hand once this bill goes into effect
retail stations will likely try to draw
down their higher tax inventory prior to
the effective date and this could cause
a supply issue if they all try to
replenish after the rate decreases
um we also anticipate a need for at
least a 90-day lead time to allow for
proper Community communication to our
Distributors and Retail stations
and update their systems as well
um
we'd like to request that if this bill
does pass we extend the effective date
to October 1st 2023.
thank you are there any questions
yes representative thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking a question
the department of safety collects a
certain proportion of the money
collected out of their old toll
would this legislation affect
the amount that the
Department either collects with that or
allocates for other
safety uh safety programs throughout the
state
we collect the entire amount of the road
toll and then we pass it along to the
highway fund for the Department of
Transportation to use towards
well
but you retain a certain portion to
cover the cost of collection and
as well don't you
I would have to get back to you on that
I'm not familiar
any further questions
thank you thank you
my last pink card if there's anyone else
wishes to speak should please bring a
card forward uh here on house filled 62
I'd like to recognize Gary Abbott from
the associated general contractors of
New Hampshire
foreign
thank you chairman committee members
it's nice to be back before the Public
Works committee my name is Gary Abbott
I'm the Executive Vice President of the
associated general contractors of New
Hampshire I come to you today in
opposition to house bill 62.
I looked at this bill and I always like
to give a different perspective you've
got some great information from the
previous speakers
we look at it as the highway program is
a long program we do a 10-year Highway
plan you have to have consistent revenue
for the Department to develop a plan one
of the things that this does is it even
if it was to work like this bill says it
would you're switching from a long-term
a long-term Financial
consistency to having every two years
subject to the budget
and uh when I brought this forward to my
board they just basically said this it's
a bad deal it is really is not a good
deal to put this into the subject of the
state budget which it is currently not
um it would be a nightmare so I told the
board well is there a way to guarantee
this and I don't think you can guarantee
the budget process every two years from
one to the other I also think the
department of safety is correct there's
some timing here of money and transfers
it's pretty close that this bill would
go into effect by June 30th and the
budget happens at June 30th and the
department of safety would be having to
try to lower their amount that gets
collected by Distributors the money
coming in there's a lot of different
issues and then the next two-year cycle
you would have this reduction
permanently in the statute while you're
not sure whether you would get the money
out of the next budget cycle
so keep in mind
the 4.2
is really part of the last tax increase
that Sunset says was discussed so we
have 11 years worth of Revenue to go and
so this really cuts it into a very
short-term non-guaranteed situation
so I also think we agree with what Alex
catrubus said we've studied a lot
the price at the pump is not necessarily
related to the gas tax so there isn't
really a correlation
there was a Senate bill in which the
Distributors from Rhode Island came in
and they were under political and
newspaper press that the prices didn't
drop even though they lowered the they
waived the gas tax during the covid
crisis so there is no correlation there
so I we looked at it tons of times New
Hampshire was sometimes had higher gas
price
then our neighboring states that hired a
higher gas tax so the correlation
doesn't really relate into the
consumer's pocket so I would just leave
you with that that we would hope this
committee would not go forward with the
bill I think
it does create a lot of different issues
and one of the other concerns that's in
here is if you notice it doesn't take it
from the 4.2 that's going to Sunset it
takes it from the 18 cents that's been
there for a long time and so that in
itself will cause problems I believe in
the future because you'll have the
sunset and you've had reduction of 4.2
from the 18. I can see some issues in
2034 which you might have to address but
I clearly probably won't be here
testifying before you in in 2034. but
with that I would hope the committee
would vote in expedient
thank you are there any questions for Mr
Abbott
seeing none thank you sir thank you my
last card now
um is uh amby Chevrolet
[Music]
I'm terrible so I apologize Continental
Paving uh Amy Charbonneau from
Continental Paving thank you for having
me I'd just like to take one minute to
kind of take a flip look at everything
so we're looking at everything we would
lose I would just like to mention
everything that the four cents gained us
um if you look at 93 just personally my
dad fought 18 years to get the four
cents on the gas tax and what 93 has
brought New Hampshire we can't forget
about that so we're talking about
everything we would lose but what we
gain from that four cents is incredible
I mean all the housing that's come and
economic development at exit one at Exit
four people are coming to New Hampshire
because now they can they're not sitting
in traffic for a long period of time so
that four cents was huge to New
Hampshire versus what the people would
gain at the pump which we've proven is
really nothing so I just wanted to take
one minute to take the flip side of the
positive of that four cents and how
amazing it has been in uh consumer
construction economic world for housing
everything I mean 93 is awesome and
nobody can really deny that and that's
what the four cents got us so the
negatives versus the positives here
are very drastic to us so thank you very
much if anybody has any questions yeah
any questions
yes thank you yeah representative thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question again
um you're everybody's saying what a
great loss this will be can you give me
an actual dollar figure on estimated
loss if this bill passes in a year's
time so again it's neutral
which everybody has said but the
difference is New Hampshire people
paying the full 35 million versus
potential out I mean look at how many
tourists there are that come to just the
hooks at toll plaza they fill their car
up from Massachusetts everywhere and
they're paying our Force you know
they're paying our gas tax versus
putting the abundance of the pain on all
New Hampshire people I mean also the
concern for us is the line budget like
we said every two years it's not a
guarantee
yeah quick follow-up so what you're
saying is it's approximately 35 million
dollars we're talking about here yes
okay thank you and the the the other
benefit that has been happening is there
has been general fund money being pushed
to dot to actually help with the deficit
that we are the dot is functioning like
we're not keeping up with the roads and
the maintenance as it is right now and
the governor and everybody have worked
to give like last year there was 66
additional million dollars given to
municipalities and towns so the worry is
that if you take 35 and you that's now a
line item there's no way we're getting
that extra 66 you know to keep up with
the roads because that that's a that's
the large number now so there's already
general fund money in the Surplus the
last couple years going to help the
D.O.T because they are functioning at a
very low I mean all honesty we should be
talking about adding four cents instead
of taking four cents away they're not
we're not keeping up with our roads and
our bridges and Concord and all the
projects they have in the 10-year plan
are getting pushed farther down
um just being pushed farther out year
after year so there's already not a line
item but a surplus being spent on Dot
that now now we're taking that general
fund we're putting that in there taking
four cents away it just and there's I
think it's more complicated than it
seems thank you uh president I just want
to remind you and others we have another
hearing starting in two minutes so be
precise
thank you
um do you have an idea if the cost of of
uh construction of a highway or
improvements to the highway have went up
down or oh definitely have gone up just
I mean the cost of Steel
um the escalation like last year
specifically what we do I can speak to
Asphalt because of oil has gone up went
up drastically Last Summer
the inflation that which is another huge
problem in the dot the funding is not
increasing because the gas tax and
people are getting more miles to the
gallon so the it's a declining revenue
for this dot at the same time inflation
around the world I mean our country is
going up 10 construction last year was
probably at 18 I mean pipe that used to
cost six is now 18 and New Hampshire
people don't have control over that
we're just buying it from our you know
where we have to and labor costs are
going up everything's going up but at
the same time we're not increasing
Revenue to the source thank you
yes please thanks
briefly do you see with this road toll
proposal do you see an impact on your
skilled labor construction managers Etc
uh being impacted
by this proposal I mean I don't think
this changes them because it technically
doesn't change the budget year after
year but it can because of that
additional money that we're getting I
the hardest part with the budget as a
current stands is we get surpluses which
are great it's like feast or famine so
you don't know what you're going to get
for a surplus one year I can employ 350
New Hampshire residents and the next
year I only need 270 because you don't
know until there's a surplus in the
budget that you're going to get any
extra money so you don't know what
work's going to come out you can't we
just want a nice you know a good Buffet
but you can't and we don't like to lay
people off personally our company we
like to keep them employed we don't want
put people on employment or layoff in
the middle of summer but we the dot just
needs a consistent funding source so
that all the contractors in New
Hampshire which New Hampshire is very
unique it's full of all family
businesses we want to keep people
employed so it's just we need a
consistent funding source and every two
years again having it be a line item
that could get chopped is an unknown for
us
right
thank you okay thank you thank you very
much thank you so much for coming
um seeing no other questions uh from the
board we will we will end testimony on
House Bill 62 FN
we will open if members need to leave
and come back I understand that we are
going to open up uh House Bill 480
relative to the intersection between
route 302 and East Conway Road in Conway
and I would like to recognize the prime
sponsor of house bill 480.
I don't there's
representative buco
and represent Buco I understand you
wanted to bring some other members up
with you or they're going to come up
after that are testifying they will they
will follow okay thank you before you
start representative for the new members
and members that have been here for the
last couple years representative bucco
served with me on public works and
highways
2002 and uh
2004. yep and with that welcome back and
please provide your testimony thank you
Mr chairman and it's it's feels good to
be back in public works and highways
um
well I record my name is Tom Buco and
I'm I currently serve Carroll County
District number one which is the town of
Conway
I'm here today to introduce House Bill
480 relative to the intersection of
Route 302 and East Conway Road in Conway
and to request that this committee
recommend this bill ought to pass
this intersection is scheduled to be
rebuilt because there's been many
accidents there and these
the East Conway Road Corridor is an
industrial Corridor several years ago
the town changed the East Conway Road to
his own in the industrial Corridor in
order to attract new businesses into
that
that area that section of Tom
and that is what we have now
in the industrial Zone
exists a landfill a landfill a transfer
station a gravel pit two fuel Depots and
these businesses draw heavy loads and
oversized traffic
and the current proposal to build around
there's a current proposal to build a
roundabout
but after making
um
after after going out of our way to make
this this industrial area in this area
industrial zoned industrial it doesn't
make sense to put this this would end up
being an obstacle actually at the end of
East Conway Road
um excuse me
um
the trucks so I they we also had a
demonstration on a heavy load on
navigating around about
and I witnessed one of these
demonstrations
and there was a big heavy load and a lot
I think it was about an 80-foot trailer
uh overall 80 foot
um and the low boy was it was snapping
and popping and it had to go up on the
curb on the outside and then the the low
boy went across the apron and cracked
all up
phony the phony brick concrete
so
and and in addition to that the drivers
told me that no if there's a roundabout
no matter what it they're gonna have to
stop anyway so it's not going to make a
continuous loop of traffic because these
big trucks have to stop and then they
have to
start up again it's they're not going to
just you know there's gonna it's gonna
cause traffic to back up in every
direction
[Music]
um
I think that uh I can try to answer some
questions but this there's several
people here that several business owners
and residents that um have a direct
impact this will have a direct impact so
I I think I'll stop there at this point
thank you representative uh represent
Mills
thank you Mr chair uh
just to be clear is is this currently is
this project currently on the 10-year
plan and you're just trying to have the
project itself itself altered yes thank
you
further questions by the committee
yes rep Sim
uh thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
representative Buco can you can you
share any light on how it is that you
were unable to get this modification in
the normal process through the regional
Planning Commission do they not agree
that this change should be made
no they that's correct they do not
you asked me if the
did I answer your question okay thank
you anyone else for the representative
thank you representative yes
yes thank you Mr chairman is this for
the construction of a roundabout or a
traditional traffic light
setup it's proposed around about this
bill would be a traditional intersection
with a traffic signal
that's what this that's what this bill
that's what this bill asks for it asks
for a traditional intercept intersection
with with traffic signals
thank you
thank you representative thank you
um Chief Neil Henry is it please
who is uh supports the bill
welcome
thank you for the record Chief Dean
letters from the Redstone fire
department and I do have three concerns
with a roundabout
as far as safety goes
versus the size of the roundabout
I'm more worried about large Vehicles
having car accidents uh Hazmat incidents
as far as the bulk fill facilities go
that are located on East Conway Road
which there were
it was mentioned there were two fuel
Depots there there's actually four bulk
pill facilities for liquid propane so
the trucks constantly come in and out of
there
um
as well as oil tankers coming through
that main route
I'm more worried about a rollover with a
an oil tanker having a Hazmat incident I
really don't want to have to do the
paperwork on anything like that
um
so that's my first concern
uh
second concern is a stop Gap in traffic
as far as 302 goes being a major road
living on that road and running the fire
department there's a ton of traffic and
there's a constant flow if we keep the
flow moving with a roundabout
uh I believe that there's issues with
traffic accidents on that road which are
a lot of traffic accidents on 302 in
that one area because of the flow of
traffic
um
the uh
of course I said I had three issues I
only have two and that's that's about it
that's even better for us thank you
Chief is there anyone have any questions
for the chief
yes representative Faulkner
thank you Chief I'm not sure I
understand the issue of rollover isn't
isn't the risk of a rollover for a Sharp
left turn the same or less
or greater than it would be with a
roundabout that would take a more
a wider turn it's uh
if you come to a traffic signal
in a bigger truck and you're you're
slowing down to turn right left anything
like that then you're coming around a
roundabout and depending on the size
they make the roundabout
uh
I I think the rollover would be more
evident than that I'd heard uh issues
with Gorham Maine there's a large
roundabout where tankers were actually
overturning on that and of course I I'm
not
uh
I just have concerns with it we'll put
it that way I don't have proof that it
would happen so
thank you
seeing no further question Chief thank
you for coming down thank you for having
me
I'd like to recognize from dot Paul
[Music]
d
Granary
am I having the wrong bill here 480 is
there someone from dot to speak town of
Conway perhaps Paul DeLeon I apologize
I'm going to yes please
thank you Mr chairman
good morning
members of the committee
um my name is Paul De leonjali
I'm the
Town engineer and Deputy Town manager
for the town of Conway for these past 32
years I'm here this morning at the
behest of the Conway Board of selectman
uh to speak against in opposition of
this bill
um before I get into the reasons why
it seems like there was some confusion
based on the questions
this is an existing intersection
of two New Hampshire Roots U.S Route 302
and the East Conway Road this
intersection has been very problematic
we have dozens of accidents and several
fatalities
we applied under the road safety program
and were accepted and is in design
to solve the problem
as you may know and there are members
from dot behind me
when you do that
you look at the problem you do the
traffic counts you get an understanding
of what the problem definition is and
then you come up with the alternatives
to solve the problems
this is an intersection
there are two Alternatives it will
either be signalized or it'll be a
roundabout
are there any questions so far
seeing none continue thank you alignment
representative thank you Jim just
briefly so
is studying right now an intersection
versus around about that's correct okay
just a for clarity thank you you're
welcome thank you please continue
on behalf of the board of Selectmen who
are opposed to this bill they are
opposed for several reasons the first
reason is that this bill is trying to
legislate a design change which
circumvents the process
of studying the problem
gaining information holding public
information hearings holding public
education hearings and ultimately
creating Community consensus
this is a process that took place
and it took place longer with additional
public hearings because of the
opposition
that's represented in the room today
in addition to the usual and customary
process
you've heard representative Buco talk
about a demonstration not one but two
demonstrations
at the heart of the problem is that
there is a
Quarry that gains access from this road
and the Quarry will move
special permit Vehicles very large
vehicles and we'll need to come through
this intersection that is a valid
concern
the town of Conway has three roundabouts
that have been in existence in operation
for many years we agreed to a
demonstration let's take that equipment
that tractor trailer that lowboy with
that load on it and let's take it
through our existing roundabouts
our existing roundabouts mind you are
designed for a wb67 wheelbase 67 which
is the statutory allowed legal vehicle
in the state of New Hampshire
not the vehicle that we will be seeing
to the Quarry which is done by special
permit
that particular vehicle was a WB 85.5
with 120 000 pound load
limit
that's the kind of vehicle that goes
down the road with a State Trooper
behind it and in front of it
I sat in the passenger seat Mr noise
drove Mr Noyes isn't in the room this
morning
and it navigated figure ate it if you
will because we have two roundabouts in
row on our North South Road the existing
roundabouts
that was witnessed by myself Town
engineer PE
the state safety engineer Mike Dugas who
has since retired PE the state's chief
of design from Zane
PE
professional engineer and our conclusion
was how it works
it works on the smaller roundabout
it's always been the intent that the
roundabout at us 302
right Maine New Hampshire and Vermont
would be a larger structure
and it will be
and yet this vehicle navigated those
roundabouts
the Selectmen are opposed to this
legislation because it circumvents the
process
the selectment reports this legislation
because it is not the governing body's
choice
I don't have more to expand on that I
explained the process explain the
multiple public hearings the two
demonstrations
the arguments listened to on both sides
and the decision was made
letters were sent in as part of the
process to the dot I'm sure Bill
Oldenburg behind me can talk to that and
produce them a letter from the board of
Selectmen in favor of the roundabout
option a letter from the police chief in
favor of the roundabout option you heard
from Chief Henry
Conway has seven precincts seven fire
departments
we had letters from the Conway Village
fire department and the North Conway the
two larger departments in support of the
roundabout
letter from the director of Public Works
in support of the roundabout
they Repose this legislation because
it's not the community's choice
this legislation is an end run it's an
attempt to change the outcome of the
process
the Boris segment is opposed to this
legislation for a third reason
a signalized intersection is neither the
safest nor the most efficient way to
treat the intersection
despite
National statistics insurance
professional societies of Engineers the
American Society of state and Highway
design officials
yeah there's a body
of statistics and results
that without a Shadow of Doubt
demonstrate that a roundabout is a safer
way to treat an intersection than a
signal
and it's more efficient
as I said we have three roundabouts in
Conway already we have lots of
development in traffic I've made a
career out of
doing traffic analysis and traffic
studies
it will simply put through more traffic
in less time
thank you
uh questions yes oh thank you again Mr
chairman thank you for appearing what's
the existing I should have asked this
earlier what's the existing traffic
control at this intersection none
hence
dozens of accidents and multiple
fatalities
further questions
rep temperatures thank you chair thanks
again
so you're studying the signalization
versus the roundabout in in just as an
aside
I've heard some reports lately of
municipalities around the country trying
to move more towards roundabouts as
opposed to certain signal
intersections I believe there's a and
you it is a town in Indiana that has
redone every of the intersections I'm
told it's the roundabout capital of the
world as opposed to uh and and
reverting them from signalized
intersections I heard that report lately
on the radio I think it was last month I
don't know if you if you're familiar
with it
um
and just in my case personally I use two
every day in Nashua one at the high
school at North on Broad Street and one
at South Main representative you could
suspend for a moment a lot of that I
don't see a question a lot of that will
handle during the executive session okay
you got it but uh
I thank you for your thanks for your
your uh Mr chairman Mr Mayor I think we
agree with where the representative was
going the Selectmen are in favor of the
roundabout thank you sir are there
further questions yes represent Burger
thank you Mr chairman
uh could you speak to the safety of a
signal intersection in reality I'm not
and the safety of a roundabout as people
are flowing have been flowing and the
actual usage of these intersections in
reality and not conceptually
so in reality
something that engineers and insurance
companies like to do is collect
statistics roundabouts have been around
for many years we've had them in conwave
going on two decades so at a minimum in
America we have a 20-year database
and what that database will tell you
what the insurance companies and what
the professional societies of design
Engineers will tell you is that the
roundabout is a safer intersection than
a signalized intersection
thank you
yes
representative fideli uh excuse me yes
Gaddafi
as I understand it just is just a
nominal section right now
this is a T intersection with U.S Route
302 being the Hat
and East Conway Road being the right now
wouldn't it be simple to just run a test
for like two months with a light there
and answer that question for those
expect to the people that are opposing
this
I don't understand the representatives
questions sir uh represent as I
understand Representatives asking if you
could do a temporary traffic light there
to uh to gauge
uh the effective use of that
intersection
anything could be done but
I don't see I don't see the point
thank you thank you
represent Khan
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question now is this going to
be a single lane or a double lane
roundabout this is a single Lane
roundabout okay thank you
any further question
yes represent Faulkner thank you uh
isn't it true that in the long term it's
you can save money with an operations
cost with around about
compared to a signalized intersection
I don't have that info I'm sorry I can't
answer that question I'm not sure about
that perhaps the dot folks can
sure
seeing no further questions thank you
sir for your testimony thank you thank
you members of committee
I'd like to recognize uh Jeff Burke from
Burke Corey please
thank you
Mr Burke it's nice to have you here in
our committee it's nice to put a name
with the face please continue thank you
I'm Jeff Burke I am the Corey owner
um I am in support of this bill
um I'm not dead against a roundabout and
I'm not saying we have to have a traffic
signal I just don't believe that the
roundabout that they're proposing is big
enough for the
um equipment that we're running through
this roundabout we we just talked about
the demonstrations we did
um we didn't mention that
the excessive wear to the tires that are
left on these radiuses
and
um the popping and twisting of the
frames of these large pieces of
equipment that we're moving in the
excessive wear on these trucks that
they're getting going through these
roundabouts
and I put we're putting a pile of big
trucks through there and it does slow
down so I think if we could put a
roundabout in and it could be big enough
I think that's fine if we can't get a
big enough roundabout then we need to go
with a traffic signal
thank you are there questions Mr Burke
yes please
below thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for testifying uh how many loads a
day a week what's the rate in the
summertime where averaging round trips
of about 300 trucks a day just coming
from our Quarry
going through that intersection
follow-up and that's the you're talking
about the big trucks those are correct
dump trucks um trailer dumps and then
um equipment that we move
okay thank you one one more please just
to clarify so it's 300 but I I think the
issue is about the really big the really
big ones how many of those
um probably a couple loads from us daily
and then there's obviously your logging
trucks the fuel trucks coming in and out
so I don't know if you would have a
total of 25 of those a day probably
but if I could follow up for that for
your extremely large loads which I'm I'm
guessing are probably bringing Crushers
in and out or something like that
Crushers excavators that that's not a
date that's not daily okay I mean some
of them I mean it's it's steady but it's
not daily yeah thank you further
questions
yes I'm sorry representative yes thank
you
so when the demonstration was done this
was on the proposed larger sized
roundabout no I believe it was 10 feet
smaller
okay
follow up could you give me a mental
picture of of this so are we talking
diameter width of the roads it would be
diameter of the
I'm not 100 sure how to explain that but
it would be 10 feet bigger in a circle
all the way around it all right thank
you thank you
seeing no further question thank you sir
for driving down here
I would like to uh recognize Bill
aldenberg from New Hampshire Dot
foreign
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Bill Oldenburg I'm
the assistant director of project
development at the DOT
on behalf of the department I'd like to
speak in opposition to House Bill 480
for a couple reasons
um as as you've heard this bill or this
this intersection already exists in the
10-year plan
um
the town had submitted a road safety
audit request due to the safety concerns
of the intersection
um we did have a a review of that and
um
concurred with their concerns and
entered a project that is funded through
our
highway safety Improvement program hsip
um that uh
is currently in the 10-year plan as
Conway
42522 just for the record and the intent
of that project uh that's your suspend
for a moment well my Clerk's phone is
turned
thank you uh please continue and the
intent of that project was to implement
intersection safety improvements
it wasn't it wasn't editor's signal it
wasn't and it was a roundabout through
the public involvement process we had
multiple public meetings with the select
board and with the public we presented
both options a signalized intersection
and a roundabout intersection
um
both work for us
um we we put them up equally against
each other
um and the select board the town
officials agreed and supported the
roundabout option and the consensus of
the public meeting was that the
roundabout option was the preferred
alternative
yes
as you'll hear there were people that
had concerns about the roundabout design
um
every project we do there are people
that
do not 100 agree with with uh everything
the public process was that the
roundabout was the preferred alternative
um the the underlying intent of this
bill is to to take that
that public process
um and require us to to put in a signal
and that
that sort of goes against our whole
public participation process
um
we did have
that so A few things that you might have
heard I'll try to answer some of the
questions that that you've already asked
um
the design of the roundabout there was
the demonstration the the 83 foot
vehicle
um went through the roundabout not
easily but went through the roundabout
the the curb it went over is the truck
apron on the inside of the roundabout
it's intended for the trucks to go on
um cars stay off trucks go on it it's a
it's intended for the trucks to be able
to navigate around the roundabout
um one thing to note is the roundabout
it went through was smaller than the
intended design that we have
we reviewed that vehicle where the the
design initially was
um larger than that roundabout we're
actually going to increase it a little
more to make sure I'm sorry you're going
to increase increase the diameter thank
you um to to ensure that that his extra
large Vehicles can can go through
uh one thing I would know
uh the the track the the dump trucks the
large vehicles
um these are all designed to handle
those regular sized vehicles
um case in point we have a roundabout on
Route 9 in Swansea daily
modular homes travel from Vermont into
New Hampshire
they navigate through those roundabouts
and those those are daily
um
school buses we heard about the the
roundabout at the right at the entrance
the National North High School
um there's there's some near the um uh
here in Concord
um a fire trucks
are the basically the same body length
and type as a school bus
um there the the roundabout here in
Concord
um where the ladder truck goes through
it's all designed to handle those
Vehicles so the design and the size of
the vehicles we can we can design
roundabouts so uh to handle those large
Vehicles there was a question about the
safety and again
um
with the queuing at a traffic signal
well let me step back when you when you
put in a the existing intersection is a
stop intersection so there is control so
root 302 is straight through East Conway
comes to a stop sign today and that's
the issue
um changing it to a signal it just takes
those problems that you have with a stop
sign and rearranges those problems now
you have people rearranging the back of
the queue you have people running the
red light
the the long-term maintenance you have
equipment that you have to maintain when
the power goes out signals don't work a
roundabout works when the power goes out
around about slows traffic I
it it is I don't want to repeat what um
please said but they're a safer
intersection so
with that I
take any questions you may have thank
you yes please represent the loan thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for
testifying so the question so you
mentioned about those modular homes so
the in Conway it's an 83 foot low boy
that was the test for the roundabout so
how big are those modular uh
tractor trailers that that go through
well the wheelbase was it's a little bit
more difficult because the wheelbase on
a modular home the wheels tend to be in
the middle but there there are upwards
of 70 75 feet long just the modular
component that just the home so you put
a trailer on that they're probably
equally in length but the wheelbase is
different and the width I'm sorry Mr
chairman follow up in the in the width
of the trailer of the modular homes
versus the the uh the lowboy that was
very usually and is it wider
it depends the the gravel they're
probably about the same size a modular
home is usually around 10 feet 11 feet
wide
okay thank you thank you very much
yes representative chairs thank you chat
uh bill you mentioned
you've got a design ready to go you've
got a signalized design You've Got a
roundabout design and you're going to
change your order the roundabout design
to increase the diameter
are there any land takings that you
might be doing for that in either any of
the design or is it or is it City
currently to city or state land
so both designs
when we went to our last public meeting
this summer The preferred alternative
was the roundabout so we've continued
with the roundabout design
we're probably half done with that
design have completed the the plan is to
advertise that does that project in
January so less than a year away both
would require land takings land
Acquisitions so one of the advantages
with the with a roundabout is
um the lanes don't have to be widened
the problem okay so
um it's all within the right-of-way so
um
there's uh I know there's property that
we'll have to probably acquire easements
for
um from eversource and the town of
Conway but for the roundabout that's the
only
uh thank you any for any further
questions
yes please represent Melvin thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question do you have an idea on what the
traffic backup would be if you had a
stoplight versus a round remote
[Music]
um
I really have that information
no we haven't we haven't calculated that
yet okay but the requirement would be as
we put in turn Lanes so there'd be left
turn lane
um
it depends on how long the signal is
but I wouldn't I wouldn't imagine the
backup's going to be very long
with a signal and none with a round
please
do you have an idea what's there now
for backup
so root 302 doesn't back up because they
don't have to stop so at East Conway
Road I
a few cars at the most I would I would
envision
thank you
seeing no further questions thank you
thank you very much
I have I have presently one two three
four more pink cards if anyone else is
wishing to speak I'd like to see that
card at this time
I'd also like to tell those
that we have just about every one of
these cards is requesting 15 to 20
minutes to speak
I would hope during the course of this
time maybe some of that information
might be repetitive and I would like you
to scale back where you can I fully
understand that this crew came from
further north than me and we will afford
your time but if if all of these
individuals require 20 minutes we're
probably going to have to recess this
hearing and bring it back at the end of
the afternoon
so let's try and be
uh
effective use of time with like with
that I would like to recognize Francis
sario please
supports the bill representing himself
good morning Mr chairman committee
members thank you my name is Fran sorrow
I live in Center Conway New Hampshire
um I guess one of the things that I'd
like to talk about today is a rebuttal
on some of the points that have been
made earlier some of the folks that are
behind me who have yet to speak will add
some additional Clarity to that but the
one thing that I would like to say is
that nobody is here to repudiate the
work that's been done or the data or the
statistics I know Paul and I have talked
about these things informally and then
at the June selectment meeting
everyone accepts the data the concern
that we have is is the proposed
roundabout going to be big enough so
that the safety attributes associated
with roundabouts will actually
materialize at this location and the
reason we ask that is oil Tanners
PowerPoint that was given in May
identified some considerations that they
had to contend with one is Wetlands on
the opposite side of Route 302 and the
other is redstone Salvage which is a
junkyard and whether there's potential
pcbs and other environmental issues in
the ground and so our question is
specifically in a perfect world if those
did not exist
would the design of the roundabout
that's being put forth now be bigger if
the answer is yes then it should be
bigger and if it can't be because of
those considerations that is the state's
issue not our issue
and that's that's a very big concern
that we have nobody's disputing the fact
that they're safer okay however a lot of
that safety I think probably is in areas
where most of you may be familiar with
more residential areas and passenger
traffic the the highway
the traffic study that was done if I'm
interpreting oil Tanners slides
correctly and I would encourage anybody
here to dispute it is they showed
thirteen thousand five hundred vehicles
per day on Route 302 approximately eight
percent of those are trucks that's a
thousand trucks a day
you've heard Mr Deli Angeli speak about
the three roundabouts that already exist
in Conway they're on the north south
road truck traffic isn't allowed in the
north south Road the only trucks that go
in there are the ones that go to
Hannaford's Lowe's Walmart maybe a few
others I can tell you from talking to
the store managers at each of those
locations that in aggregate that's 30 to
50 trucks a day not a thousand
so I don't think they're really
irrelevant comp
in fact that's pretty obvious that
they're not
safety when I talked to Mike Dugas at
the May meeting May 2022
I asked him I said why why do you like
the roundabout better he said they're
safe I said why you heard the gentleman
from the dot say today
rear end collisions people run the red
lights
every one of us have come to a traffic
light before when the light turns green
if you just go without verifying that
the traffic coming the other way hasn't
stopped shame on you
okay yes people do run red lights but
you know what look at a roundabout go to
any roundabout and see how many people
don't yield to the drivers that are
already in the roundabout when that
happens and I'm driving my 6 000 pound
pickup I can stop pretty quick
when the two gentlemen behind me here
that a driver is a drive in a rig that
weighs 140 000 pounds they're not going
to stop pretty quick
and that's the reality and what you'll
hear from one of the drivers is during
the demo he in fact got cut off and
Senator Bradley who was not here because
this is a house hearing was in his cab
and saw it and couldn't believe it so we
saw it real real life but I would
encourage you to look at the video of
the demo I shared that with commissioner
Cass it's available every one of you
should look at it I think it speaks
volumes you've heard Mr Deli Angeli say
that the trucks get around the
roundabout they do is that a definition
of success because the truck can get
around the roundabout at five miles an
hour
when you've got a thousand trucks that
are going to be going through this
roundabout a day all I ask is that you
look at the video you can see the
traffic back up in the video that was in
a controlled environment
okay and we heard about feedback from
the town and the selectment
the Selectmen are disinterested parties
for one reason
none of them live on the east Conway
Road
they don't have to deal with the traffic
none of them have businesses on the East
Conway Road they don't have to deal with
the issues that you're going to hear
some of these gentlemen talk about
and in Conway with a Conway Daily Sun
they do this thing called a teletub
where they ask the residents what they
think about an issue
the respondents from the tele talk on
the roundabout versus the traffic signal
in June I believe of 2021 is 63 of the
respondents favored a traffic signal
so
isn't that isn't that the town why are
five people who are disinterested
parties the town
I live on the east Conway Road I'm one
of those people that have to deal with
it
um let's see what are some of the other
things somebody asked the question about
budget
the design that's been put forth right
now for the roundabout is five hundred
thousand dollars more expensive than the
traffic signal I'm not making the number
up it's from Hoyle Tanner's presentation
if it's wrong well forgive me but that's
what they're saying five hundred
thousand dollars
um what are some of the other things
traffic the Hoyle Tanner presentation
for a traffic signal in 2022
the traffic for AM and PM was they use
letter grades b and a b
20 years projection forward 2042 be in a
b
for the roundabout 2022 b and a c
2042 b and a d the traffic was projected
to get worse
if that's factually incorrect I would
let these gentlemen rebut that but I'm
telling you what was in Hoyle Tanner's
presentation
uh what are some of the others
in terms of the public officials that
have spoken to it I talked to Chief
Maddie the police chief yesterday
I would say it's fair to say that he is
in favor of whatever is the safest what
he said to me and I I would welcome any
of you to reach out to him is that the
drivers of the experts they're the ones
that know what's going to be safer you
will hear from two of the drivers I
think it's critically important that you
hear from them the fire chief who
supported the roundabout has since
retired
the current fire chief whom I spoke with
personally is not a fan of roundabouts
and he was going to submit written
testimony through the general quote
website
whether he does or not
you can read it if he does
uh let's see
the public meeting
that we heard about with a D.O.T
solicited public input that's all we
read about they want public input public
input I attended the May meeting
one person at that meeting
favored the roundabout everybody else
favored a traffic signal
one person I was there representative
Woodcock was there
let's see
I could go on and on
I'd appreciate you take the time that
you need let's move yeah so I think my
point is
if you can make it big enough every one
of these gentlemen drivers business
owners
fire officials police officials have
said if it can be big enough
it'll work we pointed the D.O.T Mike
Dugas at the time to a roundabout in
Gorham Maine at Grande aggregates
that works these guys drive through it
plenty of time it works
if you cannot make it big enough
then put a traffic signal in that's all
we're asking because whatever you build
it's going to be there for our lifetime
and we have to live with it
thank you sir for your testimony are
there questions for the gentleman
please
I'm sorry I held the other room on the
beginning of your testimony but
is it traffic reasonably equal in both
directions no the track this
approximately thirteen thousand five
hundred Vehicles a day on route through
route 302 half of that on the East
Conway Road okay so there's two cars for
every one going through 302. I just I
just can't understand why
everybody will be satisfied if they put
up a spotlight at this intersection for
60 days
and see what the results are
and then
people can make up their own mind I just
don't understand that
you agree with that we agreed we agree
one of the gentlemen asked in about
rollovers don't you have a risk of a
rollover it may have been here sir when
you take the sharp turn they're taking
those turns now there's no light but
they're taking the turn they're not
rolling over what happens when you have
a center Mount trailer loaded with logs
that's extremely top heavy that's going
around a roundabout and someone cuts in
front of them then you're going to have
a roll open thank you for the new
representatives represent photography
was would you believe question which we
try and refrain from uh with testimony
thank you thank you sir for your thank
you testimony
foreign
like to recognize who came into the room
uh later uh representative Woodcock
please
thank you Mr chairman members of the
board my name is Steve Woodcock I live
on East Conway Road I'm also a
representative uh from Conway I'm
heading back to the education committee
shortly and I appreciate you taking me
Mark and uh to do for this
um
the process Jeb Bradley and I and Tom
here
two terms ago and talked about getting
something in the in the 10-year plan
because of the uh increasing amount of
accidents and deaths were there and the
board did that uh your group did that uh
there they went through the process they
went through the public hearing um I
would agree with with uh Fran that the
public hearing was uh uh limited support
uh represent uh resident wise in terms
of the roundabout uh but I would say in
all fairness D.O.T was up front on both
the statistics both their plans uh and
were right out front with it they
weren't lying and at the end of the
hearing the the folks who live on East
Colony Road pretty much were you know we
don't really give a damn what you do
just do something
that's the end of the result as things
have transpired in the demos I also sat
through the demos and wrote in one of
the trucks at the second demonstration
uh there's no question on the debt on
the roundabouts that they're using in
town now these vehicles except for
Jeff's uh lower right of these vehicles
uh are struggling to get through
struggling to get through
uh and I and I agree with that um that
that's not going to work I I would you
asked about the traffic backup at East
County Road oh yeah you can these truck
guys can be there
seven eight ten minutes I'm heading
behind him it's not happy
um because they can't get out because
the amount of cars going back and forth
and they were very clear at the hearing
that the t-boning and the accidents are
a lot more difficult at 40 miles an hour
and dangerous than they are at 15 around
round above
all that being said there was no
question that the roundabout in my mind
that the D.O.T and the engineer came
back with were not sufficient no
question however since that time I've
I've spoken with Paul uh as well as some
of the other people and the D in our DOT
uh and uh Paul who's now the uh was a
Tom engineer now Italian engineer and
assistant time manager has changed the
design has increased the design
that's the key Jeff asked that about
that before the truck I just want to be
safe they won't be able to get through
no matter how they go I don't care if
they go on a stoplight or a roundabout
it's going to be slow and they're
pulling all that weight everybody knows
that it's gonna be slow uh so I do I
just want to bring that to the point dot
came back and and we're back a year
folks this was supposed to be done this
may
we waited three years now so we've done
this may we've gone through two boards
and they're uh changing the design and
the bid time has cost us another year
uh so I do want to to complement a
Conley uh the D.O.T and Paul for
adjusting their uh plans from what they
had hoped to get until what they have
now so the the answer to my question is
is it big enough they tell us it will be
within your design to the truck is uh
going to be slow going through that
absolutely uh the car's going to slow
that absolutely
uh and I don't think the town can afford
waiting any longer some of you uh use
that road know how difficult it is uh
I'd be happy to take any questions uh I
came in to the first hearing without an
opinion I came into the second public
hearing uh without an opinion I live on
that road
we want something done and we just
wanted to be safe we wanted to
accommodate because as as uh
um Thomas when we first started they've
changed their first mile mile half two
and a half miles in that road right up
to the transfer station is commercial
but from there down for the next four
miles is relatively residential except
the gazillion driveways there with
people in canoes trying to get into the
river but the reality is that last half
a mile uh from the from the with the
last stop down by the police station and
the railroad tracks to the corner uh
islow is back up is dangerous and it's
dangerous for these guys trying to get
their rigs out and it's dangerous for
the public going by on East County Road
I think the town has acquiesced in my
opinion to the driver's concerns and
they're guaranteed that they'll make a
roundabout to fits do the town residents
want the surround about no
they want the stoplight because that's
what they're convinced about but they
have not seen the big one and I think we
have to have a a agreement here what's
going to work for both if you have the
stoplights clear not gonna be as good as
the roundabout for the traffic for the
guys so that that's my my thank you
thank you representative are there
questions for the representative
seeing none thank you you're welcome
thank you gentlemen
we have uh three more cards
um and I just want to remind you that I
have six minutes and I don't want to
stymie your input but if if we need to
run the 15 minutes for each and probably
after the first Speaker going to recess
out of this hearing so to be heard later
in the day
uh with that I would like to hear from
committee would like to hear from Mr
William
doggle
welcome thank you
I was uh
my name is William Dodd I work for Berks
I was one of the drivers
in the roundabouts I haul heavy
equipment
um I support this
um the biggest concern I have obviously
with everybody else's safety
but I go through that intersection every
day of my life
I weigh anywhere between 120 and 160 000
pounds
the dot brought up the thing about
manufactured homes their axles are
halfway down that manufactured hole I'm
81 feet long and my axles are at the end
I cannot take Corners like people think
I can whether it's an intersection or a
roundabout
I'm going to be slow going through it
um
our equipment's only getting bigger
and like I said I don't care if they put
a roundabout
it's just got to be a lot bigger and a
lot stronger
because of while I'm hauling over it the
other three roundabouts we have in town
I cannot get a permit to go over it the
only reason we were on that roundabout
is to do this demonstration to make sure
we could go over it when both trucks I
was in the first one the other truck was
behind me went through that we did have
a traffic backup
so I just want you to realize that
this intersection is a unique
intersection
and
I I just think you have to take notice
of a lot more than what you are
and that's thank you thank you William
um is there anyone with questions
and just
um
for a short myself I'm very familiar
with this I'm very familiar with the
with your organization and the others
that travel through every day thank you
thank you
um Todd Bryant please I believe
Todd welcome to Public Works
Todd Bryant
owner of Todd Bryant's Trucking Heavy
Hauling Company
it basically
it needs the roundabout is going to be
need to be bigger or you know a
stoplight
um the wear and tear on our trucks and
there's more than
every company on that road has a low bed
and there's a lot of guys coming out of
there 120 140 like Bill said
every day I bet there's at least two or
three loads coming out of there like
that
and
basically the wear and tear is I bet
double on our equipment and just the
damage to the like the truck apron
um cars throughout that demonstration
you can see the bricks all broke broken
out of that round about that was used
for the demonstration
which um
you know that's just one of my concerns
and also when you come into a roundabout
with a tractor trailer
you can't see especially if you're 14
feet wide if somebody comes in behind
you because you have to swing wide to
get around these curbs they put in
if somebody hooks into the back of your
trailer you're not going to even feel
them
you're going to drag them all around the
corner or until you do actually see them
um
but that's basically yep thank you thank
you Ms Bryant any questions Mr Bryant
yes please thank you chip so I thank you
um is I probably should ask this
question earlier is the traffic
at that present intersection
more pronoun is is there more traffic in
the summer
with with the tourism and people the
temporary residents as opposed to maybe
this time of year as much yes for sure
skiing okay yep it's a very busy
intersection thank you thank you
representative Juris representative
Patterson please
um in your opinion would you prefer
having a traffic signal there or a large
roundabout
my opinion would be a traffic signal
thank you thank you
seeing no further questions thank you
sir thank you our last card and the
people that are here for
um
House Bill
456 will be delayed here uh five minutes
or so my last speaker is uh is uh Kathy
Garland representing North Conway
incinerator service
good morning
good morning welcome to public works
thank you
um I'm Kathy Garland I own North Conway
incinerator service I'm also a truck
driver myself
um we've had the business for 45 years
and have been on East Conway Road
for probably the last 35
the problem
that we run into as the other guys do
know our trucks are not that long but
you've got uh people that are of course
impatient at the intersections they're
going to be that way whether regardless
of what's there
um human nature is everybody's go go go
and I just feel that with the
um
I'll support whatever goes in I'm happy
you know we've got to resolve the
problem that is there serious but
um with the light at least there is some
semblance of order
or more so uh yes people are going to
run a light
but
you're stopped it's I just feel that's
it's a better a better way to go with
the light at least give it a try
what's 30 more days UH 60 more days
that's how I feel thank you thank you
for your testimony any questions
thank you one and all thank you uh
before I close the hearing I would just
make a request to the department uh
Schoenberg can you provide us with the
documentation here
um one being the roundabout that the
test was run on one which was your
initial design for this roundabout your
updated and what a signalized
intersection would look like if you
could provide that for us in the next
few days I think that would be very
helpful for uh for the committee
thank you sir
with that I will close uh house bill
480.
so so I will have to
I want to call this Committee hearing to
order on House Bill 456 and I will call
upon the prime sponsor representative
Michael Vose in favor
thank you Mr chairman
and good morning to all the members
the record I'm rep representative
Michael those I represent Rockingham
District Five one of two representatives
from District Five
the other is Committee Member
representative mark vallone
we represent together the town of Epping
and I'm here this morning to introduce
House Bill 4 5 6.
a bill that takes a small step forward
in the direction of solving a problem
that I know this committee has been
grappling with for a year or better
and that is the problem of how to
make sure that everyone pays their fair
share to maintain roads and bridges
around the state of New Hampshire
I have prepared a brief written
testimony which I have distributed and
is circulating around the table
thank you for doing that representative
you're welcome just to help you remember
what this bill is about
after this hearing is is
in your memory banks and you can't quite
remember what it's about it's a one
pager here that'll help jog your memory
so what does this bill do this bill
authorizes the collection
of the equivalent of the of a gallon of
gas tax on
the amount of electricity that would be
equivalent to that gallon of gas
so
right now we all pay somewhere between
18 and 20 cents
when we buy a gallon of gas
this bill would authorize the collection
of that 18 to 20 cents for an amount of
electricity to charge an electric
vehicle that's equivalent to a gallon of
gas
that amount is 34 kilowatt hours
so for every 34 kilowatt hours of
electricity dispensed through a
separately metered
electric vehicle charging station
the utility could would be authorized to
collect that 18 to 20 cents
for every 34 kilowatt hours
now a typical electric car battery only
holds about 51 kilowatt hours so the
amount of tax we're talking about on
electric vehicle charge is only about 30
cents
so this is simply a opportunity
to allow our electric vehicle owning
citizens
to do what I'm sure they all want to do
which is contribute funds to the
maintenance of the roads and bridges
that we all use and enjoy
that's all the bill does
and it's a a fairly simple and
straightforward process
I know that it's probably not the
ultimate solution to this problem
the number of electric vehicles on the
roads in New Hampshire today for example
is only about 6 000 cars so it's not
going to generate a lot of Revenue
and in fact it may not even generate
enough Revenue to make make the whole
process worthwhile but I wanted to give
you here in this committee the
opportunity to evaluate whether this is
something worth doing or not and that's
why I have proposed this bill
uh I won't go into much more detail than
that but I'm happy to take any questions
from the committee
thank you representative votes any
questions representative Jack please
thank you Mr chairman and I thank the
illustrious chair of the sde committee
uh it isn't clear from the bill who is
going to actually uh pay the tax
I did look at 236 colon 132 it does
Define
uh what a what a electronic vehicle
charging station is but it isn't totally
clear to me from the bill who's going to
remit the tax
that is probably a weakness of this bill
my intention was that the utilities
would would collect since they uh
distribute and monitor and uh meter the
electricity they would collect the tax
or apply the tax to the amount of the
elector the price of the electricity
that was dispensed through the meter
but I did not uh when OLS drafted this
bill they did not uh
make that clear in in the bill drafting
so that's an issue that the committee
would have to address if you wanted to
go forward with this bill
do you representative representative
Jack other questions representative
votes please okay uh representative
Newton please
yes thank you uh for taking my question
how would this work at an individual's
house if an individual was charging
their vehicle with just a 20 amp service
how would you charge
what you would need to charge for
charging the car
thank you for the question
it's a good question and the answer is
there would have to be a separate meter
on that charging station in order for
this tax to be applied to that
particular EV charge
since most homes don't have a separate
meter on their electric vehicle charging
station they would not be this this tax
would not be applicable to them
some utilities such as New Hampshire
Electric Co-op I believe utility Unitil
as well do allow separate meters on your
electric vehicle charging station so
that if you wanted for example to keep
track of how much you're spending on
charging your car you could do so and in
that case if there's a meter there that
could track that electricity then the
attacks can be applied but if there's no
meter then no tax can no tax can be
applied
thank you chair thank you representative
so we could just from the previous
answer
one way to do this at home was to to
possibly compel homeowners to install
the media
um and that you kind of explained that
in paragraph five of your
of
your sheet here which is a which is
helpful and then the public stations the
next paragraph the utility would collect
the tax in aggregate
is that is that the intention in both
cases if there was a a meter a separate
meter applied to an EV charging station
at your home the tax could still be
applied there it doesn't have to be
public it can be a private meter
in fact many of the meters that you'll
see in various places around the state
are not public they're private like
charging stations at uh at uh Wentworth
Douglas hospital where my wife works I
happen to know
um that those are for the use of
employees only so it's it's a it's a pub
it's a semi-public I guess you would say
charging station but not entirely public
but as long as it's metered it could be
app that the tax could be applicable
uh whether it's public or private or
semi-public
just briefly follow up so the parking
garage down the street here on Green
Street or it went with Douglas we could
install meters and then the utility
would be responsible for collecting that
tax
theoretically
the utility would always be responsible
for collecting the tax and remanding it
to the state
any of the case okay thank you yes thank
you
of Representative Mo of owes
further questions from the committee any
I do not see any hands raised okay thank
you very much for your testimony
representative votes thank you to the
members
okay I now call upon representative Mark
McConkey who's another one of the
co-sponsors in support of the bill
thank you Mr chairman illustrious
members of the great Public Works and
highways committee
uh I had started down the road of a
separate piece of legislation uh to
address a short-term
way to capture some of the revenue that
we're not receiving at this point in
time for the newer members electric cars
aren't paying the road toll and in a
meeting with representative I mean how
how could I continue on without letting
Science and Technology go there so that
that is why this is here
um we I we were coming
um
I was chairman of the commission that
you folks all were kind enough to
continue for next year and we'll go back
in Earnest on on what we're going to do
to uh to get fees for road toll for
these alternative uh forms of
Transportation uh electric and hybrid
and so forth and there were members in
that committee thought that we shouldn't
wait until that commission is done and
that we should get something in now that
would start the process it may not be
the end-all but we are hoping
that you would give this due
consideration and
um and I'm here in support of of this
proposal
thank you representative McConkey
questions of Representative McConkey
from the committee please
any questions uh yes representative
Faulkner please thank you for taking the
question I I'm still troubled by the
concept of separately meeting if it's a
commercial
station out on the highway obviously
they're going to be separate from any
other
user but you know employer provided or a
landlord provided or individually
provided why would anybody ever put a
separate meter and in which case aren't
we missing
a huge part of the of the target uh
base to pay this pay this tax
thank you representative for the
question
um
we are we this is not an end-all and we
are missing
um uh revenue and other collection
points I I believe that um
I believe that that this is a start to
that process one of the biggest issues
to date when we have tried to
capture Revenue Source from electric
vehicles more so than hybrid is that the
automobile dealers and the people that
purchase their cars have always been
very resistant in what we can do I think
this is one of I believe there's a
Senate Bill also that I'm on
um so I I think in the the end I think
the committee will probably have to look
at several bills and decide which is the
best method to go forward
thank you representative Faulkner
representative McConkey further
questions of Representative McConkey
from the committee police
any further uh yes representative Jairus
please
thank you Vice chair and chairman thank
you thank you for testifying today
would it be a possibility in in this
proposed legislation to incentivize
homeowners or property managers uh
business owners to install the meters
have has that have you or representative
Rose thought of that
um thank you for the question
um we ourselves uh have not had that
conversation I can't speak for represent
both
thank you uh okay any other questions
from representative McConkey from the
committee any other questions seen on
thank you representative McConkey
I will now call upon uh I think and I'm
hopefully I'm right is it Sam Evans
Brown of New Hampshire clean energy in
opposition to the bill okay good thank
you welcome to Public Works and highways
thank you for having me
for the record I'm Sam Evans Brown I'm
the executive director of clean energy
New Hampshire we're a 51c3 non-profit
and also we are the conveners of a
stakeholder group called Drive Electric
New Hampshire which consists of many
state agencies as well as electric
vehicle charging infrastructure
installers and developers
um and I I think I want to start my
testimony by saying that uh for years
our organization and our supporters
would have opposed any suggestion that
Electric Vehicle drivers need to be
contributing to into the highway fund
and and I think that I have come to the
conclusion that that position does in
fact need to change and needs to change
sooner rather than later and the
anecdote that I've been sharing to sort
of illustrate that point is that last
year during the Super Bowl there were
five ads for electric vehicles so these
vehicles really are ready for the
mainstream and we should be planning for
how we're going to integrate them into
into our grid into our economy and how
we're going to figure out how we're
going to pay for roads and bridges once
that becomes the norm I do however have
concerns about this bill
you should have in your inboxes
testimony from from some charging
providers who will tell you that as it
stands there is an enormous amount of
capital that is looking for places to
invest in electric vehicle charging but
in New Hampshire in particular and in
many rural places there is not a
business case as it stands the trouble
is that there just aren't enough cars on
the road yet and so it's it's a money
losing Endeavor to invest particularly
in fast charging which means that if
we're going to
several members of the committee have
noted these separately metered language
in this bill which which is going to
capture a very small portion of the
charging that's happening 80 percent of
charging happens at home most of that
charging is not on separate meters so
what we're talking about is public
charging we're talking about mostly fast
charging and we're talking about a a
business a business case that currently
is nascents uh and is and is uh and
currently not viable in most parts of of
New Hampshire because of the low levels
of penetration so the the trouble here
is that if we're adding additional fees
and taxes onto a business that is
currently not viable what we're going to
see is that there won't be private
investment in electric vehicle charging
infrastructure in the state of New
Hampshire which has a real potential to
hamper uh our efforts to continue to
have a viable tourist industry in the
state of New Hampshire
um by 2030 it's forecast they're going
to be 3 million EVS on the road between
Southern Southern New England and Quebec
and both Maine and Vermont have robust
programs to invest in public charging
and we are far behind both of those
States so the question that you have to
ask yourselves is where will those
tourists go uh if there's no charges in
the state of New Hampshire so uh I think
that personally that their will in the
future ba role for some sort of fee like
the one that we're discussing for this
bill once there are enough vehicles on
the road that there is a business model
for public charging and the Chargers get
built and then they have a and then and
then we can talk about how those those
tourists visiting New Hampshire can
contribute to the highway fund I just
think the time for that is not is not
now
um I in the testimony that I just
emailed to the committee uh slightly
late because I spent about a half hour
wrestling with a printer this morning so
I apologize that you don't have written
testimony in front of you but I did
email it to the committee as I was
sitting in the back there are two bills
advancing including one that is uh is
prime sponsored by the chair that I
think are more reasonable approaches to
trying to solve this issue in the short
term
um and then I think the question of how
to how to ensure that tourists visiting
the state are contributing to the
highway fund is one that can be figured
out in the sort of the medium term over
you know between 2020 2025 and 2030. so
with that I'll conclude my remarks take
any questions thank you Mr Evans Brown
questions of Mr Evans Brown from the
committee yes go ahead please
representative
thank you
um the question
um
how do we Finance the installation of
all these charges and stuff uh do we
charge the current taxpayers the current
Highway fund do we uh because if we
don't have a way of charging the
electric vehicle the EV person they're
getting a free ride on a system that
everybody else is paying for so now
we're subsidizing them
to buy something that everybody else has
to pay for them to use is that what I'm
hearing are you asking how with regard
to the highway fund or with regard to
electric vehicle charging infrastructure
in general all of it because it all
comes down to the same thing someone's
got to pay for it and who do you
envision see and pay for
it
there's a a it's a question I think
really calls out for a nuanced and
comprehensive solution
um that that will probably involve a
number of different approaches
personally I think that most EV drivers
should be should be paying in at the
time of registration of their vehicle in
in into a fund that goes into the into
the highway fund that does that does cry
out though what what is it how are
tourists then paying for the wear and
tear that they cause on their roads
which I think then does Point towards
having some sort of fee that is added
onto public charging the trouble is a
chicken and egg one which is that we
need the infrastructure to ensure that
the tourists keep coming to New
Hampshire and uh and if a fee is going
to result in us not building the
infrastructure then the tourists aren't
going to come to New Hampshire
um and and so I think that's that's the
that's the question that that I think we
need to solve and and I would argue it
argues for a phased approach in which we
we phase in these type types of these
types of fees as used as the user base
grows and as the as the business model
becomes becomes one that can be
stabilized and is a little more certain
in the interim in the beginning I I
personally believe this is a problem
that really calls out for one-time
funding as a as a stopgap measure and
there are some pots of money that are
that are already allocated to that so
the the diesel gate fund um is going to
to build some fast charging
um in in rural places in New Hampshire
and that's I think uh five million
dollars total and Des is here so I they
can speak they can speak to that but
also the nevi fund which is the national
electric vehicle infrastructure program
that was part of the bipartisan
infrastructure law that is 17 million
dollars over five years that will also
pay for fast charging but I will State
uh both of those those programs
may still struggle to attract private
investment because of the rate structure
that we have here in New Hampshire which
uh you know I I uh I won't board the
committee talking about utility rate
structures but if you have not heard
about the the troubles that demand
charges uh uh um represent for for
electric vehicle fast charging it's a
major impediment to attracting private
investment and it's something that that
the Public Utilities Commission is is
currently in the midst of wrestling with
as we speak
okay
I think about Mr Evans Brown
any other questions
okay thank you
all right thank you I apologize
on representative Timothy Horrigan in
opposition to the bill
I am representative Timothy Horrigan I'm
from Stratford County District 10 which
is the town of Durham and um
I'm not an EV user myself I drove here
in a stinky old gas guzzling Volvo
station wagon a
the electric vehicle enthusiasm was
trying to refer to those as ice
um
ice internal combustion engine so um
and uh but I do think EVS are the wave
of the future and there is indeed a
chicken to the egg problem that uh we
need to build out a network of public
public charging uh charging stations
both and that'll probably have to be in
the government funded at first or
subsidized um the the free market can't
do its magic if the infrastructure for
the market doesn't exist and um
New Hampshire is a lot to offer to
tourists from other states but they
can't get to our interstates on they
can't get to our wonderful liquor stores
on the interstate of
if they if they're afraid they won't be
able to get home because they can't find
anywhere to charge their car you know
they're not going to stay in our ski
resorts even with the rooms and meals
taxed lowered from nine to 8.5 or
whoever we did to it you know they're
not going to do our tax-free shopping or
anything or if cheaper cigarettes or any
of buyers cheaper cigarettes or any any
of that if they don't think they can get
home and I think there's a lot of range
anxiety for electric vehicle owners um
and
so I think certainly uh this tax would
be be um imposed on public charging
stations and although there really isn't
I don't know if a good way to do it it
uh does that with where richer people
who can afford their own fast charging
uh would not be taxed and uh I mean I
guess that does
um divert funds from the middle class
you know to the rich people those job
creators who are always eager to lure
away from other states but still that's
um a perverse incentive in my opinion
and finally I want to point out that
even though
and not to get two pointers in here and
of course this is your bill and this
committee is always running very
nonpartisan fashion but all the sponsors
of this bill they're all Republicans
mostly some of the mostly very
conservative Republicans so I find it a
little bit surprising that they're
contemplating
imposing a new tax so this is a um
this is a news tax and even as you know
a more liberal more Progressive Democrat
in the house um I think I don't think we
should be imposing new taxes unless
they're structured right and they you
know in a progressive way with useful
incentives and this one this is a
regressive tax the incentives are all
wrong and so this is
um not the time not the time to impose
this tax especially not just on the
public charging stations which we're
having you know we need to build out a
network of those and uh we're having a
lot of trouble uh
doing that so I
so I would uh I would say I was
respectfully your state committee uh not
to move forward with this bill this year
although at some point we'll have to
find a way of
making EVS contribute to the road toll
and that will involve a new tax but I
don't think this is the right new tax to
do it
um so
that's that's all I have to say I'd be
happy to take any questions should
anyone have any thank you representative
Horrigan any questions of Representative
Horrigan from the committee uh yes
representative Juris please thank you
Vice chair thank you representative
Horrigan thanks for uh stopping in today
the testimony maybe I should ask earlier
to Sam Evans is this
state
has property
to locate
charging stations I mentioned rest stops
by ways off of us you know a state road
up north we were just talking about
route 302 do we know of any
incentivization that I'm assuming that
we would charge
we would make could possibly make a deal
with investors to come in and maybe for
a rental rate that's a little more cost
effective uh to maybe start a program
like that to incentivize these investors
that come in has any been any thought on
that and then if if we had the tax we
could if we had to do it if we had to
demand charge on the meter we could
install that at the same time
um I mean it's
I mean I think that's still a
disincentive having this taxed on top of
top of everything certainly um I mean
I mean there are not just rest stops but
lots of public facilities where uh EV
stations could be installed for the
public and also of course State vehicles
are moving to the public so we have
we're going to have EV like I'm sure
we'll soon we probably already have them
but we'll soon have EV stations like
like over in Hazen Drive there's
currently a natural gas filling station
I'm sure pretty soon
that dot will put in a EV station in
places like that so there's and you can
also do public private Partnerships as I
suppose you're thinking other states
have lots of them at shopping centers
and so forth and actually even the Tesla
and I'm not a big Elon Musk fan but he
he's uh
he's kind of subsidized his Chargers and
although they're only good for people
who drive his random automobiles most of
those are sort of located on land that
he's leasing from public uh
from public property owners like uh but
so I mean I'm not I'm not the expert on
it but that's something that's something
you can consider but I'm not sure if
this bill will really
this particular bill is not really a
good vehicle for moving forward with it
and um
certainly sure in the future it will be
like uh and of course soon it'll be like
gasoline where the you know they have
filling pumps and from every convenience
store and part of that
part of that is so like they know a
certain percentage of people come in and
buy like a Coke or a hot dog or whatever
so that I'm sure eventually once the
technology becomes more ubiquitous so
that'll be they'll have those EV
stations and all those convenience
stores too but that's
that's something that's not going to
happen spontaneously or right away but
anyways I don't know this bill is useful
for that effort but you can consider it
thanks it's
got it thank you representative thank
you thank you representative Juris
representative Horrigan further
questions of Representative Horrigan
from the committee uh yes uh please uh
I'm sorry represented I bear with me
boys thank you thank you you're welcome
thank you Mr Vice chairman I appreciate
it and representative hurricane thank
you for taking my question
if
if you testify that you object to the
the partisan Nation nature of the bill
accepting that but also taking
government subsidies out of the equation
what would be a solution that you would
propose for this committee's
consideration that would begin to
address the problem that would equitably
manage all the vehicles that are using
the roads in our state thank you well
I'm I'm not on TV it's just hitting this
bill and that a lot of those are issued
for ways and beans or some other
committee well I guess it's I guess it's
been the ear purview I mean I think
I think eventually we'll probably have
to move to charging people per mile and
I know that's a new fee and people won't
like that but have that registry maybe
registration time you have to State your
mileage and I mean there's a lot of
problems with that like verifying that
your mileage is correct and so forth but
I'm uh I'm not wedded to any principle
and also like
as like eventually if EVS dominate the
landscape the whole Marketplace we could
probably just calculate what percentage
of uh electricity is being used for the
vehicles and then
have the electric you know take that out
of the electric bills that again is a
of course that's another new tax and
electricity is too expensive anyway but
um those are those are just the ideas
off the top of my head but it's pretty
much up
probably up to you guys more than me to
like sort that out and I'm not sure if
you're able to sort that out uh you know
in the next couple of weeks but thanks
thank you for your candidate thank you
Mr fisherman
thank you represent bully representative
Horrigan further questions of
Representative Corrigan from the
committee
seeing none again thank you for your
testimony
okay I will now call upon and you did
not indicate a position of the bill Mr
Michael Fitzgerald I assume it's from
the New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services you have no
position but you want to testify to us
for three minutes welcome to Public
Works and highways yes good morning Mr
chair my name is Michael Fitzgerald I'm
the assistant director of the uh air
Resources Division at the Department of
Environmental Services our division is
charged with uh uh Environmental Policy
uh that includes
administration of the Volkswagen funds
uh that were previously mentioned for
providing for charging and for uh
General promotion of electric vehicles
um in terms of their uh positive
environmental impacts and so I'd just
like to make a couple of very quick
points as you noted we do not take a
position on the bill
several of the points that I was going
to raise have been raised already by
members I the members of the committee
or those testifying before me we have
long taken a position that
electric vehicles should pay a fair
portion of the road toll and that they
should there should be an equitable way
to uh to determine that and I think
directionally this bill
um uh heads in that direction
appropriately by by looking at charging
they're just a couple of issues that I'd
like to highlight
one as was noted most charging occurs at
home and it's not separately separately
metered
second even public charging a lot of it
is not separately metered a lot of it is
at commercial buildings shopping centers
uh there's some on State uh you know at
at rest areas
um et cetera you'll you'll note down in
Hooksett
um but uh there are some restraints on
on the use of State uh some State
Properties but
um those by uh by and large many of
those are not separately metered and it
would be a significant expense to put in
a a separate meter as was noted some
utilities do encourage separate meters
for EVS the intent of that is to take
advantage of time of use rates so that
you can charge your car at a lower rate
come in and charge it at night when when
the cost of electricity may be lower and
utilities can offer a special rate
for that
this might sort of offset that but I do
think that there is a solution that is
necessary this is a complex and thorny
problem as has been noted there's been
several commissions over the past few
years and this committee has wrestled
with this issue we do think that a
solution is necessary and that the EVS
should pay their fair share
um and that that it if to be Equitable
it should be you know perhaps mileage
based or or as I say this bill seems to
directionally go the right way in terms
of converting the electricity use into
into uh motor vehicle usage
you know equivalent gallon of gas
um and
um the uh we also agree that it's
important to capture uh road toll from
vehicles coming into the state
um and that that
um again directionally this bill would
would do that I would note that uh as
representative McConkey uh noted that
the bill there is a bill in the Senate
um that would introduce a 50 surcharge
on electric vehicles and I believe that
bill was amended actually to uh to a
hundred dollars
um and it passed out of committee last
week this this week actually so that'll
probably be coming this way as well I
think there are several several
potential Vehicles we're happy to
provide uh
provide input and um
I think that that pretty much covers the
um the territory that I wanted to
to address I'd be happy to try to take
any questions on our efforts relative to
public charging infrastructure and so on
if the committee has any desire
thank you Mr Fitzgerald any questions of
Mr Fitzgerald from the committee
representative Boyd police
thank you Mr Vice chairman and Mr Cheryl
thank you for your testimony and I'm
going to apologize up to you in advance
I don't know if you're going to be able
to answer this question but it just kind
of struck me having read the bill but
the language includes output of
electricity it takes to equal the energy
content of one gallon do you happen to
know what what numerically that output
of energy is that would equal I don't uh
happen to know that off the top of my
head but it is you know I mean there is
a measure of you know
100 000 BTUs per gallon or something
like that and and so there can be a
direct equivalence
um you have you do have to account for
the efficiency of an electric engine and
and those sort of things
um uh but I believe what the build tasks
it tests the department of safety
um to to you know determine that
calculation and and we'd certainly be
more than willing to uh and ready to
assist them to do that I appreciate that
thank you thank you Mr Vice chairman
thank you representative Boyd further
questions of Mr Fitzgerald from the
committee
any further questions okay thank you Mr
thank you for your testimony
okay I will now call upon uh Miss
Jennifer Hall from the uh New Hampshire
Department of safety's road toll Bureau
please and I notice again you have
indicated no position on the bill but uh
we welcome you coming in and speaking to
the bill
thank you
um we are neutral we
agree that you know the majority of the
consumption from Electric Vehicle users
is from their home charging
um
the gallon equivalency that was just
being discussed would have to be
determined by our department so
taking that into consideration and the
need to develop changes to our current
forms and our current software we would
need at least a six month lead time in
order to implement this bill so request
that we push the effective date out
accordingly
um
and additionally the current language in
259 3D that defines alternative fuel
explicitly excludes electricity from the
definition of an alternative fuel so we
would need to amend that RSA as well to
implement this change
okay is that your testimony all right
okay thank you representative Jack
please yeah thank you Mr chairman uh can
you suggest what a an effective date
that you would be comfortable with
assuming that we're that we did an
amendment uh January 1st of 24 would be
ideal that's assuming you know that this
bill wouldn't be passed until later on
this year and we would need a six-month
lead
representative Jack uh further questions
uh yes okay go ahead please uh
representative Bogart uh just a real
quick what was that RSA that needed to
get updated because of the definitions
259 3D
thank you representative Bogart for the
question yes I'm Jairus please thank you
Mr Vice chair Jennifer you're at the
D.O.T and you're in the business of
collecting road tolls as it is right now
with fossil fuel cars correct yeah I'm
at Department of Safety Department of
Safety uh
okay
has there been any discussion on how to
do this in your department by getting
more EV Chargers out there and me
possibly metering them so we can collect
more road toll as everyone's aware it's
a Hot Topic across the country and we
attend several conferences
um you know we're we're working with the
fuel Tax Administration and the
international fuel Tax Administration
to try to you know figure out the best
way to handle this a lot of discussion
about charging a mileage-based user fee
um
we don't have a suggestion for the best
solution at this point
okay thank you thank you representative
Juris further questions please
any further questions
okay all right thank you very much for
your testimony thank you
I will now call upon uh Mr and Andre and
I'm sorry for Mr Bria I guess you're the
assistant command I'm sorry if I
mispronounced your last name that's okay
because of my last time today so okay
good and I notice you have indicated
your support for the bill so welcome to
public
thank you again uh members of the
committee uh yeah uh nhdot
um oh I'm sorry again Andre Brier Deputy
Commissioner nhdot uh speaks in support
of the measure we're generally
supportive as you heard in my earlier
testimony today of any measure that
helps address the long-term structural
deficit of our Highway fund this is one
uh approach
um in front of you you will also see a
letter of support from Mr uh James
jalbert who's the chairman of the New
Hampshire
Transportation Council
as he points out there's also an hdot's
position this is a step in the right
direction different states have taken
different approaches uh generally
between some sort of uh some sort of
measure like this that's similar to a
road toll some states have approached it
in terms of registration fees as you
heard from previous testimonies also
being considered by this body or by the
uh by the other body of the legislature
uh this approach does have the advantage
of acting like a road toll in that uh it
does allow out-of-staters tourists to
contribute to our highways we're
supportive of that approach
um not necessarily to the exclusion of a
registration fee which we also support
again we support any measure in general
that goes toward closing the Gap in loss
of Highway fund Revenue
and I won't reiterate other points but
you know all first steps uh tend to be
uh imperfect this one certainly is
because as you've heard in previous
testimony it does not account for most
of the home charging at least as it
currently stands in the future that may
change but at least it would start us on
the path of ensuring Equitable uh
contributions to our Highway fund
and that saw that concludes my testimony
and standing by for any questions
all right thank you for your testimony
Mr Deputy Commissioner any questions of
the Deputy Commissioner for members of
the committee
any questions all right representation
thank you Vice chair uh so Deputy
Commissioner in agreement with more road
tolls so we can keep maintaining the
highways to the state roads doing things
like drainage uh uh pavement markings
guard rails Etc
do any thoughts in your department or
where to place more charges
on state property in areas where
tourists go or there are heavily
trafficked so as you can collect more
road toll to help fill the the budget
for maintenance and improvements and and
uh and the like that you mentioned in
your testimony
well thank you thank you for that
question there there are restrictions on
our on our ability to use state property
for this type of thing
um that that's something I testify to uh
in the other body when we were talking
about uh registration fees
um generally speaking uh
private
the you know these types of chargers
that are placed on private property
whether it's funded by us or others or
privately funded
you know can can serve that role you can
extract a a road toll-like fee from
those uh from those EV Chargers
um you've heard under separate testimony
here A whole lot of different efforts
that are going on in our state to uh to
improve accessibility in the number of
chargers that exist here and those
efforts are ongoing both by our
department and the other departments
represented here
if I could just do a brief follow-up so
follow-up please continue in the case of
it was mentioned earlier there's there's
a Motor Vehicle Manufacturer on on
that's got charging stations on Route 93
on both sides and there are plazas there
where you can stop you can eat you can
buy uh products
how's that working out do we charge that
manufacturer rent does a state charge
them rent and then on top of that
a usage fee for electricity and those
meters they're not currently needed
right now are they
I would have to get back to you on that
on that particular location sir
um each each location tends to be a
little bit different as you've heard in
previous testimony some The Meters
separate some The Meters with the
facility itself so each is slightly
different but if you do have a a
specific question we're happy to get
back to you so for as far as investors
go you could engage investors that we've
got these properties and there's State
Properties put these charging stations
up maybe make an incentive a deal for
the first few years and then put your
meters on those charges so as you can
collect road toll to help with the
maintenance budget
yeah I think as you heard Mr Evans Brown
testified too there's a there's a phased
uh intention here that some of what
you're describing will come to pass
trying to construct a business model
that that is attractive to Private
Industry is part of the part of the
thing that that Most states are working
on right now and and trying to figure
out what that model looks like
thank you thank you representative Juris
further questions
uh yes of the Deputy go ahead please
representative thank you thanks
uh if I do my calculations correctly it
seems like even if we
tax every kilowatt that a electric
vehicle uses
they traveled 12 000 miles a year which
I think you said it was the average
they're going to pay about 25 dollars
right now a gas burning vehicle 25 miles
a gallon pays about a hundred so
if collecting a hundred dollars per
vehicle isn't enough
oh we're only collecting a quarter of
that through this vehicle taxes so um
question is whether this is really a
long-term solution or or whether um
we really see this as kind of the first
step and something else has to be done
to solve the problem
yeah I think the exact shape of this how
it how it develops Nationwide is is
really in flux right now I mean you see
some states experimenting with with one
the other both
and the Laboratories of democracy are
are kind of taken off right now and and
we'll see what sticks but uh certainly
this is this is one approach that that
several states are taking
um and that's not again we wouldn't
testify that this should happen to the
exclusion of a vehicle registration fee
but it's one of the other options
foreign thank you representative
Faulkner for the questions of the Deputy
Commissioner from the committee any
further questions
okay I see none uh thank you very much
for your testimony Mr Deputy
Commissioner
not have any more pink cards is there
anybody else uh who did not uh who wants
to testify for or against but if you
wish to testify if you haven't submitted
a pink card already if you could please
do so
I do not see anybody in the audience so
feelings
thank you everybody we will be in uh we
have our next hearing at 11
on House Bill 110.
hello how are you good to see you
on the 14th to provide us with his uh
with his budget
uh we're looking we're looking to
preserve the week off that the if we
don't have business we don't have to be
here uh the end of the end of the month
so we're looking and these will be all
day presentations February 24th
hearing from agencies hearing from
agencies again on March 6 which we're
coming back after that vacation
March 10th hearing from
from
agencies
uh we have a process I need to bring
that forward here
so March 13th
March 15th 17th and 20th to get through
our executive sessions so
um Chris Shea is uh or is providing a
lot of input and going between his
duties and working in ways and means in
ours so there's a little bit of flux
here what agencies will come on those
days but I just wanted you to have
um have that so you could start planning
and you know be aware of the fact that
that may change also
yes
um many of the um
no later than 10 and actually several
will start at nine o'clock the the idea
is to try and get through as many as we
can during the day we also have a
request from the Department of Education
to do a site visit to a building they're
hoping to lease just down the road here
and so at some point in time we'll work
that in
they want us to come by and see that we
have a full schedule today
but I I wanted to um uh remind everyone
and I went back to the clerk uh Mr Smith
to ask to make sure I had the right
understanding uh house rule 44 B permits
the chair and ranking member to agree to
hold an executive session after a public
hearing or to dispose of it I'd ask the
question just because we we have had a
lot of naming bills and we've been
followers following that procedure so I
just wanted everyone to be aware that we
might get to something today that we we
can exec but of course I will need to be
uh
in agreement with the uh the ranking
member to do that
the
I should have another paper here I
wanted to speak and then I'll let you go
so you have a few minutes
and I'm afraid with the Clutter I don't
have it so enjoy your freedom for a few
minutes yes representative Abbott
I'd be happy to
yep
I wanted to give you one John I think
you already have them
uh February um in which month
March March 6th
March 10th
March 13th
March 15th
17th and 20.
could be
24th
so I'll leave I'll leave a list here and
everyone can take a look and it's it
like it's still in a little bit of flux
yes representative uh just to throw
something out there that I
since it's been built I don't think this
this committee has gone on any kind of a
tour of the women's prison the newly
development facility oh we have we have
representative yes did I miss that
um I think it was prior to your coming
onto the committee
but I'm I'm I'm I'm willing to go look
at any facility
um with a sufficient time to go uh
perhaps we could ask for an update of
where they are with it I've been several
times during construction grand opening
the once after but I've heard that it
may not be
wearing well with the test of time and
it might be valuable oh sure okay
yes we did yes yep okay so I I'm
we will put that on the list
anyone else with questions just if you
clarify again Shannon
when the Chairman's when you're say
you're a chairman you're testifying or
refer to you as
uh represented as representative and
who's ever sitting here would be
chairman would be would be chair okay
thank you yep no thank you
yes
yes Mr chairman yes just just a question
on your schedule that you have do you
have anything for February 17th at this
point representative Newman let me look
yes we have
um and we probably
it's tentative but we have the 15th 17th
and 20th
and and that would be a start time of
nine or ten or well those would be those
will be executive sessions when we get
when we get down to that point so I
would say is is 10 o'clock more
preferable to the committee
or nine o'clock
we'll we'll we'll play with that I I
come from the ones coming from further
north I like 10 o'clock yeah we're in
executive session so I think when we get
to that point we can probably go to 10
o'clock
why don't I just give you a copy okay
okay well I'll I'll say them one more
time but if I just gave you guys so
February 24th
March 6th
10th 13
17 and 20. if I
if I were I'm looking for that week of
the 14th in February if there's anything
that week scheduled
I I don't have I don't have a calendar
but it looks like we're surrounding it
everywhere okay
for for new members that signed up and
looked at our bill loads and saw that
you know we only have seven or 10 or 14
bills a year we've had people in the
past join on because they thought we
didn't have a load you know it's is we
have a substantial uh body of work that
we need to do not only this year but
then next year with the 10-year plan
ah I did have I did find my list here so
um I do uh last and then I'll let you
have 15 minutes I do want to uh and it's
part of this process I want to point a
subcommittee for the review of lapse
funds request in conjunction with the
capital budget
I'm appointing representative Jack
representative Mills represent Juris and
representative Boyd to be on that what
for the for the some members that
weren't with us previously
um representative Jack being first name
Will chair that subcommittee uh
subcommittees will then report back to
the full committee and they'll report
um as representative has done in several
several terms back uh what what their
position is on that ultimately it will
be the decision of this committee
all right
okay now we're down to 14 minutes so
enjoy yourself
apologize for uh the slight delay there
I would like to open up the hearing on
House Bill 110 which is prohibiting the
use of State funds for new passenger
rail projects before I recognize
representative
eckenberger I apologize if I've missed
on that uh I would work Hackenberg I um
I just want to remind everyone that we
are going to be here until we've heard
all of our testimony
um but I would uh suggest when we have a
large number of people in attendance uh
when it gets time to say what it is you
would like to say to this committee if
that point has been made previously
please please be mindful uh and um
either agree with that point or just
move over that uh with that I would like
to recognize the prime sponsor
thank you
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee for the record my name is
Aiden Ankerberg I represent Stratford
district 7 which is Rochester's Ward 3.
this morning I'm here to introduce House
Bill 110. some of you returning members
may remember it a feeling of deja vu
less less than a year ago I was here
introducing House Bill 1432 which passed
the house in a bipartisan way
so this is the exact same language of of
the previous Bill all it seeks to do is
to prohibit the use of State funds for
new passenger rail projects
um so obviously we've we've come through
the
um the financial plan that was supposed
to be released
um upon the orders of the executive
Council That was supposed to be released
on the 31st I have not had access to
that despite repeated attempts to see A
draft copy of that I contacted both the
house Republican office and a number of
executive counselors and even through
their intervention I still have not seen
any data to work off that would change
any testimony that I had previously so
sort of the history of this is in 2014
um when that the dot released its report
we had those numbers to to go off of
which I have included in the packets
that I handed out to members of the
committee also there was an article that
I I included titled the
the case for commuter rail in New
Hampshire got worse not better in the
last seven years which appeared in the
Josiah Bartlett Center
that mentioned that in 2021 with the
updated numbers that they were actually
projecting that ridership would drop by
eight percent for the capital Corridor
project and also that eight percent
decline in ridership was occurring even
though the number of trips to Manchester
doubled going from 16 the original
report to 32 in the 2021 update
obviously I haven't seen anything
further with that as I mentioned in the
um that I have not received a copy of
that report from Dot
also along with the decrease in
ridership the costs were actually
expected due to inflation a number of
other factors to raise uh to Rise
um quite dramatically
my biggest problem with with this uh
proposal again without seeing the the
most up-to-date financial analysis of
this project would be that
the recommendations for funding in the
2021 report relied on
um one method which would be a Transit
sales tax I mean I I don't think a sales
tax is in keeping with the New Hampshire
advantage and uh that this is sort of
what spurred
my motivation to really uh introduce
this bill in the the original form
because you know this this is not in
keeping with the New Hampshire advantage
and for a project which will benefit
you know Nashua Merrimack Bedford
Manchester I represent Rochester and
what are we getting for our money there
you know I I don't feel that that is a
burden that we should put on the
taxpayers in my area and other areas of
the state that will not benefit
so
I know there's a lot of people
testifying
um I would certainly take questions but
I I would recommend that if if the
people have questions about
how this project is going to be paid for
that they would ask those questions of
the commissioner of Department of
Transportation because obviously he
would be the one to have the the most
up-to-date numbers on that
thank you
thank you representative Bank questions
for uh the sponsor
seeing none thank you sir
I would like to recognize uh
representative David
Pierce
Paris
having known you for years I do
apologize
foreign
thank you
oh this almost afternoon so I'm going to
say good afternoon I'm David priest I'm
a representative of Hillsboro 17.
uh in my previous life I was the
executive director for the Southern New
Hampshire Planning Commission
and one of the emphasis that I placed
was on economic development
of the capital corridor
and from that aspect I've got to say and
stress that
the access to passing jewel is very
important
for future job growth and economic
development Within
our state and without it
we will
um not see it
we have a future of young people who
want to come and work in this state but
they don't want to they live elsewhere
and but they don't own a car and we've
seen this many many times
and this would provide them access to
Nashua and to Manchester and in the
cities in between
and I and again I just urge you to
oppose 110
and to continue the
um progress that we are making on making
the capital Corridor a reality
are there questions
uh for the representative
thank you sir thank you very much
those those in the audience uh
practices that we tend to go back and
forth between those in favor and those
opposed and I will go back to uh uh
representative Erica
Leon please
in support
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee I am representative Erica Leon
from Derry and I'm an economist and a
former commuter on BART in San Francisco
the T in Boston and the commuter buses
from New Hampshire to Boston I have two
articles in the packet that was handed
out one from Politico about the systemic
impacts of post-coveted Trends on
commuter rail in New York as well as a
2015 policy briefing from the Josiah
Bartlett Center for Public Policy
evaluating the impact of New Hampshire's
current commuter rail the Downeaster on
the three towns served Exeter Dover and
Durham to summarize the political
article the pandemic fuel fueled a shift
to remote work which is unlikely to ever
reverse course creating new financial
and logistical challenges for transit
systems they were built around the nine
to five commuting structure commuting
railroad lines which are primarily used
by white collar office workers stand to
suffer the most from the shift
the hybrid work model is going to be
almost Universal the president and CEO
of the partnership for New York City
said overall employers are accepting the
need for flexibility and we're also
seeing that here in New Hampshire
depressed rail ridership creates a
paradox for Transit officials who must
contend with subsidizing a system that
people may use less but rely on for
service once it's there
they say that it will not reach the
levels they knew in the past but people
won't stop using it they'll use it less
because working from home will stay not
full-time but part-time
Transit agencies in New York managed to
save off Draconian service Cuts after
receiving billions of dollars in of aid
from federal stimulus packages but new
revenue streams may be necessary to help
bolster the rail in the long run
it could rejuvenate the debate about
dedicated subsidy streams for revenue
for Rail lines and a lot of these were
struggling to balance their books even
before covid just pulling up from this
for a second we're looking at a program
that
has been implemented in many other areas
even with their ridership in established
patterns they are needing more and more
subsidies and if we do this in New
Hampshire how can we guarantee that the
federal government or the towns that
benefit will do that and that it won't
fall to the taxpayers of the state
so when you look at this businesses are
rethinking where their main hubs will be
about staying in Manhattan or not in my
experience in Boston a lot of the
medical device and other health care
companies that I covered moved from
being very very close to downtown Boston
they moved out to um to the 495 ring
because they were better able to have
employees get there and they had better
costs Boston Scientific is no longer in
Natick they're much farther out
we've already changed not where we work
but how we work and a point-to-point
system of commuter rails is
unfortunately relic of the past
when we look to the policy matters
briefing in that packet from the Josiah
bar lip Center for Public Policy about
does commuter rail commute create jobs
there's actually a case study on what
happened here in New Hampshire when
service began on the Downeaster in 2001.
if you look at that Exeter lost 328 jobs
Dover gained 1019 jobs and Durham gained
11 jobs over that time frame this looks
and Compares what happened there versus
other similar communities it looked at
so I wrote on the back that it looked at
Epping to compare to Exeter which gained
1400 Jobs versus exeter's loss of 328
and then it looked to Rochester as a
comparison to Dover which lost 1700 jobs
as opposed to the Thousand gained in
Dover a lot of that was the shift to
Service as opposed to manufacturing and
as we have more jobs that are in the
office moving to hybrid we're looking at
our essential workers getting getting
around and making sure that they're
served the Josiah Bartlett one speaks to
the coaster commuter rail in San Diego
it serves what's similar to our
communities in Manchester and Nashua
reaching to the larger area of downtown
San Diego
the impacts of The Coasters study found
that there were minor gains in value for
some types of residential property near
the non-downtown San Diego stations and
commercial property values fell nearly
10 percent
um over Christmas I was in San Diego
helping my mother-in-law move from a
Skilled Nursing Facility to an assisted
living facility as Vice chairman of
Health and Human Services I was curious
about the impacts of the workforce
because they had severe Staffing
shortages there's a new trolley line in
San Diego that opened up and it's only a
few miles from these two facilities
but the number one problem with getting
employees to these Health Care
Facilities was unreliable Transportation
even with the trolley getting them five
miles away
there were public city buses that
weren't on time they couldn't get an
Uber or have another way to close that
Gap
I appreciate that there are some
benefits that could come from the towns
that would be served but they're not
benefits that will be widespread enough
to obligate the rest of the people of
New Hampshire to pay for this if there's
another funding stream whether it's
Federal whether it's local to those
areas I have no problem with them
pursuing this this strategy this program
that's that's time probably has passed
but if they can find the funding that's
fine but obligating the people of New
Hampshire who will likely never set foot
on those trains to pay for the cost
overruns and the subsidies that will be
required I believe is inappropriate and
that's why I co-sponsored this bill last
year and again this year thank you
thank you representative are there
questions for yes representative Boyd
thank you Mr chairman and representative
land thank you very much for your
testimony just a quick question it's a
curiosity thing during the context of
your research that you happen to do
analysis and analyzes of The Rail Runner
in New Mexico which runs from Belen
through Albuquerque up to Santa Fe
um thank you I did not look at that one
but New Mexico is not a state that we
would want to emulate
um we actually drove through there
because we drove to and from California
and while Albuquerque hasn't declined as
much as the other parts of New Mexico
since I spent a few weeks there back in
2004. it really is a state on the
decline and I do not think we should
model any of our policies on New Mexico
wonderful thank you very much thank you
Mr chairman yes representative
is have you noticed a lot of
construction along the Rail lines for
housing and and uh businesses in terms
of commuter rail and close to the home
in Boston the developments that happen
around the uh the new Green Line the new
Green Line in uh Summerville and Medford
and the and the
the rail line that's going to happen
down to New Bedford the commuter rail
line and the anticipation of
what's going to happen in terms of the
economic activity and the housing
activity
have you looked at that in in places
like Nashville and Manchester
um thank you for the question they may
be building in anticipation but when you
look at those last mile closure areas
you're looking at benefiting a very very
small geographic area directly around
those stations if you're looking to
spread that Economic Development beyond
that walkable distance from a station
you're looking at adding additional
public transportation infrastructure
that also needs to have reliability in
order to allow people to get to their
jobs this was actually an issue that I
dealt with when I was commuting on the
bus down to Boston if anybody who didn't
work right downtown would have to rely
on the MBTA and the T or the city buses
in order to get to their other jobs it
was unfeasible and unpracticable for
anybody who did not live near South
state did not work now near South
Station or in the financial district
where they did morning drop-offs to
actually take the bus because the time
and cost in involved between taking the
T or the bus to get to that Central Hub
of South Station was prohibitive and I
don't think that it would be any more
feasible outside of those immediately
concentrated areas to see much of a
benefit in the Josiah Bartlett study
there is a study of the MBTA commuter
rail system that had that that showed
that the development patterns actually
were not as related to those sites as it
would at first appear when you looked at
the it's in that document I didn't want
to dive too deeply into it so I'll let
you look to that document thank you
thank you any further questions
yes represent Faulkner yes I wonder if
you can talk a little bit about the
amount of construction of new office
space in downtown Boston
which is where this line would serve and
the differential and salaries between
Boston and uh
in the suburbs and New Hampshire and
uh
and how that plays into the benefit of
this uh thank you it actually has not
been a concentration in downtown Boston
it has been Fortune 500 companies
leaving Boston to go further out to
enhance the commuter and also to enhance
the cost it's a lot less expensive for
companies like Boston Scientific to be
further out and to then have a more
drivable area where their employees can
go out to lunch as opposed to just be in
the cafeteria when they were in Natick
that was actually something that hurt
their recruiting efforts they were one
of the companies that I covered closely
for over a decade also I've spoken with
people who are in commercial real estate
in Boston and they're having severe
tenancy issues there there are a lot of
people who now that there's a mix of
hybrid don't see the value of having
those offices in downtown Boston and is
saying a lot higher vacancy rates for
his property management business thank
you further questions
thank you represent land thank you
I would like to call
um
representative Charles Sinclair
thank you thank you all I represent uh
Laconia District Five
and I want to answer to a couple of
statements that were made one was the
fact that um I think the representative
from Rochester saw no benefit to
projects such as Rail lines and I'm here
to tell you
that I drive to Dover to take the train
to Boston because I can't stand 93 and
it also alleviates me from having the
park in Boston so I take the 45 minute
ride to Dover I hop on the train and
there I am but I quite often stop in
Rochester
perhaps to get gas perhaps to run into
Cumberland Farms or perhaps to go to a
restaurant so
I do a little bit of an economic
boom to the city of Rochester because
I'm going to get the train in Dover and
I suspect that happens with a lot of
other people I've been doing this route
on on the Downeaster for
probably close to 10 years now again for
the reason I stated and I've taken time
to speak to a lot of people I saw that
Downeaster at its full capacity before
the virus and after the virus now we're
it's building back up and this past
Friday
perhaps it was a week ago Friday I took
the 345 out and the train was sold out
and I probably should count I do have
pitches because I'm always amazed at how
many people get off an Exeter their arm
and then Dover I can catch the six
15 a.m train and see a lot of people
going south
going north I'm always
astounded how well the state of Maine
has been doing with this service because
I see people with suitcases
and one time I went up to have was
actually Thanksgiving I went up to
Portland to just have Thanksgiving with
some friends and there was a whole
family going north and I just noticed
them and then they were on this same
evening train going back and I said to
them so did you guys come up for dinner
like I said no we've never been up to
Portland before we just thought we'd
come up and find a place to eat and uh
and check this city out that's what
we're missing here we're talking about
commuters and that's great but we're
also missing people that travel and like
to travel by rail versus bus or dealing
with vehicles and being in Laconia I
realize that's not on the capital
Corridor but nonetheless the tracks run
right up through there and God forbid
maybe at some point will have enough
foresight in his state to push push it
further north and and benefit from that
and you know I don't have any stuff from
political or all these think tanks
because most of them are very I think
self-serving maybe I should have gone
around and got a petition and come down
here with thousands of signatures
because everybody I talked to in my
hometown in Laconia and other places in
the state all say the same thing
why are we not doing this and as far as
somebody mentioned that this was you
know they mentioned something about a
potential sales tax or something like
that and that's not to the New Hampshire
Advantage I would love to remind
everybody have here we have a meals and
rooms tax
and I know in the last session I think
it was you the state legislators and the
Senate reduced it by a half a percent or
something like that and um I you know I
I don't see the state doing away with
that to increase our so-called New
Hampshire Advantage uh by not having all
these people come into the state help
pay our expenses
um so I I don't see that that would be
an issue and again
has anybody here taken the Downeaster
I asked this I think two years ago
representative you could uh contain your
okay well this is I understand that I
understand that but I just want to
publicly say uh to help educate you on
on the people that take the New
Hampshire residents to take that train
I'll be more than happy to pick up the
fair uh at my expense to uh because I
think everybody on this committee should
and do a little more investigating on
what this what they have there how that
would benefit the center of the state
right up right up through especially
through Concord thank you thank you for
your testimony are there questions for
representative Sinclair
thank you sir
represent Baum
supports the bill
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
public works
I reckon I'm Ralph boam Hillsboro
district 14 town of Litchfield
in the early 90s
30 years ago Neely I was on Judd reg's
Railway Commission
probably the only one around that was on
that commission we studied bringing
commuter rail to Nashua we had many
meetings for a whole year
met at what was called then
Nashua Tech which is the Community
College
and included representatives from the
MBTA
after a year discussing and looking at
the issues it would determine that
computer rail was not financially
feasible more so now
it would determine that the tracks from
Lowell up would have to be completely
replaced and include turn off tracks the
existing track is 15 mile an hour
Freight
and worse now is there are less train
traffic 15 Mile now because the rails
does this
not suitable for
commuter rail
and then of course we have the initial
cost of the trains the upkeep of the
trains Etc or that coming from my other
pocket my federal taxes
the MBTA operation is paid for by a big
portion of the Massachusetts sales tax
and property tax
for most of the towns east of 495 and I
remembered a few years I was living in
Hudson Mass and even though the rail
never went through Hudson we had it on
our property tax bill is that going to
happen here
and
and we know that the MBTA is having
financial problems also as we mentioned
the Downeaster
going through Dover that's bam track
that has nothing to do with New
Hampshire that is Amtrak and substitute
subsidized by the federal government and
their
losing money every year
the argument that all transportation is
subsidized only goes so far yes in our
property taxes we pay for Road plowing
improvements Etc but we can control that
by our vote
there will not be any way to say no to
an estate State imposed subsidy tax or
whatever kind that's going to be we all
use the roads a very small minority
minority will use the rail and why
should I pay to make it cheaper for
someone to go to Massachusetts and why
should we make it easier for New
Hampshire residents to work in
Massachusetts and apparent and if a
pandemic what a better way to transmit
it than on a train
instead of bending more on trains the
money should be spent on New Hampshire
making it more cost effective for
businesses to do move to New Hampshire
so that workers don't have to commute
this bill will only increase state taxes
forcing companies out of New Hampshire
if Manchester and Nashville want
computer rail then they can pay for it
and let those that use a service pay for
it I use the words my gas tax pays for
it by the way even Vehicles now use the
road for free but that was another bill
so thank you thank you representative
foreign yes questions for the
representative
I got just briefly Mr chair thank you
brief thank you I like it brief you got
it uh representative thank you for
coming today familiar with uh Federal
subsidies for for state roads local
roads
and um
as well as for rail
I don't didn't get that are you familiar
with the federal government subsidizing
highways and bridges oh yeah
thank you
thank you representative testimony okay
um speaking uh opposing opposing the
bill I would like to bring forward
representative Horrigan please
and uh before you begin your testimony
representative uh the chairman would be
appreciative if we could leave party out
of discussions and then secondly uh
others speaking not to disparage other
representatives for their testimony
you've probably seen my written
testimony I I have not had that pleasure
okay please keep keep all right thank
you very much Mr one last thing
representative you're up against lunch
we have a lot of people oh here against
my lunch too and I have another bill at
once be precise thank you so I'm written
Timothy Horrigan I'm from Stratford
counties district 10 which is uh
which is uh uh the town of Durham which
is in Amtrak City we contribute 42 000
uh writers last year it's going to be
more I think in future years to the 467
000 Rising who ride the Downeaster
um
I don't want to get too partisan but
from a
place
but from a uh ideological perspective
we've heard that Josiah Bartlett Senator
mentioned two or three times as a
Libertarian think tank it's the one
thing Libertarians representative you
could container yes well we just any
case um we have heard about the desire
Bartlett the sales tax and Massachusetts
and we are in a symbiotic relationship
with Massachusetts our two communities
are divided by much as we like to think
we have nothing to do with Massachusetts
we're just we're one Community we're
divided by an arbitrarily drawn line
um anyway
so he's stricted primarily against the
national Manchester Concord line but the
way I read the bill
um I think it would effectively and
prevent any upgrades too or extensions
of the existing Amtrak Downeaster
service which I think has been very
successful and uh
can be even more successful in the
future
um
so it would even I don't even know he'd
use State funding and approve the
parking lots or access roads New
Hampshire's existing Amtrak stations and
we did hear about the last mile problem
and you know that's uh that's a real
problem but um that exists all already
um
something that's not on my written
testimony I have a note here about is uh
the town Easter because although has a
stop at Freeport Maine and you can like
ride the train walk all the way up that
little bean and you might say well why
would anybody do such a thing Maine has
a broad-based sales tax well the reason
they don't pull off at Durham or Dover
exit and go to the stores here in New
Hampshire there's various reasons but
one is like the last mile problem you
know there's
it's hard to get to the uh the malls you
know they're not located near the train
station but um and also of course they
build a destination shopping facility up
there in Freeport so if people are
willing to pay the extra 6.5 uh to go up
there and of course A lot of them come
from Massachusetts where the sales tax
it's about the same so um
and uh it's problematic for UNH the
station is right in the heart of Campus
all that's funds even though most of
them don't come from the state budget I
think they're going to ask for about 90
million 95 million of the billion dollar
budget for the whole system it's a small
percentage but other the other 98.5
percent is also State funds I'm not sure
whether they could use those
you know to improve the station there's
even a problem of the UNH Dairy Bar
restaurant with popular Lunch Spot in
Durham which is operated by the
university and located at the terrain
station and um
I'm not going to tune the motives of the
sponsors from my written tells him does
question their judgment a little bit
first of all Rochester Rochester
benefits from the train and represent
Sinclair uh alluded to that um it's a
short ride from from Dover it's uh
you know it's just about eight miles
down uh Route 16 or Route 108 so it's
very near Dover there probably are I'm
sure represent Sinclair is not the only
person who passes through Rochester on
the way to pick up the Amtrak in Dover
or Durham
and uh although then there's going to be
five stations as well we haven't
discussion yep we're here by the
Merrimack River Corridor uh two of the
sponsors from Hudson
Hudson uh and there's going to be
stations we know in South Nashville by
the circumferential highway bridge and I
think the site has already been picked
out for this one in uh downtown Nashua
near the Bridge Street Bridge route 101a
and the South Nashville station and I
guess somebody would have to provide a
bus service probably the employer it's
about
there's a very serious plan to build a
industrial and or distribution facility
right across the river from where the
train station would go right across here
from South
Nashville which is protected can deploy
over 2 000 people they actually said 2
100 in the latest presentations playing
for it but you know it's a significant
number of people um it would be
even if the
whether the Regional Transit Authority
in Nashville Hudson area doesn't provide
a bus it would be simple to have a
shuttle bus provided by the employer so
that could keep 2 000 cars a lot of
those two thousand cars could be kept
off the road or they could just get off
the train in South Nashville you know
get picked up by the shuttle bus and
just ride across and get to work so
uh Nashville is right near downtown
Hudson it's when the walking distance
that would certainly be good for
downtown Hudson If people could take the
train up to the Nashville station good
for Nashua too
the other two
um oh then there's going to be probably
Bedford it might be in Merrimack but
right by where the Raymond Resort Bridge
passes over the uh the representative
gets suspend for a moment
um I I'd like to get back on topic for
your support of this bill please
opposition well because I'm explaining
why the why the uh
why the project is a good idea and why I
think the ideological concerns about
train travel are misplaced um and I
think it can be successful obviously you
need subsidies but highways need
subsidies bus service
the airports
which I'm about to talk about requires
subsidies um none of them are supported
entirely of the fair backs at Fair box
and none them really only affect people
who ride the trains because there's
always development around uh trained
hubs
um so anyway
Manchester Regional Boston Regional
Airport MHT as we call it is currently
one of the only two major airports
in New England region that doesn't have
rail service at least doesn't have rail
service within a few miles um so uh the
other is Bangor International Airport a
very small air
airport in a remote rural part of Maine
um
and that would uh and they already do a
bus service to Manchester to Manchester
Boston Regional Airport but that would
you know we could have uh if we were
really dreaming we could probably build
a light rail line along the line of the
Raymond Resort Parkway but certainly it
wouldn't take much to
have a bus line that picks people up the
state station and drops them off at the
train to interface with it and
finally there's a station in downtown
Manchester
um I'm represented by the rail yard I
think I understand it for a moment yes
they um I I appreciate the philosophical
effort going here and prohibit I think
it's bad Bill and and I I've heard many
examples of relevant uh relevant to that
but um I just want to make sure that you
know your testimony is is prohibiting
the use of State funds for new passenger
rail projects yes please
I don't think we can effectively
um
I don't mean I don't think it's possible
to build a uh Rail Project without State
funds just as it's not you know just as
it wouldn't be possible to start a new
bus service without at least some you
know interfacing with the state
government state funds so I just I think
it's a good idea and I don't think
there's any way to do it without State
funds um when there are and there is a
lot of uh there's a large pot of money
that's available it would be a lot of it
would be Federal subsidies not that we
like the federal government too much but
I think I mean the money
the money is is there it's just a
question of how we allocate it and I
think it's uh so I think it's
short-sighted uh
short-sighted uh not to uh not to build
this rail line or at least consider
building it oh and the last thing I want
to say is uh for all of us the uh
the Concord station it's going to be
somewhere near the state house to
re-develop they've already started
redeveloping you know the area by the
train station on the fire side of store
Street and that's going to be somewhere
in there I'm going to guess probably
near where the existing bus station is
and uh
that will probably be within walking
distance of state house so that'll be
very convenient for legislators and
non-legislators and alike who want to
come up and visit the state house and
testifying bills or serve in the
legislatures that'd be like very good
for uh
everybody along that court or if you
could take a train to the state house
instead of even though we're going to
have a new parking garage eventually
like trying to park in that story Street
garage and everything so that's also
beneficial so uh
so I apologize for getting too
philosophical but I think this is a good
idea and I certainly think you need to
clarify that it doesn't do anything
about to harm the that we can still
support the existing train lines that
are already there aside from the
Downeaster uh the vice chair also lives
in Claremont which has a station
um so thank you thank you very much and
thank you anybody wants to answer any
questions I suppose they can and I
certainly worry about lunch I'll handle
that for you are there any
Representatives who wish to ask question
um
please
representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
representative Horrigan for your
testimony the Downeaster came into
existence on December 15 2001 and has
been running through the town of Durham
for for 20 some odd years what do you
think has been prohibitive in preventing
the am uh Downeaster from being able to
improve Economic Development
opportunities in Durham
um well we had
we have an issue uh
I mean it's a small it's a small train
station in the middle of the UNH campus
and the you know UNH uses a lot but it's
uh
there is a town-owned property which is
now actually originally they didn't
didn't really do a very good job of
serving the commuters on the train
they've since realized that's a problem
so there's a town
Town parking lot which is serves the
commuters who can earn many communities
just drive there and park in the town
parking lot there is also uh public
transit that serves the train station
and there's you know there's plans
there's plans uh I think there's plans
afoot to uh do more development there by
the Whittemore Center so it's a it's a
long process to do that thing and
there's some bureaucratic things so I
mean it's uh
you know we are thinking like a lot
farther ahead than we usually do but you
know and even what's there it's been
very successful there's a lot of writers
and there is at least a
one successful business operating at the
train station and I'm I mean I
personally if it's possible we'd like to
see some more if so thank you thank you
uh thank you for the question
representative Boyd thank you uh are
there any further questions for
representative Harrigan seeing none
thank you for your testimony
I'd like to call uh Drew Claire in
support of the bill
please
a correction Mr chairman it's Klein c l
i n e Klein thank you for the correction
well that was uh I have a problem
enunciating and handwriting would be
appreciated thank you sir
thank you uh Drew Klein I'm president of
the just higher Bartlett Center for
Public Policy uh we are a free market
Think Tank not a Libertarian think tank
for the record uh there is a difference
um I will try to be brief a lot of our
work has already been covered in
testimonies I won't go over that thank
you it'd be appreciated we have some new
stuff so uh commuter rail I think might
make sense in New Hampshire
um just not in 2023 or any time this
Century or The Next Century
um it doesn't make sense now for basic
math reasons
um
the general rule for light rail commuter
rail is that cities need population
density of about 10 000 people per
square foot this is what you find in the
academic studies and the textbooks Etc
to make rail work
Manchester's population density is per
the latest U.S census
3496 people per square mile I'm sorry 10
000 people per square mile not square
foot sorry about that slip there that
would be a real feat
um
so 3496 people per square mile in
Manchester Manchester does not have a
single zip code
with even 4 000 people per square mile
if rail enthusiasts hoped the city to
grow into a rail friendly city they're
going to be waiting a very very very
long time U.S censor data put
Manchester's population density at 3 310
per square mile in 2010
so the city's density has grown by just
186 people per square mile in the last
decade
at that rate
reaching 10 000 people per square mile
is going to take about 350 years
if the city's growth rate somehow
quickly doubled
we'd still be waiting 125 years to get
the 10 000 people per square mile
nashua's population density is much less
2961.7 people per square mile now there
seems to be this assumption you hear
this over the years when it comes to
rail that Nashua Manchester and Lowell
Massachusetts are relatively close in
population therefore it makes sense to
have that Commuter Rail Line come to
Nashua and then the Manchester from
Lowell but there's a huge difference so
Nashville is about 91 000 people Lowell
and Manchester are both give or take you
know roughly 115 000 people
but Lowell's population density
is
8489.8 people per square mile
it is well over double Manchester's
that's a huge difference the reason we
don't already have commuter rail from
Lowell to Nashua uh Manchester is
because it economically does not make
sense
we've done a lot of other research on
this in the past
I will just leave you with some more
recent data on commuting patterns and
railridership
um
since the pandemic just last month or
last week rather axios reported that the
U.S office vacancy rate has reached a
new post-pandemic high
of 50 percent
of its pre-pandemic levels
Boston's commercial vacancy rate
is about 15 percent that's the highest
it's been since the.com bust it's office
vacancy rate right now is about 17
percent
so representative Leon was absolutely
correct
our commuting patterns our work patterns
are changing
people are leaving
the center cities they're hollowing out
right now people aren't coming back
um they're not filling that in and
building a point-to-point rail line
as if
the old working commuting patterns still
existed uh would be a financial mistake
so um railrider ship commuter rail
ridership in Boston is only now back to
about 75 76 percent of what it was
before pandemic so even in Boston their
commuter rail is not back to speed
the MBTA who has been pegged by the dot
to run our Commuter Rail Line
gets 91 percent of its operating revenue
from subsidies only nine percent of it
comes from ticket fares
and this is in a city with a density of
about just under 14 000 people per
square mile
if anyone thinks that that ratio is
going to improve with a rail line to a
city that has density of less than 4 000
people per square mile
um I think they're a mistake so I'm
going to leave you with that data
um if there any questions happen to take
them otherwise I'll take off thank you
Mr Klein are there questions from the
committee members
seeing none thank you for your testimony
um I'm going to recognize uh
representative O'Brien
uh to speak next
um representative I think there's a
mistake on your card it says you're only
going to speak two minutes
knowing you for knowing you for a long
time could you could you could you
please try and figure something thank
you Mr chairman evidently you know I did
kiss a blondie Stone before I left the
outside yes that's my point go ahead
representative I I will try as I used to
tell sister raspisha to be on my best
behavior
uh
committee members of my representative
Mike O'Brien are represent district 10
which is the city of Nashua uh the other
hat that I wear I'm also vice president
of the board of alderman for the city of
Nashua
uh
this is the most prejudicial thing I
ever saw come down the pike
in my life
this is earmarked for one place and one
place only Manchester and Nashua
this is terrible this should be wrapped
up and thrown away into the basket in my
personal opinion but let me stay just
strictly on the bill but
if I look at line three of the bill down
to line seven
it says you you know this committee
supposed to develop
trans you know futuristic Transportation
needs for the state but then the new
language that came in but here's the
bullet to kill it
so it to me it's very highly confusing
the other thing is look at the new
additions from line seven to line 10.
that no state funds will go into any
rail projects
including the project and like I say
laser focus
direct attack this is not a dumb bomb
this is a smart bomb coming right down
for the project named Nashua Manchester
conquet but does it also affect what's
happening to rail Corridor out in
Seacoast
have you asked that question what is the
ill effect of that
it might
so again this is a bad Bill based upon
that now I hear others say oh geez you
know Nashua Here Comes Nashua I know how
you feel his Manchester Nashua again
but then again let's look at your own
communities how many you got Keno Nashua
has Keno but in some communities in the
state you know one representative to say
well what do my community get well you
get a lot out of Nashua
because all that money that went from
keno and the lottery and everything goes
into the to state fund and funds
education even to communities that don't
contribute or have Keno
in the community you get a lot out of
Nashua
business-wise
uh 1.1 billion dollars is raised and
taxed by the state in Nashua uh in jobs
from BAE Systems
does that not benefit the state of New
Hampshire that's what you get from
Nashua you want to laugh at 1.1 billion
dollars I'm not
and then again if we build this railroad
is this increasing jobs particularly
jobs in in the uh in the technical field
are you guys against jobs is the
representative that put this bill in
against jobs this is putting people to
work
I also want to remind this committee
that what do I get out of Nashua what do
I get out of Manchester
well I'll tell you another thing 35
percent of the state economy is
generated out of Nashua Manchester
General area
that's a lot
that's more than anybody else in the
whole state and yet to sit here and see
something laser focused like this
to try to come down to the communities
of Nashua or Manchester and stop us from
doing our due diligence of trying to
make this state one of the best states
to live in the Union
how can we do this can we do it alone no
municipality can will we need a little
assistance from the state the answer is
yes well we need some assistance from
federal funding the answer is yes but
let's look at the census this year's
sentences National increase to a
population of ninety one thousand one
hundred and twenty four people it's an
increase from the last time they did
this census
in my opinion probably by the next
census Nashua may be a new number one
city in New Hampshire
we're growing we increase our density
we're doing all right look at the
business model for the city of Nashua
and you tell me if we're doing a bad job
and what's going to go hand and glove
with this is this commuter rail process
this opens up the door you take what I
mentioned Bae what do you think Bae gets
a bae gets a lot of their people MIT
have it
if you're right on the link down in
Boston they can jump on the train and
come right up into Nashua unless also
too and why am I telling you your
business but I do know your business
because I used to say senator O'Brien
could you suspend a moment yes please
yes I always enjoy your conversation oh
you sure
we have we have another hearing at one
o'clock well if I may make one point and
I will do it I don't mean to say what I
was getting to uh Mr chair and thank you
for allowing
this has got to be taken into
consideration you have public works and
Highway you know rule three the Everett
Turnpike is built out
it's not going to expand
you can't
next time you do a project like that you
get into imminent domain if y'all like
me you hate imminent domain
so how can we alleviate the future
traffic with an increase in population
to Future traffic to make New Hampshire
citizens viable in a different Market
the Boston Market for the money that
they'll make down there will bring up
and that's what's going to help out the
General New Hampshire economy thank you
for your allowances Mr chairman
to representative of their questions for
the Mr Boyd representative thank you Mr
chairman I appreciate it and
representative Brian thank you for your
testimony a quick question you alluded
to that you are vice president of the
national board of alderman
um thank you for your service can it was
very easy to do just run for an election
[Laughter]
say I hear you same here
um how much has the city of Nashua
allocated in its budget in terms of
strategically planning for the prospects
of rail coming to Nashua quite a lot
actually and thank you for the question
Nashua has looked at purchasing and has
purchased
two potential Rail stations in
anticipation for it for it to come in
that would not be affected by the state
money but Nashua has looked at that in
the Crown Hill section it will
rejuvenate that particular neighborhood
and then also in the South End so things
are very much Nashua also has appointed
by the several Mayors and still in
existence the national rail commission
which has been working with New
Hampshire D.O.T coming up with the ins
and outs of this all it basically needs
just give us a little bit of funding and
we'll show you the way to the bright
light
just a quick follow-up Mr chairman
if I I would appreciate it quick it's
very quick uh representative O'Brien I
was looking for a price tag do you
remember how much was allocated
financially for
in your city budget do you remember how
much was that there was somebody from
the mayor's office that is here that may
have that number anything I tell you I
may be speaking the untruth and I don't
do that in front of him I don't want to
hold you in contemplary thank you thank
you thank you thank you both is there
any further question for the
representative
just briefly yep
thank you I recognize you for a brief
question representative O'Brien thank
you for coming to our hearing today and
do you will you find it to be true that
cars from out of out of Nashua residents
from out of Nashville like paulus or
Hudson or Londonderry would come into
Nashua to pack in that Commuter Rail
station proposed Commuter Rail station
and take the train into other whether
they're going north or south oh
absolutely one of the stations designed
like I say in the Crown Hill
Neighborhood uh is very close to Hudson
the Hudson Bridge that people would come
over uh to take care I know like in in
the feeder streets such as West Hollis
Street in the western part of the city
uh that's a big communication line of
transportation for people that live in
Milford Hollis and everything that do
come to Nashua thank God and spend if
they want a good evening out they do and
so you know Nashua is the host and I'm
so glad the city in Nashville has broad
shoulders to welcome everybody
thank you just a brief follow-up
chairman if I could
just
I'm sorry
um
is it was there any further questions he
had a if you will allow sir
just real quick currently do you would
you thank you chairman
currently do you think that there are uh
in in current Commuter Rail stations uh
North Billerica Wilmington and Lowell
Mass are their cars and those densities
that we've talked a lot about densities
uh are there vehicles uh their residents
from other towns or cities going into
places like Lowell North America
Wilmington to get onto the commuter
rails to go south into into Boston or
possibly North into into New Hampshire
National and Manchester well from what
you described if you go down off of 128
and look at the brand new garage that
was built on University Ave and that's a
short hop and Skip right into Boston but
it's more economical for people to do
that than to pay the X amount Boston
type of uh payment to get a parking
space and everything so this is like a
lot of the benefits of the commuter rail
system so yes the short answer is yes
but you can see it for in existence down
at the University Avenue Needham
thank you thank you both for the
question and thank you representative
all right we're um and I I will take it
head on my shoulders the amount of time
allotted for this uh for this hearing
but we're going to recess from this
hearing uh we will come back at
um
1 30.
and uh at that point in time I will open
the the testimony back for this I just
please ask for my committee members and
from the others that we try and be
concise on what we're doing here because
we have a lot to be done today and
um so we are going to be in recess till
uh 1 45 so that this committee can have
the opportunity to take a break thank
you
you said 145 yes
foreign
that are here for uh the one o'clock
hearing you will be delayed as uh so
House Bill 606 House Bill 511 and House
Bill 361 will be delayed uh with my
apologies I'm the guy that schedules the
we are still continuing on House Bill
110.
and before I open up House Bill 110
please note that we do have all that
other business to get to today
please tell me for against and uh and be
as
close in your testimony as you can
please
happy to accept written testimony any
written testimony would go to the clerk
and there is a process if you want more
information to be delivered on your
message the House website allows for
testimony and that'll be through the
rest of this day
with that I would like to
my cards got switched
we will go for in favor of 110
and I would like to recognize Greg Moore
please
and with apologies I intended to take
your testimony before lunch I'm sorry I
held you up for this time that's okay
not your pleasure thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee I appreciate
the opportunity to speak here today for
the record my name is Greg Moore I am
the state director with Americans for
Prosperity New Hampshire here today to
testify in support of House Bill 110 and
I will say about house bill 110. I
certainly heard a lot of testimony and I
certainly don't want to be redundant one
of the things that I didn't hear was a
lot of testimony about what is
specifically in the bill and what the
bill the bill bill is not a referendum
on trains certainly we have Pat commuter
rail going through New Hampshire and the
and the down over and over running
through Exeter Durham and Dover and
that's functioning just fine
the question is is whether
the state taxpayers will subsidize
commuter rail going forward
whether a small a small number of people
will benefit from uh the taxpay the
taxpayers of the entirety of New
Hampshire and our belief is that is that
uh that projects like that that require
High degrees of subsidy and we don't
exactly know obviously the Department of
Transportation will follow and can offer
more Guidance with the the
most recent study which presumably
should be completed in the near term
what exactly the amount of the subsidy
is and at a time when you look at a you
look at the MBTA the data that an
earlier an earlier presenter mentioned
that 91 percent of its costs are funded
by subsidies and so the question then
becomes what is appropriate as far as as
far as subsidizing a small number of New
Hampshire residents and maybe a small a
small number of Massachusetts residents
relative to the size of the of the state
as a whole and we believe it's it's it's
inappropriate the and the level of
subsidy is unwarranted uh so from our
perspective focusing exclusively on on
the subsidies I think is the key for
this committee and I think it's it's
really the key just of this entire uh
process certainly no issue if the cities
of Manchester Nashville feel it's
appropriate to subsidize as a train if
there is a passenger rail service which
could charge to get all of the money
they need from the fares of that that is
appropriate but uh asking asking New
Hampshire taxpayers to subsidize what's
only going to benefit a small number of
New Hampshire residents we think it's
bad policy so for that reason we're
opposed to I mean we support the
legislation we we oppose subsidies and
I'd be happy to take any questions
thank you uh questions for Mr Moore yes
please
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question can you tell me any
passenger rail service that doesn't
operate without subsidies
I I it's it thank you for the question
I'm not aware of any commuter-based rail
services that operate without subsidies
at this point uh the the there was an a
about four years ago I remember I think
it was four years ago there was an
effort put forth by a businessman from
Massachusetts to actually uh actually
bring passenger rail service up through
Concord and Manchester privately meaning
no no taxpayer subsidies I'm not sure
how that model would work frankly I was
a little skeptical my understanding is
that his his company is has gone by the
wayside so that's no longer a viable
project but at least one person did view
this as as what as a viable alternative
I don't know if he had plans for federal
subsidies I assume he did because it's
just a capital upgrades in the tracks
would be prohibitively expensive for an
individual or a company to to pay for
but he had a plan to bring it up uh it
was fairly notable when it was when it
was rolled out uh and that was I think
think
2018 I believe was 2018. so it's not
outside the realm of possibility
for other questions for Mr Moore
if you could indulge me one or in your
research are you aware of a passenger
line that operates without subsidy or at
a profit
uh not in the U.S thank you sir
my question is to
representative stube
Stout are you here
are you my question is do you are you in
committee today
okay could I hold you for a moment we've
had people waiting quite a while thank
you I will recognize you
I'd like to recognize Megan
Kane
Karen
please city of Nashua opposes the bill
do you have written testimony yeah
okay we'll we'll read that testimony
please continue
if you have something to add
microphone please sorry
um good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the committee my name is
Megan Karen and I'm here to read a
statement on behalf of Mayor Jim donkess
of Nashua who regretfully could not be
here today
as the mayor of the city of Nashua I am
writing to you to express my strong
opposition to house bill 110. this bills
aim to prohibit the use of State funds
for new passenger rail projects is
short-sighted and has direct negative
impacts on Nashua
despite the executive council's recent
decision to Halt the nhdot's feasibility
study at 72 percent completion
I remain committed to ensuring that our
state's decision makers and citizens are
provided with the necessary information
to evaluate the role that rail will have
will play in our future growth
prosperity and Community Development
this legislation specifically names the
national Manchester Concord rail line as
a as a project that would be excluded
from being funded if this legislation
passes this is despite the fact that
this project is identified in the
current 10-year Transportation
Improvement plan
the state has already recognized the
importance of this project by including
it in its long-term Transportation
Planning and partially completing a
feasibility study but passage of this
bill would hinder our ability to work
collaboratively collaboratively with the
state to explore the future of rail in
New Hampshire
passenger rail is a transformative
opportunity for New Hampshire's future
growth and development
connecting our state with the Greater
Boston area opens up a wide array of
economic opportunities for New Hampshire
businesses to attract new workers and
customers reduce the emission of
greenhouse gases by taking cars off the
road and increases Transportation Equity
by opening opportunities for people
without cars to access the educational
medical and cultural resources of Boston
these benefits will not only be seen by
Nashua or Manchester but all of Southern
New Hampshire
passenger Rail stations in Nashville
will be connected to the Nashua transit
system which serves and connects with
riders and surrounding communities
the services are critical to our
communities most vulnerable populations
the train will be an important piece in
creating an accessible multimodal
Transit Network across Southern New
Hampshire that connects people with the
places they need and want to go
I would urge the committee to give this
bill a recommendation of inexpedient to
legislate the state has already
identified this project as a priority by
including it in its 10-year
Transportation plan and perhaps most
importantly our communities want
passenger rail in the access and
opportunities that come with it thank
you for your consideration
thank you for your testimony and for uh
city of Nashua sending that along are
there questions
thank you for your testimony oh I'm
sorry is there a question yes
thank you Mr chairman I apologize and
miss Karen thank you for representing
the mayor of Nashua very quickly I asked
representative O'Brien uh previously how
much money had the city of Nashua
allocated in preparation and I'm going
to ask you that same question again
thank you thank you for the question so
uh the exact figure I can get to you but
I will say that the New Hampshire D.O.T
when asked if uh the mayor could
contribute
um uh any any money he uh did say he
could
um or he's confident that the the board
of aldermen would support uh a little
over 20 million dollars
thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman
thank you
I'd like to bring forward uh Andrea
brayer from New Hampshire dot please who
is opposed to the bill
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee it's been fun to spend the day
with you
again for the record Andre Briere Deputy
Commissioner with me is uh Miss Shelley
Winters who's our director of Aviation
Rail and Transit
uh just for brief place setting remarks
I'll tell uh tell you for the record
that New Hampshire D.O.T neither
supports nor opposes any particular mode
of transportation
to include passenger rail we design
build and maintain all modes that are uh
that are directed for us to uh to design
build and maintain by The People's
elected representatives so we came into
this project starting in 2019 with a
task that was given to us by this body
and that was to take this through the
preliminary design phase approximately
the 30 design phase and therefore to
come up with a realistic financial plan
that's what we've done
uh that project and I guess in direct uh
response to the to the sponsor who
introduced the bill just for clarity
that project closed out on the 31st of
January that's when we were given the
initial drafts uh by the consultant
so as you can imagine we have to then QC
those drafts uh make sure that they are
sufficient in substance uh and then uh
when we're satisfied that those are
complete and correct we will make those
publicly available and also provide
those to the legislature so that's where
we are as far as this project goes
our opposition really is technical and
that goes to the uh the wording
of the bill itself as written the title
stipulates that it prohibits the use of
State funds for new passenger rail
projects the body of the legislation
though uh does not make that distinction
and I quote no state fund shall be
appropriate or expended for the planning
construction operation or management of
Passenger rail projects it does not say
new
we interpret this to mean that we would
be prohibited from any sort of State
funding for maintenance or indeed the
the time of the State Workforce
um to dedicate ourselves to any project
associated with the Downeaster or any
similar passenger rail it also doesn't
Define what passenger rail is in this
context which could be interpreted as
also meaning tourist rail to include the
Cog railroad which operates on our lines
so our our primary objections are
technical again we are not either havocs
or opponents of the capital Corridor
project itself we were given a task and
we accomplished that task
so with that I would defer to the
committee for any questions thank you
are there questions from the committee
yes
Reservoir
thank you thank you Mr chairman just a
real quick one do you have an ETA on
when that report would be ready
yes sir we're in the midst of editing it
ourselves uh so again we were provided
the uh the final consultant drafts late
night on the 31st this week
so we are currently in conversations uh
both uh Miss Winters and I have gone
back and forth on several drafts
ultimately the the commissioner of dot
will have to approve those
I I wouldn't speculate a guess I would
say it's it's a matter of uh weeks not
months so it will be not too long
thank you further questions
yes
thank you Mr chairman and Deputy
Commissioner thank you for your
testimony just one um two two first
question the technical line seven the
where it says no State funds you're
saying you should put if if it read no
new state funds
or uh alternatively
um
on line eight or nine if it were to say
new passenger rail projects in other
words match the title of the legislation
that would be correct in in as far as
we're concerned it would allow us the
latitude to continue to expend time and
funds on existing passenger rail service
uh second follow-up follow-up thank you
Mr chairman uh Deputy Commissioner back
in
I want to say it was
fall of 2020 my dates could be wrong but
there was a rollout it was assumed
meeting where they introduced the
capital Corridor project they was
basically high level talked about the
length of the line Economic Development
opportunities it's a lot of data that
was included and I wasn't looking for it
today and I I have it somewhere but my
question to you is this report that's
being going to be propagating in the
next couple of weeks it's not going to
have any impact on the data that was
communicated to us three years ago in
other words it's the data potentially
going to be changing in One Direction or
the other or do you see that being
relatively static
so I I can answer your question I guess
at the kind of the 30 000 foot level
which is we have continued to refine
those numbers between that particular
meeting which I was also on I recall
um and today so the numbers are are much
more refined much more fulsome uh
factoring in everything that that we and
the consultant team and the communities
could come up with as far as actual
costs in real terms
um
I will also say there's a number of
assumptions that we've we've had to make
um
foremost of which is uh the
participation or not of the state of
Massachusetts
we have no assurances we've consulted
obviously and uh coordinated but that
was largely in the previous
administration the new Administration
South of the Border hasn't weighed in on
this project so there's a lot of
assumptions that have to go into this in
the in the report that you will see in
its final form we spell out we're very
clear about what is fact and what is
assumption when it does come to costs
and the overall burden that
would come to the state of New Hampshire
If This Were pursued okay I appreciate
you Candor and I look forward to the
report yes sir thank you thank you Mr
chairman yep thank you represent Boyd is
there any further questions from the
committee
seeing none uh thank you Mr Pierre thank
you sir
I'd like to uh call forward Wendy hunt
please Nashua chamber
has written testimony oppose the bill
thank you
good afternoon chairman McConkey and
members of the House Public Works and
highways committee my name is Wendy hunt
I'm the president and CEO of the greater
Nashua Chamber of Commerce our chamber
has consistently and strongly gone on
record in support of the Capitol
Corridor project and I'm here today to
emphasize our continued support for rail
expansion of the Nashua Manchester
Corridor in New Hampshire
the chamber represents over 400
businesses across Southern New Hampshire
that employ thousands of our state's
residents and generate over a billion
dollars of economic activity each year
the Nashua Manchester Corridor serves as
the economic backbone of our entire
State as goes the economic output of our
region so goes the rest of New Hampshire
therefore economic growth along the
Nashua Manchester Corridor is important
to the overall growth of our state's
economy
the New Hampshire Capital Corridor Rail
Project has the potential to have a
transformative impact in on New
Hampshire's economy by positively
impacting the national Manchester
Corridor we hear consistently from our
business members that they want rail
expansion and that is vital to the
Southern Tier of the state I'm gonna I
have
giving you all my testimony so I'm going
to cut it short because of so many
things that we agree with that have to
do with the PDP and some other things
but but here is why um we feel the
capital Corridor project is so critical
first of all when we think of
cross-state employment we always think
of New Hampshire residents commuting
into Boston for jobs and not vice versa
in Merrimack Valley Valley Massachusetts
there's a much higher unemployment rate
than in New Hampshire greater now the
greater Nashua area has thousands of
unfilled jobs in manufacturing Health
Care construction and other Industries
rail expansion expansion into Southern
New Hampshire from Massachusetts has the
potential to bring thousands of daily
commuters each day into our state to
fill these jobs
New Hampshire's population is aging
population wise we are one of the oldest
states in the country this means a
smaller Workforce as workers retire and
increase pressure as business look to
hire and retain employees in the years
to come
we need to attract younger employees to
into our state or keep the ones we have
so our businesses and economy can
continue to prosper and grow as we look
at those younger employees we want to
attract public transportation is one of
the most important factors to them in
fact people under 30 are far more likely
to ride public transportation and to
express positive feelings than older
people regardless of what part of the
country they live in
open up opening up the possibility of
train travel from New Hampshire to other
states in the Northeast and Beyond is
wildly attractive to this younger
demographic
finally on the New Hampshire Dot's Rail
and Transit page I've given attachments
on all of the testimony thank you
um it states quote the state is the
largest railroad owner of over 200 miles
of active purchased line to preserve
freight service industry or promote
tourism and economic development so it
is part of of their job description
um specifically why H why I want to talk
about why HB 110 and we hope you find it
an expedient to legislate
um would would not only because the
study's not ready but um also as the
Deputy Commissioner said
um the language is very confusing about
new in the title and it's not mentioned
in the body
um also I've attached um in the 2021
infrastructure investment jobs act HB
110 may be in violation of that as well
as a federal passenger rail investment
Improvement Act of 2008 and other DOT
regulations
um
also it limits the ability of future
legislators to provide Pastor rail
Transportation as an option to the
citizens of New Hampshire you're binding
future legislators if you support this
bill
um and I will leave it there thank you
very much thank you for your testimony
are there any questions
thank you so much and uh please pass
your testimony forward if you haven't
already we have it already thank you
thank you
I would like to um
greater Manchester chamber Heather
mcgrail
welcome to Public Works
thank you thank you chairman and
committee members and it is strategic of
you to place me right after Wendy so I
can Echo a lot of the points that she
just said but I'd like to add a few of
my own
um as obviously CEO for the largest city
in New Hampshire it may seem that we
have self-serving interest in this in in
opposing this bill that I'd like you to
broaden your lens of Economic
Development and I'm going to use one
example to illustrate that economic
development for our state goes far
beyond zip codes and borders I'm sure
you're all familiar with the Army
project and the buildback better a
regional challenge that we were able to
win through Dean cayman's work and
that's really building a whole new
industry for our entire state has the
opportunity to be the Silicon Valley of
New Hampshire it's biofabrication it's a
new industry and it is 44 million
dollars of federal funding that we
received
right now that's creating 7 000 jobs
in the future it will create tens of
thousands of jobs I know you all know
the the housing shortages and the
Staffing shortages that we are all
experiencing especially in Manchester
but throughout the whole state we need
places for these workers to be able to
live we need we need rail to be able to
get them to and from to be able to
support that kind of growth and I would
argue that manufacturing and biofab are
two of the highest fastest growing
industries that need this kind of
support need to be able to bring you
know people from MIT and Harvard yes but
even from farther and it's giving a lot
of national and international support
and putting New Hampshire on the map so
just one illustration of many many
examples that are that are just the same
maybe not as large in scale but many
many hundreds of examples so I'll leave
it there and uh I think that's that's
all we have time for I know you're
fatigued
thank you are there questions
uh represent boy
thank you Mr chairman thank you very
much for your testimony Mr mcgrail
um correct me if I'm wrong but the the
Intermodal facility in Manchester that's
that's close correct is correct okay
then my question you follow up Mrs
follow up thank you Mr chairman so my
question to you is how much of a
downtick in employment opportunities has
occurred as a result of that bus station
not providing a level of
level of service to people that frequent
downtown and work downtown Manchester I
wish I had that exact stat I I thank you
for the question but I don't know the
exact stat of that I would imagine it's
pretty significant
but I wouldn't want to speak out of turn
thank you thank you Mr chairman thank
you both
anyone else further questions from the
seeing none thank you thank you so much
brevity was well appreciated
um yeah I just want to remind you if
you're if you're holding a pink card and
you are hoping to testify in this bill
we should we should have that at this
point in time
like to hear from EJ Powers New
Hampshire business for rail expansion
please
they are yeah there's uh there's three
there
I'm submitting some testimony on behalf
of a couple of uh business owners in New
Hampshire as well uh chairman
McConaughey and members of the committee
my name is EJ powers and I'm with the
New Hampshire business for rail
expansion coalition
it's not often that you find an
initiative that has support of 75
percent of New Hampshire residents it's
rare when support comes from majority of
residents from every political party uh
every gender every age every education
level every ideology and in every County
of the state
it's even more rare when businesses both
large and small from coffee shops to
construction companies from Banks to
biotech startups led by the staunchest
of Republicans and most left-leaning
liberal Democrats all agree to support a
specific project
well that initiative is the expansion of
Passenger rail from Boston to Nashua and
Manchester and those supporters are your
neighbors families friends uh and your
constituents they support this
initiative because of the overwhelming
Economic Development opportunity that it
would provide which would supercharge
New Hampshire's already booming economy
I apologize no problem
for some reason my phone likes stance go
ahead and I apologize
um so the rail Expansion Project would
result in thousands of jobs each year
thousands of much needed residential
units millions of square feet of
commercial real estate and hundreds of
millions of dollars in real estate
investment and reinvested worker
earnings
uh currently the project development
analysis is underway uh and that's
examining multiple aspects of the
project this is an in-depth analysis
that will provide a solid environmental
engineering and financial uh picture to
give you all uh the necessary
information to make an educated decision
as written hb110 would eliminate all
prospects for investing in rail it would
for the will of the overwhelming
majority of New Hampshire citizens it
would squander a once in a lifetime
Economic Development opportunity for the
state it's simply an unnecessary
preemptive bill that's not ready for
prime time it presumes the state should
invest zero dollars in an infrastructure
project before you have any data to make
an informed decision so I urge you on
behalf of 75 percent of New Hampshire
residents over a hundred bipartisan
businesses from across the state to
reject HB 110. thank you thank you Mr
Powers questions for Mr Powers
yes please
thank you Mr chairman
um what's thank you for taking my
question what's that source of 75 of
support that was a Saint Anselm College
survey conducted in 2019. uh Statewide
cna's survey thank you representative
um thank you sir for your testimony
uh
Bryce cow woo
I really like how you did that
phonetically for me
welcome to Public Works
thank you Mr chairman and yep the figure
I'd include a pronunciation guide
because otherwise wouldn't make sense
um so good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of this committee my name is
Bryce kawu and I live in Manchester
where I'm a homeowner and an active
member of the community I also currently
serve as the chair of the Manchester
planning board I have with me printed
testimony from the vice chair and
another member who had a baby this week
and couldn't make it so I will hand
those out at the end but for my
testimony I came here today to speak in
strong opposition to houseboat 110
because new passenger rail is essential
to expanding Freedom reducing traffic
and building a better future for our
state
I'd first like to talk about expanding
Freedom so building out our regional
passenger rail network will enable
people to travel in more ways that suit
their needs giving the people giving the
people of Manchester Nashua other
communities in the surrounding area to
you know the freedom to skip the traffic
593 or the Fe Everett Turnpike if they
so choose better access to work Leisure
and other things like medical treatment
Braille will give more people more
personal choice in how they want to get
around as for traffic reduction I'm sure
you've heard before but for every person
who uses Regional Rail that's one less
car on our state roads and highways and
as you know we have a lot of traffic
that goes back and forth between New
Hampshire and Massachusetts the roads
can suck sometimes with all the cars and
wouldn't it be awesome if we had
thousands of less cars on the road each
day depending on the level of service of
this rail because folks can choose to
take the rail and some folks you know if
they still have to take their car out of
necessity or if they want to drive they
can and the roads would be a better
experience for them because of that
reduced congestion and rail is scalable
too so very Mary will you know save us
from having to endlessly pursue new
highway widening projects we just spent
751 million dollars widening I-93 and if
we continue to increase in population
and if we continue to have more drivers
that would become a prerogative in the
future as well which could negatively
impact the surrounding communities the
environment and just cost a lot of money
too
so rails service is also an important
part of the vision that we have for the
future here in Manchester so the return
of regional passenger rail service to
the city is a critical component of our
master plan which we adopted just again
in 2021 we have approved some potential
sites within City boundaries and a
potential layover site as well we've
additionally designated an entire
Transit oriented development District
that would be rejuvenated by the
rearrival of Passenger rail in
Manchester which we did have
historically but it has gone by the
wayside residents businesses and other
stakeholders from across the community
are enthusiastic about this endeavor and
it would throw an enormous wrench in our
plans if houseboat 110 were to become
law now some other stuff that hasn't
been mentioned before first supporters
of House Bill 110 and opponents of rail
Transit generally May opine that
commuter rail is passe that it is
outdated and that is it's irrelevant to
the modern economy and actually perhaps
to your surprise I agree with them this
discussion has moved on and more and
more people like myself are no longer
interested in commuter rail nine to five
job stuff because that is a notion from
the past instead we're focused on
building out an integrated
round-the-clock Regional passenger rail
service that suits a variety of needs
not just commuting to and from work but
inclusive of that so that's an important
shift in the conversation that I think
the committee should keep in mind as we
move forward
and second it's important for this
committee to consider the short and
long-term costs of Transportation
projects so here in New Hampshire we
spend hundreds of millions of dollars
each year expanding and maintaining our
Statewide Road Network yet we deem it
worthwhile we think there's value to it
and when it comes to Regional Rail
capacity yes there would be a cost as
well but the state would only be
responsible for a limited amount of
matching funds I'm sure you all are
familiar with the various FTA grants we
get for roads there are also lots of
grants available for rail projects and
every Rider would pay some sort of use
fee user fee to buy a ticket and whatnot
to help defray the costs of operation
and maintenance so in a way future Rail
lines could be similar to our existing
turnpikes where drivers pay a toll and
regardless we don't expect our all of
our roads to turn a profit and we
shouldn't unnecessarily hold rail to a
higher standard the last thing I would
like to say before wrapping up here is
that as someone else has mentioned
houseboat 110 unduly short circuits the
upcoming 10-year Transportation plan
process the governor himself had said in
December 2022 when the executive Council
um kind of next the The Project declined
an extension of the timeline he said
that supporters of Regional Rail would
have an opportunity to advocate for its
inclusion in the next 10-year
Transportation plan I would love to come
back here again uh if you have hearings
for that and speak with you again but
whichever direction that plan goes
please don't let this legislation
shortchange that process and prevent
those discussion discussions from
happening in the first place so with
that respectfully SCU designate this
legislation as in expedient to legislate
and uh thank you I'd be happy to answer
any questions thank you Mr Scott are
there any questions for the gentleman
seeing none thank you thank you
I believe it's gradeland Hayes
thank you
thank you Mr chairman uh good afternoon
members of the committee my name is
Gwendolyn Ricard Hayes I'm a lifelong
resident of Epping New Hampshire and I'm
here today to speak in strong opposition
to House Bill 110. uh when I was four
years old I experienced a car collision
that forever changed my life it not only
took away my mother but also my ability
to feel safe while driving in a car
unfortunately for me the local leaders
of the past and present have failed to
consider or care about the people like
me who do not want to be forced into
cars as a sole means of transportation
why have we been ignored the motor and
oil industry has always been very
effective at lobbying those in power to
help increase profit margins that's why
we've been ignored profit margins oil is
a dying industry it must be a dying
industry in order to save our planet we
have to kill it cars are not the future
they are simply too inefficient too
space demanding and too destructive to
the planet electrification does not
solve these issues the solution fund any
other form of transportation and fund it
significantly people will use the
options given to them in the long run
this would also be the more economically
efficient Venture for the local
communities
creating a local web of Transportation
options expands the possible pool of
patrons by making it significantly
easier and accessible to get places
therefore increasing traffic to local
businesses along with that benefit uh we
no longer need to spend Millions
maintaining a massive Road system this
bill would ban State funds for passenger
rail projects why would we want to do
such a thing the whole point of society
in governments is to use our Mass
resources to improve the quality of life
and make life more accessible for all
this bill is completely antithetical to
that ethos members of the committee when
you vote on this bill please consider
the many people like me who for whatever
personal reason do not feel comfortable
driving in a car and if given the choice
would choose otherwise please vote in
expedient to legislate on hb110 thank
you for your time thank you thank you
for your testimony and everything
questions from the committee
thank you
I believe I hold in my hand the last
speaker
representative stob please
who is opposed to the bill
and once again I apologize for not
extending the courtesy of putting you in
front but we've been we've been hours
here thank you that's fine uh thank you
Mr chairman um I intentionally held my
card back because I thought it would
give me an opportunity to answer some
questions that people had for the record
my name is Kathy Staub I'm
representative of Hillsboro 25 which is
um Ward 5 in Manchester and I'm here
speaking in opposition in opposition to
this bill I think one of the issues that
um
we have with this is that
um prior to the pandemic I I did a lot
of research on this issue a number of
years ago and I will be sending some
emails to you with some links so you can
read some of the stuff that I I have
written about this but prior to the
pandemic there was an estimated 80 000
people who commuted from New Hampshire
into Massachusetts
anyone who's been on 93 recently I
babysit a couple days a week down in
Massachusetts and the roads are still
very congested
um
by not including a passenger rail as
part of our Intermodal transportation
system I think we're missing a loss
opportunity we do have those Rail lines
that come up the Merrimack Valley it
would be a great way for us to get
vehicles off of the road
passenger vehicles also carriers of
freight there there is some utilization
of that currently but because the tracks
are slow 15 miles an hour
there isn't quite as much utilization as
there could be
um
I'd also like to address a couple of the
questions that came up for example
people talked about
um I I apologize
I'm having pink cards show up all of a
sudden are they sitting in front of
members
that's okay I'm sorry Representative no
no problem
um the Downeaster for example you know
they talked about loss of utilization
prior to the pandemic they reached their
Peak at about 500 000 and this last year
it was already back up to 400 000 and
they expect to reach 500 000 again
there are lots of opportunities that
some folks have spoken about already in
terms of
development the rail station in
Manchester would be in the area within
walking distance of this new Arena and
the Fisher Cats baseball stadium in
downtown Manchester that will
undoubtedly produce a lot of additional
room and meals taxes for the state also
there's already started to be a lot of
housing development in that area in
anticipation of this rail station going
in so real estate trans transfer taxes
Etc will will also come into the state
coffers based on this on this project
it's um somebody also asked a question
about any non-subsidized uh passenger
rail line the bright line in Florida is
fairly new and it it is a privately
owned rail operation you know this is
we spend a lot of money on roads
expanding 93 cost us 770 million dollars
in the project to expand Route 3 is 168
million dollars
um Massachusetts the city of Boston is
is
I don't want to say that word but
they're very focused on reducing their
on greenhouse gas emissions by 25 and so
they don't want any more cars in their
city so for that reason they have they
have stated in no uncertain terms that
they will not expand 93 or route 3. so
no matter how many lanes we put in in
New Hampshire as soon as you hit the
Border it's going down to three and
anyone who's gone down there and has had
to deal with that bottleneck um again
you know it's it's not good so
you know a bunch of other people have
said a bunch of stuff also the other
point that I would like to make is that
Boston expressed the last time I checked
received six hundred thousand dollars
per year from the state
um in um subsidies and at that uh at
that point that I had done that research
they were preparing to buy new buses for
the for the Boston Express so
you know public transportation it's it's
a quality of life issue and this my my
personal philosophy is that um we we
support the state so that it can get the
things for us that we can't get as
individuals so and I would like you to
consider all that as you think about how
to
um
how to recommend this bill and I would
suggest that
um on itl would be beneficial for those
of us in Manchester and really everyone
from the state
um one more thing the airport more
people use the airport the more carriers
not having rail is is a is a barrier to
that so if more people were able to
utilize the airport more carriers would
come in prices would go down anybody
who's ever used Manchester Airport would
benefit so that's all I have to say and
I thank you so much for hearing my
testimony and have a nice afternoon
thank you representative are there any
questions for the representative do
seeing none thank you for your testimony
is there is there a
Jane Hugh here
Jane welcome to public works thank you
very much uh chairman my name is Jane
hake and I'm a resident of Manchester
just representing myself
and I'm very interested in I think of
myself as a futurist I like to think
about what the future is going to be
like I don't think I've ever talked to
anybody in New Hampshire that doesn't
want the economy to grow I think we hear
a lot about growing the economy and um
I think that if you think ahead
the idea that all the people that are
going to come and take the jobs that
we're hoping to have in New Hampshire
that they're all going to commute in
cars is really kind of on unrealistic as
my associate representative Staub said
they're not going to expand 93 or 3
anymore and
um
so I'm going to leave out some of my
testimony um
so um
as some people seem to see The Rail Link
as exporting workers to Boston I think
it's more likely that we'll be importing
workers from Lowell and Boston and areas
like that for instance as the Chamber of
Commerce representative mentioned the
new jobs at the bio lab facilities that
we're hoping to create and we already
have an enormous grant to get that
industry underway those are going to be
lab jobs those are not going to be like
jobs that people can work remotely at
and um so we have to think of ourselves
and see it as a periphery of the Boston
metropolitan area and even though the
rest of New Hampshire is not necessarily
going to ride the railroad as the
representative from Nashua said it's a
huge amount of money that comes into the
New Hampshire economy and thus the state
coffers from those Industries
and I would just like to say if we don't
facilitate the creation of a rail line
now
we're going to find ourselves paying
much more for it in 5 10 or 15 years and
that this will also benefit anybody who
wants to commute who might still be
commuting down to Boston because the the
uh the roads won't be as crowded really
we can't the roads can't get much
crowded before they hit gridlock which I
think will happen in five years if we
don't do anything so that's all I have
to say thank you very much thank you for
your testimony are there anyone with
questions
thank you
um last last to speak uh Henry good
please come forward
good afternoon and thank you
uh president of Concord originally from
Manchester I'm a proponent of rails
passenger rail service
uh I have my issues uh with the commuter
rail they're talking about because it
doesn't do weekends
it's just talking about during the week
I also should point out too that I'm a
member of train riders Northeast which
is the advocacy group that started the
Downeaster
and as part of that I worked as a
volunteer as a train host
helping passengers Portland Brunswick to
Boston and back
my issue with this bill is a lot of
unintended consequences
talks about economic growth mass transit
and then eviscerates it my question is
Amtrak may want to put in service from
Boston to Manchester Concord this could
preclude that
train right as Northeast is working with
Maine to
create a cross-platform transfer in
Boston to a train to New York City
to me this is an Avenue for tourism
a lot of Europeans United States Asians
whatever are very comfortable using
trains
and I think that would be very favorable
for New Hampshire for people to come who
don't want to rent a car don't want to
drive
so I I call that potential growth uh
it's an option and uh I think there
would be this would be a detriment to
that type of service and I close with
just a couple of thoughts that not
they're not my thoughts I read them
years ago
uh Americans love Mobility
not necessarily the automobile
if you can get somewhere the other
another way you may choose that if you
have that option and the other one I
always like to think about when I look
at any kind of a project not just rail
is
subsidy
subsidies to me is if you don't like the
project
if you like a project
it's investment
and I think there would be a lot of
investment into New Hampshire
with passenger rail service
thank you thank you for your testimony
sir any questions to the gentleman
seeing none thank you
I have no other ping cards uh for House
Bill 110
is closed
we will move right to House Bill 606 FN
requiring construction of state
buildings or state-funded projects to
contain electric vehicles EV charging
infrastructure
and I would like to
recognize
Michael Fitzgerald
for the prime sponsor I'm sorry do I
drive the sponsor here I don't have any
part
lucious I I don't have I don't have a
card I don't have a card from you
hey no we had cards
you certainly can why don't you get
started that would be great thank you so
much sir
let's see something pink that's my bile
no I know I had it vote
okay sounds great thank you
I apologize for the confusion
representative just please introduce
yourself and we'll grab a pink card on
the way out
thank you thank you committee thank you
chair for the opportunity addresses this
year
all right
electric field infrastructure refers to
the network of charging stations and
other sporting systems needed to power
EVS
the development and expansion of PV
infrastructure is crucial for the
anticipation adoption of EVS it's no
longer a question of if we switch to EVS
but how soon
CNN recently projected that EV sales
will outstrip internal combustion
Vehicles by 2040 17 years from now
as of 2021 New Hampshire had 4 000 EVS
registered
California leads by a wide margin of the
563 thousand
representing 42 percent of all
registered cars in their state
I am could I have you suspend the
gentleman with the camera could you move
ahead of
the representatives I'd appreciate it
and you should have room to do your work
go right ahead sir thank you
politics aside auto manufacturers are
listening and adjusting their production
of EVS
States other than New Hampshire are
driving the demand for EPs and like it
or not the free market is transitioning
away from internal combustion engines
House Bill 606 is drafted in response to
this Market Direction
if predictions for future charging
stations are to be met the time delayed
the infrastructure to meet these needs
is now
undeniably the laying of electric cable
is much easier when it's part of the
original construction rather in
retrofitting in an existing structure
this bill makes scant requirements for
what's above ground but ensures a vital
cable is in place as preparation for a
charging station so I should stop here
and add that the title of the bill enact
I find that may be a little bit
misleading so I'm really addressing more
of the body of the bill
now having a driven electric vehicle
myself perhaps it might be helpful to
discuss what is meant by EV ready
you have an EV if you have a 120 volt
electric dryer in your house
none of your house is already EV ready
by virtual having that receptacle
available it'll look something like this
if I may use a visual age Aid
um summer three prong this one happens
before this is from an EV not for my
dryer
um EV capable means that the wiring is
installed but the plug is absent
EV installed means that I bring the
charging cable that came with the
purchase of my EV and plug it into the
220 volt receptacle
aside from Tesla all EVS are universally
capable of plugging to a standard 220
volt receptacle
on the other end is a meter the branch
circuit can be tied to an existing meter
or employ a standalone meter
this being said in the case of an
apartment complex
each branch circuit can be conducted to
the meter of a particular residence
going off just one of this one second if
you and if you remember a few years ago
we had two meters on our houses one for
water
we could do the same conceivably for
electric vehicles
um in the case of a fleet a circuit we
run on a time and meter obviously
now while I've invested various codes on
the way to recommendations listed in
this bill but I am very open adjusting
these recommendations either by
Amendment or by subcommittee
these are changing times and I hope the
committee can seize the bill as an
opportunity for the future rather into a
threat to our status quo I asked for an
OTP and thank the committee for their
time I'll take any questions thank you
representative questions question please
thank you Mr chairman
the question I have when the automobile
came in to be the combustion engine
automobile came in to be uh who financed
all the gas stations to be put in place
as an infrastructure
and with that being said since this is
electricity
with the electric company be a better
place to install or have the ability to
install these charging stations as it is
electricity and that is something the
electric company sales is electricity
I can under that's a very good question
thank you for the question
um
I think that the electric company would
benefit from the addition of these
vehicles because they would be able to
charge through the monthly bill
however
um as far as having them pay for the
infrastructure on an apartment complex
or a
parking garage that's funded with
federal dollars you might find it a very
hard sell to approach ever source and
ask them to put up that up
to be frank
um there is money available for charging
stations uh
uh
up and down are public highways but this
is Bill is not really about that this
bill is really about home charging
thank you uh representative Jack thank
you and uh thank you representative
partial the title is a little bit
incongruous in on line five it
specifically calls out housing which I
think is your intent that it only
applied to state-funded housing and yet
the title of the bill says state
buildings or state-funded projects which
would seem to Encompass like State
Office Buildings and and any other kind
of thing but you're specifically
targeted to housing here as it says in
the bill the bill was to Target housing
however uh in retrospect I don't think
it would be a bad idea as we build new
parking garage is to also consider
preparing ourselves for the future
would be much easier fixing a parking
garage obviously yeah so follow-up for
example and if I could ask one more
question different question
um this this amends the State Building
Code uh there's another committee that
typically deals with the State Building
Code we may not have
um is that from your research in in
developing the bill is there a problem
with amending the State Building Code in
this way that you know of
none that I'm aware of and I do
understand that we are talking building
codes here and I know sometimes we get
bills in front of us that we wonder why
they're in front of us
thank you any further questions of the
representative
thank you sir thank you I just want to
um sitting in the audience uh we have is
it Fitzgerald Michael fishon with uh New
Hampshire's fire Environmental Services
um if um if the committee has questions
of him concerning EV charging
infrastructure or the Volkswagen
settlement
foreign none we will bring you back
thank you sir
uh is there anyone else that wishes to
testify on
House Bill 606
I have no other cards
thank you we'll close house bill 606.
we will move on to House Bill 511 FN
relative requiring the Department of
Transportation do road maintenance and
repairs according to the complete
streets program
do we have the sponsoring representative
here
thank you
have a seat welcome to Public Works and
please present your testimony
and we don't I don't believe I have a
card from you so when you're finished
testifying or anyone else going forward
could you please take a pink card and
pass it down the uh that's the gentleman
that didn't Testify the last one
I'm sorry representative please please
continue
thank you very much Mr chair members of
the committee it's a pleasure to be here
for the record my name is representative
Rebecca McWilliams I'm from South
Concord you're in ward 6 which is one of
the words I represent it's a pleasure to
have you in my home District
this is a very simple bill
um
if you take a look at the language we're
adding some new statute information here
um
basically we're we're looking at uh
adding
the complete streets program
as part of
when funds are sent to a district so
when cities and towns ask for money
that work is to be performed following
the requirements of the complete streets
program as opposed to
Highway programs because we're talking
about local funds for local projects and
local main streets and therefore the
needs for things like bicycles
pedestrians are very different than if
this was an actual Highway project so
really what we're talking about here is
adding new language to integrate a
program that makes this more pedestrian
friendly and more walkable for our towns
specifically rural but really any town
that needs funding to to do a project so
the intent here is to make complete
streets the default not something that
the city or town has to struggle to
achieve or overcome a barrier just by
way of background the aashto or ash toe
standards are appropriate for State
highways but not Town streets they
prioritize rapid vehicle movement often
over 35 miles an hour rather than Street
designs for multi-modal users
towns that adopt a complete streets
policy have shown that they are
interested in having their streets safe
and welcoming to pedestrians bicycles
and other modes of transportation in
addition to automobiles so that using
the nacto standards nacto standards is
appropriate a complete streets policy
identifies the roadways of a town or
city that the jurisdiction believes
should be improved for multi-modal use
so this is something the jurisdiction
wants not something be imposed by the
state and once again this intends to
make this more friendly for pedestrians
bicycles things other than Automobiles
and so that's the the gist of the bill
and I have to admit that I'm not an
expert on the subject matter there are
people after me who will have much more
technical responses but I'm happy to
take questions thank you thank you
representative I
I don't I do not have any cards from any
one department or anyone else
oh I have I I have a card here from uh
representative Horrigan
so I just I just want to caution you on
that yes ma'am
there was a same thing it's right here
I hate to trouble you but could you just
please fill out another card for us
please
thank you
um if if I could sure representative so
I'm I'm a fan of of
complete streets but I'm I'm
I and maybe I missed it uh can you
explain to me maintenance and repairs
and what you're anticipating the
department to do I I offer most projects
for even a simple sidewalk in my rural
area requires that the town is going to
plow and maintain those structures so
with money is limited maybe I'm missing
something tell me what you believe
maintenance and repairs would be
my understanding would be it would be a
little bit more extensive than just a
sidewalk repair something like if there
are new utilities coming through and
you're going to have some kind of
infrastructure such as manholes and
repaving
Etc then considering complete streets as
part of that project
and I'm sorry if I could follow up
so you would like to be to the table
when those projects after the after it's
been decided by the town or your
Regional Commission that this area is
qualified for this project
whom whom would pay for manholes Paving
and all and all of that work the cost to
put underground utilities and so forth
so as always it depends right every
project is different you may have
applied for a grant you may have gotten
some federal funds as part of your your
walkable downtown or maybe not maybe the
town is just going to pay for this out
of their own pocket so it really depends
on who's going to pay for it for the
town and the project but the goal here
is really to put complete streets at the
front for the consideration of these
kinds of projects so that we're not
designing to the standards of 35 Plus
miles an hour rather we're designing 235
or below and therefore as part of the
planning and deciding how to spend the
funds we're considering walkability and
bicycling
thank you you're welcome and I and I see
now the department is going to speak so
anyone else with questions for the
representative
yes represent Faulkner and I think this
is a
quick answer
this could at least there's been Vision
that every project every street project
every new construction project comply
with this design standard to accommodate
other other modes or that you know are
there are there pedestrian friendly
streets versus traffic friendly streets
versus Transit streets
what kind of flexibility would a
municipality have
that's an excellent question thank you
um I would say that the intention here
is to consider complete streets as part
of doing the project that doesn't mean
that it's Bible that doesn't mean that
that's exactly what happens but it's a
consideration so just as an example my
district includes
um Concord and some of you have driven
on Loudon Road in Concord it's a Strode
right it's kind of a combination Street
Road it's got four lanes and an awful
lot of strip retail there are sidewalks
but I wouldn't consider it particularly
friendly to bicyclists at all if you
want to use a bicycle on that road
you're taking your life in your own
hands you probably end up on the
sidewalk anyway especially when there's
snow on the ground so that's the kind of
development area that I think would be
good for considering
this program that doesn't mean it's
going to change a lot but it could
change something
thank you
anyone else uh with the question yes
please go ahead representative yes thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question does this um
National Association of City traffic
officials or the complete Street
advisories committee do they have any
regulatory Authority whatsoever
and yes they do yes
thank you for the question further
question yeah quick one so if somebody
doesn't do what they say they want them
to do what happens then
uh so I believe there would be a
discussion right there would probably be
a letter issued you know you intended to
do this program with complete streets
and then it fell through there would be
a discussion and a follow-up I I don't
believe there would be a fine if that's
what you're asking but there there are
certainly goals to achieve and if you
fail to achieve them then there's a
discussion of what will we do to
remediate the situation
thank you thank you
further questions thank you
representative thank you
like to recognize Ivy Vaughn
it couldn't get much worse could it
losing your card and then not spelling
your name
okay please thank you so much chairman
and thank you members of this committee
on which I actually served for a term I
think three years ago anyway it's nice
to be back uh this is a bill that I
filed before I lost my primary thank you
Rebecca for picking it up for me the
goal here is all the things that Rebecca
said right now if it's Town decides that
it would like its Main Street which is a
state highway to be a street rather than
a road it is hard to make that
negotiation work all the time often uh
does the Department of Transportation
correctly uses the American Association
of state highway traffic officials
standards for state highways those are
the ashto standards they're intended for
through streets for through roads
they're in 10 did for higher volumes
higher speeds most of the towns in New
Hampshire are bifurcated
by a state highway and that State
Highway often functions as the main
street for the town
when we run a
a highway through the middle of the Town
it is not a great fit for the town for
the businesses for the people it turns
out that cars don't buy things people do
so what the goal here is is to make our
main streets when they are a state
highway more like a street slower more
complete available for Walkers and
bicyclists than people in Mobility
assisted Mobility
that's what this is intended to do is to
say that if a town has identified
the state highway that forms a piece of
their town as a place where they want to
see complete streets ideals instituted
this bill says
the Department of Transportation has to
has to support that the National
Association of City traffic officials
produces a book I think they updated
about every three or four years it's
green it's known as the green book and
it has within it all of the standards
four streets that are usable for all
modes of transportation it doesn't mean
that the cars are not welcome or that
you can't drive a log truck down it it
means that it's going to be slower and
safer and available
for all users not just people in
vehicles so that's the goal here is to
put that conversation about what do we
want this street to look like right at
the beginning of the conversation so
that towns don't feel like they're
battling
the desire to make this more like a
highway
and I'm happy to take questions oh and
the other thing I always forget to say
uh I am actually an urban planner which
is why I care deeply about this
um and and my interest in this goes back
to the idea of building places that are
good for all people not just for people
who are temporarily driving vehicles
so I'm happy to accept questions thank
you representative Jack please uh thank
you Mr chairman and it's good to see you
again uh former representative uh I
remember when we did the original study
I went looking for what is in current
law with respect to what people have to
do with respect to complete streets and
I wasn't able to find it I wonder if you
know what current law is there isn't a
law now that says that you have to do it
we talked about it I think it was in my
first term which would have been 2014.
we had a bill that would have said that
the dot would use the complete Street
standards
um I can't remember what the parameters
were but we did talk about it but in the
end
um it kind of fizzled and I don't think
I think the bill was withdrawn so so I
don't think there's anything now
thank you further questions
yes represent boy thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative van for taking
my question
the bill is proposed how do you see this
being compatible with local land boards
having the ability to plan their own
main streets
um in independent from obviously they're
within an urban compact the state record
you know do you see this complementing I
mean it can can this be enabling that
gives me the spell is the flexibility of
actually opting in if they see value to
it right that's exactly what it does
because what it says is that in order
for this to go into effect the town has
to have adopted a complete streets
policy and identified the the street
road Highway in question as a place
where they want to see complete streets
techniques and standards employed
so it's an opt-in for the town
thank you
um if if I could sure so I'm still hung
up on on the language of this and just
briefly looked at the bill again
um and it's talking about the the
department to do road maintenance and
repairs
so you start out the process and towns
favorable and town wants to use the this
practice and they want to make their
Route 16 that runs through their Town
something where people can move and
bicycle and so forth right
and but tell me about the maintenance
what so okay
it's the same as it is now
um now if the state is rebuilding a
state highway the state pays for it and
um if the town wants to do something
fancy
the town is responsible for the payment
so the payment would re would remain the
same so for example
um uh Route 202 goes through the town of
Peterborough and becomes Concord Street
um when I was talking to the department
about Concord Street and Peterborough
has in fact adopted a complete Street
policy and identified Concord Street as
a street that needs to be more
pedestrian and bicycle friendly
um the state was paying for it and their
their interest in providing a narrower
travel Lane and on-street parking both
of which serve to slow traffic
was somewhat Limited
but back to your question about payment
the payment would break down the same as
it does now if it's a state highway the
state pays for it they just use the
nacto standards if the town wants
something that is not the nacto
standards one something fancier then
they pay for it as they do now for
example burying burying utility lines is
I think nearly always a town expense and
under this bill that would remain the
same does that help at all I understand
it to me it just doesn't seem like a
clear line but I'll speak to the
department yeah I mean and maybe we
could have an amendment that made it
more clearer what I'm trying to prevent
is the state has regularly scheduled
maintenance and rebuilding of Roads when
they come to do that
we want them to use the standards that
the town wants if the town has
identified this as a place where they
want those nacto standards and the
complete Street standards which are
virtually the same
then the state would do it without a
giant battle thanks thank you for your
response yes representative
thank you Mr chairman so when they do
the maintenance and let's say it's just
a regular
Highway going in okay and then the town
says Okay I want it to meet this new
criteria okay and
it now adds a greater expense on that
maintenance and does that it's a
question yeah and the second part of
that is
if there's no available land without
having to buy more land who's
responsible for if they have to widen
the road during in order to accommodate
right the question of widening the road
I think is not usually a problem because
real usually the issue is what we're
doing is reducing the road width the
lane width so that then we have property
available for other modes of
transportation so I think I think that's
less likely to be an issue the question
of is this going to be more expensive
sometimes it is sometimes it isn't
however we budget money for the
Department to build roads and I think
that asking them to build the roads that
people want is is okay
um it would it could in some cases mean
a little more money it could in some
cases mean less money because of that
particularly for routine maintenance
events routine resurfacing if you've
narrowed your lanes then your cost for
routine resurfacing is going to be less
than it would be if you had a 14-foot
Lane
and as a former member of Public Works
it's a pleasure to have you back in Rome
thank you it's nice to be back I'm
available if I mean I'm easy to find on
the internet
[Laughter]
Reach Out questions thank you so much
all right I would like to bring a New
Hampshire Department of Transportation
Bill Watson forward please excuse me
bill it's always a pleasure to have you
here
and welcome and welcome to public works
thank you
so good afternoon chairman for the
record my name is Bill Watson
I'm the administrator in the Bureau of
planning and Community Assistance at the
Department of Transportation
I'm happy to be here with our assistant
commissioner Dave rodrigue between the
two of us hopefully we can answer any
questions that might come up thank you a
pleasure to have you also
um
so there is written testimony
signed by myself on behalf of the
department that talks to the bill
as it was presented
generally speaking
we are
in opposition to House Bill 511 FN as
it's written
there is a couple of technical issues
with the bill
that I'll get into momentarily Deputy
Commissioner Brier was here earlier to
talk about a different bill
and our opposition to the bill doesn't
mean that we're in opposition of
complete streets approaches to
transportation we are a multimodal
agency
whether that is vehicle or pedestrian or
bicycle Transit rail air whatever that
mode is we are a multimodal agency and
we are in support of implementing
capital projects that that meet those
needs and meet those desires throughout
the state
um I've been with the state for just
over 30 years
when I first started we got into this
um
program or effort of what we called
context sensitive Solutions
context sensitive designs
probably a precursor to what people call
complete streets today
and the approach that that represented
is simply this we work with a community
we listen to them we spend a lot of time
with them more time on some projects
than others depending on the complexity
depending on the work that's proposed to
understand what their needs are to
understand what their wants are
and then we try to develop
strategies to meet their needs within
the constraints that we have sometimes
those constraints are physical
how much roadway with do you have to
work with it goes to some of the
questions that were asked maybe of
previous previous people that were
sitting in this chair
um it also goes to financial constraints
operations maintenance in the long term
Etc
so
that's something we've been doing
for years and and we have that approach
we are committed to following that
approach with all of our projects that
we fund and are involved with
specifically to the opposition to this
bill I mentioned a couple of technical
issues I mentioned two in the letter
um
one
I think their need there we would
recommend a correction if this bill were
to move forward we can't find that
there's a National Association of City
traffic officials
or any documents to that that they would
represent there is a National
Association of city transportation
officials and unfortunately there are
new New Hampshire cities
or towns represented as part of that
group
so what is being proposed in legislation
is that we are asked to adopt standards
and guidelines
that know
city or town in New Hampshire
has already bought into
as part of that National Organization
the other thing that we see in the
legislation is that there needs to be
coordination there's reference in the
legislation to complete streets advisory
committee
um
reading the legislation in its entirety
that is reference to RSA 22849
and and functions of the Department of
Transportation and how that fits into
maintenance and repairs and such I think
there's been a few I know there's been a
few questions as it relates to that
um in that same context we have a
complete streets advisory committee
within a department it's our
understanding as we read the legislation
that every project that would be coming
forward would have to be reviewed by
that complete speech advisory committee
within our department
um
that's a something that
we fear is is will bring a lot of work
that we're not prepared for for an
advisory committee that's both staffed
from the Department as well as external
volunteers that didn't intend to be part
of that sort of process
so those are the two technical items
that we saw with the bill I think the
third that I would add separate from
what's in the written testimony
is that there is the overall question
about
um if this language as proposed really
fits into RSA 22849
is this really about the Department of
Transportation being involved RSA 22849
in a general sense is
um giving the department the
commissioner of the Department of
Transportation the authority to do
repairs and maintenance of roadways on
behalf of communities and municipalities
and I'm not sure that from what I've
heard and what I've read that that's
really the intent of what's being
um proposed here
thank you
um questions to the committee
yes representative
I'm going to follow up a question I
asked earlier uh it seems to be a more
appropriate
place to ask the question in the lane
with as you start to shrink these Lanes
down it was referred to as
a calming effect of the speed of the
vehicles and
in theory
I guess that works in theory but in
reality do we find that that actually
works by shrinking the lanes down where
the cars are growing bigger and you got
bigger trucks and bigger things is that
a safe way of doing things by shrinking
it down
foreign
Mr chair members of the committee my
name's David rodrigue I'm the assistant
commissioner for the Department of
Transportation shrinking the lanes down
is a strategy that the department uses
in some cases to do exactly what you're
describing to calm the traffic our
typical Lane width is 12 foot wide we
will go down to 11 and sometimes a
little bit narrower than 11 but we get
very concerned when we start talking
about whiffs below 10 and a half feet
and so forth so we do shrink Lanes as a
way of calming traffic but we have
limits to the extent that that we will
reduce those lines Lane whips thank you
yes please representative thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question if this legislation was passed
do you feel that it could sometimes
really slow down what you guys are
trying to do because now you've got to
get a hold of these organizations and
people
and then you've got to maybe explain to
them why you're doing what you're doing
when you know what you're doing because
the D.O.T does a great job in my opinion
but thank thank you for that
um I do want to address that the the RSA
that this legislation
um proposes to change that is RSA
228.49
RSA
228.49 is requested maintenance and
repair projects the truth is the
Department of Transportation
particularly with our current Staffing
levels but at all times does very little
work under this statute what this statue
allows is communities to ask the
department with our forces in equipment
and so forth to come in and help a town
do a project the department is not
currently set up to do this type of work
um the last time that I can think of
that we used it was during an ice storm
in the town of them first when there
were lots of trees down lots of road
closed school was closed for days and
the department was asked to come in and
help to clear some of the debris and we
used this statute to do that that work
we don't normally on a year to year do
do work under this statute for
communities I think the spirit of this
bill would like to say anytime we
resurface a road or come into a
community to do work on a state road
that we follow these contact sensitive
design guidelines and and so forth our
our resurfacing program is very
streamlined these these days we do as
little ancillary work in those projects
as possible so that we can pave as many
miles as possible so that we can improve
the condition of our roadways we've been
very focused on that for the last eight
to ten years and thanks to additional
funding that was passed in SB 367 we've
made great progress on
improving pavement conditions in our
roadways so if this was passed in its
Spirit it would mean any of those
routine maintenance projects where we're
coming in to to pave with some
efficiency
um would it would slow down the process
and it would create more discussion and
preparation of those projects and if
additional work was included
um would take funds from that
resurfacing work
thank you
um I think that was clear
uh repsham Jack uh thank you Mr chairman
uh so if I understood what you just said
even if we thought this was a good idea
there's a major drafting error in that
it amends the wrong RSA in your opinion
in my opinion there is
thank you a further question yes
representative Jewish thank you chair
William on paragraph two of the letter
it talks about collaboration with local
officials
for uh coordinating uh what they might
want for those who live and work and
travel and you know in in that town
how does that differ from the intended
legislation
if it sounds like you're you're going to
work with them anyway to to downtown
it's a state road they want complete
streets you're saying you you do this
so just for clarification purposes
um
the assistant commissioner just
identified a couple of scenarios so we
have the Amherst ice storm scenario
which we believe that RSA 22849
really applies to
we have the routine maintenance and
resurfacing type of work that we do
that we try to be as efficient and
stretch those dollars as far as we can
and then we have our Capital program our
10-year plan that that you will all see
as part of Public Works and highways
that that many know about that includes
all of our federal and state and local
funded projects that that come through
the the the gaset and legislative and
Governor's process in all of those
projects that the department is involved
with yes we are having public
informational meetings we are having
public officials meetings if we are
doing a project in a downtown area in
many cases
the town is managing that project
themselves and has the lead management
role my office my Bureau we have over
400 million dollars worth of locally
driven projects ongoing in a 10-year
plan right now where the towns if they
have complete speech policies are
already
applying those complete streets
approaches or those policies to the
projects that we are involved with in
funding
but from day one on those projects that
are in the capital program this is the
approach that we are already supporting
and have been for as long as I can
remember in the department and that's
I can't remember back to day one 30
years ago but it's been about that long
thank you
uh thank you Mr chairman
and thanks for taking my question
back in 2016 it was a committee that met
in fact two of the individuals that are
sitting here were on that committee and
it had to do with this uh a lot of it
had to do with the complete Street
program and there were several
recommendations were made and from what
you just described what you do maybe you
don't need these recommendations or
maybe they would maybe they were taken
but
one of them was uh create a more
formalized criteria to help prioritize
complete streets related project
applications
do you have any idea if that was done or
do that's just your standard operating
procedure there is not a set aside
program for complete streets projects
complete streets projects could be
funded through
a dozen different Federal funding
sources or other funding sources that we
we work with and deal with on a regular
basis it's just part of our process it's
part of what we're we're trained and
hired to do
okay thanks though I want to ask you
about the two other recommendations then
thank you
thank you representative any further
questions yes please represent Bart it's
just a clarification question uh based
on your previous answer not to this
question the one previous to that one
um
should this kind of stuff be going to
the 10-year plan is what I'm
understanding you're saying when they
have a major project that's not just a
resurfacing and stuff that maybe that
should be addressed on a 10-year plan
and not on your maintenance plan is that
what I understood
from my perspective and my opinion our
maintenance programs are intended to to
do just that maintain what is their
and and keep those roads and those
bridges in service and as good a
condition as possible I do believe that
complete streets approach
context-sensitive approach to projects
that are in a 10-year plan
are appropriate to discuss in all cases
and with coordination with the towns
then you can determine which of those
components
our best to be implemented given the
constraints you have to work with
if I may yes please if I may to to
follow up I I do want to be clear even
our resurfacing program we have maps on
our websites that show where we plan to
resurface and so forth and if
communities bring changes to us in lane
whiffs and so forth they would like us
to consider as part of that work we are
certainly open to to that communication
and we work to to let people know where
we're coming and when we'll be there so
that we can have those discussions
thank you any further questions
sure thank you chair real quick thank
you what so in in your in your efforts
if if the if the town asks for a
a bike lane or an extended sidewalk or a
bump out that's not your purview
you're not necessarily going to
accommodate it
again it depends on the circumstances of
the project
um a bump out
our maintenance if that is a roadway
that our our Highway Maintenance
districts are responsible for
maintaining they're going to encourage
us to try to accommodate that Crossing
that what that bump out is trying to
achieve perhaps in some other way or
they need to change their their
maintenance their plowing Arrangements a
little bit if a town asks for a sidewalk
as part of a project we will try to
accommodate them and we will make sure
there's a local agreement in place so
that when that sidewalk is completed the
town takes over the maintenance and
operations responsibility for that
um but it's as part of a larger project
or depending on some of our federal
programs there are Standalone sidewalker
stand-alone Trail projects that can that
can occur
thank you
I I'm starting to feel like we're talked
out here is there anyone else who would
like one more question
thank you gentlemen thank you
my last speaker is representative Horgan
and I would just like to uh before I
bring you up
uh we have some folks on the other side
in room 203 that are setting up office
have drinks and so forth when you leave
will you please make sure that your
furniture goes back to where it was and
all drinks are taken with you when you
leave the room thank you representative
horian I'd like to recognize you you
have you have written testimony here and
your first line is I could go on for a
long time about complete streams they've
already done so I well I thank you I'm
representative Timothy Horrigan from
dropper County District 10 and um
my original expectation was a few days
ago that
um Reverend McWilliams was going to be
unable to attend the hearing and happily
she was and then representative van we
weren't sure whether or not she could
come and she came so uh you know they
maybe explained what a complete street
is it's a street that uh serves them
serves everyone and I cited an example I
said it was a good example the expert
said it was more of a not bad example or
a pretty good example which is a Main
Street in Concord and I'm sure we're all
those of us who serve weren't a couple
of terms we'll also remember when it was
extensively renovated um using a lot of
the complete Street principles although
there's a few things missing like it
doesn't have a separate bike lane but
it's a I mean it was a pretty good
pedestrian friendly space even before
the end result is uh like is superb it's
quite it's quite nice and then on the
opposite what just I made of the term of
an incomplete Street a good example
might be Loudon Road in Concord and both
Main Street and Loudon Road are also
State highways um
and uh
ironically uh makes me I think it's
actually easier to drive up the length
of Main Street than Loudoun Road even
though Loudon Road was pretty design
thinking only of the motor vehicles you
know they have a few perfunctory
sidewalks and so forth but
um I think it's actually even though
it's probably slower I think it's
actually easier to drive up Main Street
it's less stressful it's more uh it's
more more
it's more orderly it's just generally a
better driving experience at least in my
opinion and um these three programs they
talked about there is a commission and I
figured that would administer the
program that the Department of
Transportation uh I guess disagreed with
that point so that's something you'll
have to work out
but it
um at least the rudiments of of a
program of a the program are in place
um
one thing I will admit it uh
it does you know it demands more the
bare minimum you know we're not going to
do it's demands we do things with more
thoughts and just the quickest and
cheapest way to do it and uh that may
seem at odds with the New Hampshire way
but also New Hampshire has dozens maybe
hundreds of beautiful Villages towns and
cities of various sizes and um
some of them are world famous tourist
attractions um
and their Central districts were all
designed to be fairly pedestrian
friendly and to serve a wide variety of
uses in a compact space and uh
I'd say they're pretty close to what we
now refer to as complete streets the
classic New England Town Center so
we act we're actually my opinion we're
probably going back to the way we did
things back in the quote unquote good
old days so that's um
that's why I think this is oh and one
thing we're talking about the length of
the width so I just happen to like do a
little quick Googling there actually is
a set width for the maximum width of a
vehicle that can go in the highway so
that's uh
I think it's 102 inches so that's eight
feet six inches so I guess school buses
are uh can be up to nine feet so like a
10 foot travel Lane is enough to
accommodate just about anything that
goes down the highway without like a
whole lot of trouble so thank you thank
you representative
are there any questions for the
representative
seeing none thank you sir thank you
we will call House Bill
515 FN to a close
for for the people uh uh here for House
Bill 361 it's nothing but apologies to
you my scheduling was off and we're
going to give you our full attention
thank you
do I have a sponsor here for
foreign
thank you
got you down at the bottom give me a big
rep next time
thank you please be seated and uh
proceed
thank you
my name is Jackie groda I'm a
representative rep from Rockingham 24
representing the towns of Rye in
Greenland
my in my previous District I also I
represented the towns of rye and
Newcastle so I'm familiar with my
previous District as well
House Bill 361 came about as a request
from the town from our my constituents
and the select board as well as the
select board from Newcastle
when the peace Development Authority was
first developed was first implemented
the area of the PDA was defined to the
area that we know now as the piece of
airport
um
the trade port
and since that time Harbors had been
added to the responsibility of the peace
Development Authority
because Rye is contiguous now with at
the beginning
the towns that were part of that were
represented on the peace Development
Authority were those towns that were
contiguous with what is now known as
pre-piece trade forth
there was no representation for towns
that were now part of the that were
contiguous with the harbors
so the town of Newcastle you may have
you will have received a letter early
from the select Board of Newcastle
because the naval base is is contiguous
with Newcastle and the Rye Harbor is
contiguous with Rye
so
um originally this bill was asking for
representation on the peace development
board
but we've I've submitted an amendment
that is amendment I believe I sent it to
you today
[Music]
okay I have a copy of it would you like
to see it would you like we need to have
the amendment you can discuss the sort
of things you might put on the
Amendments yes okay that's right I'm
asking the committee to consider this
amendment no that's my point is we don't
have a copy of your Amendment all right
let me uh let me just tell you what I
would like to put on the amendment
please
so rather than having the we're asking
we didn't want to expand the board and
change the membership because that's a
very cumbersome process so we chose a
position that exists now which is that
member appointed by the Speaker of the
House
and what we would like to have is a
reporting relationship with that member
so that they can report to the towns of
Ryan Newcastle on a regular basis the
deliberations of the peace Development
Authority
I
okay thank you for that let me just
make sure I understand what you're
saying
in your proposal you would not be
looking to add a member to but you would
ask that the member that is appointed
now by the speaker would report on a
regular basis the business that's before
them
okay thank you yes exactly as specific
to the towns of Ryan Newcastle really if
it doesn't affect them they don't need
to know okay thank you welcome this is
we will need to uh we will need to get a
copy a copy of your Amendment brought to
us and then
um would you like it in paper form or I
have sent it to you electronically to
your email you didn't get it paper paper
yeah I will have attention and run it
run it by the normal Services bring us
in a uh bring us in a stamp for the
amendment Mr chair yes electronically
223-0314h it is an approved Watermark oh
okay thank you all right we're just
going to need to get that in here we Pro
is this a this is not an early bill is
it don't know not due until March 16th
okay thank you you're welcome
I have
um I have here
uh
Thomas King Rye select board
King if you'd come forward identify
yourself
uh good afternoon my name is Tom King
I'm a vice chair of the right Rye select
board speaking for the select board
today in support of this bill
thanks for allowing Excuse Me Miss King
are you in support of the proposed
amendment or the original Bill the
original Bill okay thank you go ahead
um thanks for allowing us to speak today
we believe that Ryan Newcastle should
have a direct representation on the peas
Development Authority board to ensure
that we can be informed about policies
projects that affect our towns in a in a
timely fashion the lack of this uh
direct representation we view is almost
a historical accident due to the fact
that the ports and harbors oversight was
added after the fact and uh
um and and was the representation was
not really updated at that time to take
into account those towns that were uh in
which those Harbors uh resided we have
seven of the harbors between rye and
Newcastle and uh we think it's only fair
to correct this uh situation at this
time
um
in Rye in particular were uh
realizing the difficulty of uh dealing
with
policies that are from the peace
Development Authority board
if you don't have a seat at the table
we just asked for the this ability so
that we can properly uh represent our
constituents
so we do support the original bill as
written
um thank you for letting me speak thank
you Mr King is there any questions for
yes represent Mills
uh thank you thank you for taking my
question so you say you support the
original Bill what about the amendment
as you heard it written or as you heard
it spoken do you support the amendment
which changes a little bit it doesn't
give you a seat it gives you
representation from a seat that already
exists I think
correct the original build is the same
as the representation from a seat that
already exists
um my view of the amendment is that it
deletes the requirement for or the of
input of seeking our input this the
amendment merely asked that we be report
that deliberations are reported to US
versus us having input to a member and
so we would prefer the original Bill
thank you thank you
further question
seeing none thank you
I'd like to recognize Matthews grutton
the town of Rye
welcome to Public Works
please introduce yourself
yeah there you go
I apologize thank you good afternoon Mr
chair and members of the committee my
name is Matthew scrutin I'm the Town
Administrator in Rye and I'm here today
to support the original bill 361.
um representative groda and select board
member and vice chair Tom King have
already reviewed a number of points that
I agree with and support and I have
submitted my written testimony so I
won't go through it line by line but I'm
here again to support the original Bill
if there were to be an amendment I
believe a town would want to make sure
that the position the the board seat not
only has the
um
original uh or rather that the the town
still can provide input to the board
seat uh the way the amendment is written
it it almost appears as if the amendment
tries to take away the ability of the
town to uh consult with and advise and
make recommendations to that board seat
I want to be clear that the town is
looking for somebody that they can go to
with concerns uh and with questions uh
they don't just want a
report they want input so that's the
point I think is important to make if
there is an amendment and that is what
the town would desire
thank you
um
uh questions from the committee
if if I could sir
so limited knowledge on the Seacoast I
don't think we have a lot of it so you
got to put up with me further up north
so the um we have the port in Portsmouth
and does any part of that facility touch
on to Rye Rye has a excellent question
uh the Roy has Rye Harbor Little Harbor
and gosport
Newcastle has Goat Island Goat Island
back Channel Hearts Cove and Portsmouth
Yacht Club
thank you for that I underst I
understand that there are many Harbors
in there but does does the peace
Authority on the on that property does
it it does not tie directly to
your town
only the the harbors um and if I'm if I
may call upon selectman King if I'm
mistaken but my understanding is that
the only Three Harbors uh that impact
Rye would be Rye Harbor Little Harbor
and gosport
yeah just I I apologize for going online
if I was standing at the at the Port
peace Port down there which were the
committee many times has been down there
to see the operation the expansion and
everything else can I step on to your
towns from there
I'm not aware I'm sorry I'm not aware if
you could or could not at that location
I'm looking I'm sorry I'm looking it
back for advice from one of the
residents of rye
there you go
are you speaking of the peace
development trade Port where where lonza
has their facilities and well I'm
thinking down to the port itself oh yes
the pier yes
is located I'm sorry in which town
it's located in Rye it is located yes
the right heart the right yes that part
is located in Rai that's what I was
talking about yeah thank you
thank you
um seeing no further questions
may I
thank you I'd like to recognize
um
Bob Cheney from peace Development
Authority please
which is the only other card I have if
there's someone else that wishes to
speak you two gentlemen free to sit
together thank you sorry
oh we have two people on this card
yes okay that's a little interesting
okay thank you Mr chairman thank you
committee members I'm Paul Breen I'm the
executive director of the peas
Development Authority I'm joined with uh
councilor Bob Chaney who um historically
wrote 12g statue which created the peas
Development Authority Mr Cheney was also
on board when the state decided to
give peas Development Authority
administrative oversight of the division
in ports and harbors we're prepared
today to provide any context or
answering any questions that you may
have
foreign
excuse me does the authority weigh in
opposed or supporting the bill
chairman Dupree uh the peace Development
Authority chairman of the board has
issued a written uh letter and submitted
that
um I I do not have the authority to wait
on the bill I would go back to my board
and and get full support for that
um but I would be happy to provide any
any insight today that I could uh inform
the legislative about the peas
Development Authority and specifically
um
what we do for clarity I would like to
to identify that as far as division in
ports and harbors we currently have
administrative oversight of the Market
Street
um deep water wolfridge pier in
Portsmouth New Hampshire the Portsmouth
fish Pier which is dedicated to
commercial fishing and recreational
fishing within Portsmouth
Hampton Harbor in Rye Harbor and we're
responsible for all the Moorings along
the the the the the Seacoast but
specifically uh Rye Harbor
um
is is our only
um our only actual Landing facility in
in right thank you
your
um your meetings I'm sure are published
in public
and it would it would seem to me
that issues that arise uh by these two
towns would fall under due consideration
by by your Authority
Mr chairman that's correct all of our
meetings including our subcommitting
meetings our public meetings all of our
meetings whether it's dph division of
ports and harbors a public you know
publicly noticed uh welcome and minutes
are reported
um and posted online uh accordingly
thank you questions the committee yes
representative Jack uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you gentlemen for
appearing uh if I understand the there
is one House member on the on the
commission as it is on the on the
authority on the board
and if you will that member would
represent at large all of the towns that
uh impinge on the PDA and this the
effect of this the original bill would
be to specialize that member to only
represent Ryan Newcastle thereby
depriving all of the other towns of that
person's uh representation is that your
understanding that's how I understand
the bill and yes we we currently have a
a Speaker of the House appointee
foreign
yes thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question at your meetings do
you allow public comment or republican
for it
we do okay thank you
further questions
uh gentlemen we don't have a copy of Mr
Dupree's letter here in committee today
I didn't know point of order yes
um the letter was sent to us via email
just so you know last night I did have
the opportunity to review chairman
Duprees uh letter it was about three
about two and a half pages in length the
gist of it was expressing opposition to
to the bill just so that it's added to
the record thank you
thank you
any other further questions Mr chairman
I can provide 20 copies thank you I
really appreciate that and and is there
possibly a map that shows where your
facilities lie in also
you're with the the towns that your
Authority has oversight in Mr chairman
yes and Mr Dupree's letter there's
actually a map attached to them as an
exhibit okay thank you
and if if you can if you can indulge me
in one question then I'll come back to
uh representative Jack
when when these Development Authority
was first initiated
was it to the benefit of only the towns
that it was in because I'm of the
understanding that is supposed to
benefit the entire state
could you answer that question
yes Mr chair
um
again my name is Bob Cheney
when the peace Development Authority was
created in uh
legislation in 1990 I was then associate
attorney general in the Attorney
General's office and I was detailed to
work for the peace Development Authority
when we established the statute and and
the thing to remember about the peace
Development Authority and the way the
statute is set up that's very important
is that this is a state facility it is
state-owned land it is the state that
has an obligation when when the state
took this property through the peas
Development Authority from the federal
government the state made a commitment
to the federal government that we would
operate that airport as a public airport
essentially forever
if we ever stop operating it as a public
airport there's a reverter clause in the
Deeds that came to the state in 2003 and
2005 and it all reverts back to the
federal government
so this is a state agency the peas
Development Authority it's it's
obviously a little different and if you
had time and the interest I could
explain how that happened but it is a
state agency somewhat different than
your typical uh
state agency but the thing to remember
about the responsibility of these board
members and if you look at the purpose
and intent of the statute in the
legislative history
the Redevelopment appease was intended
for State purposes to benefit all the
citizens of the state it says
and and so the representation the the
obligation of the board members sitting
on that board is to manage this trade
port for the benefit of the Seacoast
region but for the benefit of all the
people in the state but they are acting
as agents for the state agency you
people get nominated to participate in
this by whether it's the speaker the
Senate President the governor Portsmouth
Newington or the other municipalities
but
while the appointments may come out of
those communities they don't
it's it's it's not like being a
representative you're a board member you
have obligations to the board there are
things that are confidential
fiduciary responsibilities as a board
member to that board
and and
the proceedings are very public as the
executive director has explained but
your job is to serve on that state
agency on that state board
thank you thank you for that
uh representative and uh thank you again
if I remember the map in Mr Dupree's
letter uh it only covered the airport
and the property surrounding it and what
town that was in and now that the
division of ports and harbors is part of
the PDA I think there are other
properties on the water that I think are
the subject of this and that's what we
don't have a map of well to be clear
division Imports and harbors operates
under its own State Statute we have
General administrative oversight a
division of ports and harbors but yes
you were correct the division of ports
and harbors would would Encompass
Portsmouth Hampton Rye in the coastal
waterways
of the authority does that
excuse me but the authority does not
you you have over you have oversight of
of the port
the pier
but we have we have administrative
oversight
division in ports and harbors operates
under a separate statute
okay let me just explain please
um
when the division it was the New
Hampshire Port Authority and and it was
determined
um that the
it was in 2001 that we should merge the
New Hampshire Port Authority into the
peas Development Authority
So within the peas Development Authority
there is a division of ports and harvest
that is subject to Direction by by the
PDA board what is separate between the
two is that because of the requirements
for operating the public Airport
all of the funds generated off the trade
Port go into support of the airport
all the funds related to the division of
ports and harbors stay at the division
of ports and harbors so it's all under
one PDA organization but there are very
separate responsibilities and separate
accounting for the finances but it is
part of the Visa Development Authority
thank you any further questions
uh have you uh are you in a position the
way uh gentlemen are you in a position
to weigh in on the amended language for
this bill
I am not okay
thank you
um we have many other cards I see no
other cards
we will bring this hearing to a close
and I'd like the committee to remain
foreign
committee members we are going to caucus
Republicans will stay here this time and
our fine friends will adjourn into
Democrats our office back there yeah
we'll just we're just gonna present what
we just talked about
the peas bill by the way tests written
testing okay
whenever you want to pass it on
we will open up uh executive session uh
we are going to uh
exec House Bill 20 uh and I'll name I
will get to more specifics as we go
house bill 456.
uh House Bill 110 and house bill 62.
I'll I'll name each one as we go we'll
have a motion and a vote uh discussion
if needed
um with the help of the vice chair
um and all of you here it looks like we
will we will have exact out our early
bills
uh we were not on the schedule to meet
next week and everything else here that
requires more information we'll have
more time and we can handle it at the
beginning of uh most likely our capital
budget uh discussions
so with that I would like to pull up uh
item number one house bill 20 which was
the naming of the bridge in the town of
Merrimack for The Honorable Richard Dick
hinch
before I look for the motion uh I
everyone should have a copy of the
letter which is all that we were missing
at the time and we have that so with
that I would like to recognize
um
representative Boyd promotion
thank you Mr chairman I would humbly ask
the public works and highways committee
to move to ought to pass house bill 20.
second thank you and this and the second
one
you have the second second okay
is there any discussion
the clerk will call the roll
thank you Mr chairman
representative Cloutier
representative Mills the clerk votes yes
representative fidolfi yes
representative Newton yes representative
Kaczynski is no vote representative
Bowden
representative Boyd boy representative
Melvin yes
representative bogert
representative Connor yes
representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes representative
Edgar all right representative Faulkner
yes representative Newman yes
representative Eaton yes representative
Peterson yes representative vallone yes
representative Juris yes
chairman McConkey chairman votes eye
Mr chair the motion passes 19 to zero
thank you thank you one and all
um because of what it is I would suggest
we leave it on the regular calendar yeah
regular calendar in case somebody wants
to be there thank you John cry about it
several people
thank you
so it'll be on the regular calendar
House Bill 456
House Bill 456 is uh relative to
collecting road tolls on the output of
separately metered electric vehicle
Chargers
um
recognize represent Mills for a motion
thank you Mr chair I vote that we retain
house bill 456.
thank you do we have a second
second by uh representative Cloutier
discussion
seeing none when the clerk is ready
thank you Mr chair representative
Cloutier yes
representative Mills votes yes
representative fadolfi
representative Newton yeah
representative Kaczynski is no vote
representative Bowden
representative Boyd boy
representative Melvin yes representative
bogert
yes representative Connor
representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes representative
Edgar all right representative Faulkner
yes
representative Newman yes
representative Eaton yes
representative Peterson yes
representative vallone yes
representative Juris yes chairman
McConkey chairman votes High
to share the motion to retain passes
1901 abstention
thank you uh thank you Mr Clerk
um we will move now exec on House Bill
110 and I would look for a motion from
representative Jack thank you Mr
chairman I move to retain
motion has been made to retain second Mr
chairman
110 seconded by Boyd represent Boyd
discussion
oh I apologize I apologize I got that
train moving uh it's prohibiting the use
of State funds well it is appropriate
probing the use of State funds for new
passenger rail projects
thank you for uh making the correction
um is there any discussion
with the clerk call the roll
yes sir I will I just have one question
did we retain Bill the last one retained
consent calendar never okay
see this this is why I don't make
emotions
call names
retained is held inside the committee
and it'll be noted as that but no blurb
thank you
and the motion to retain representative
Cloutier yes
representative Mills votes yes
representative fadolfi
you were you were so good on those Zoom
ones with that with that lag yeah I can
count on it representative Newton yeah
representative Kaczynski is you know
representative Bowden
representative Boyd
side representative Melvin
yes representative Bogart yes
representative Connor
representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes
representative Edgar aye
representative Faulkner
representative Newman yes
representative Eaton
representative Peterson
yes representative vallone
representative Juris yes
chairman McConkey chairman votes High
Mr chair of the motion retained passes
to 1 abstention
thank you
our last bill that we'll take up is uh
House Bill 62 FN
relative to adjusting the road toll
um I I Look to uh Vice chairman Cloutier
for a motion uh okay Mr chairman I move
in expedient to legislate on House Bill
62. thank you motion to itl is there a
second
by Jackson Jack thank you
any discussion
Mr chairman please I have been in uh in
2014 having been involved in the effort
along with former chairman Campbell
former Senator Roush and former
representative Bouchard to raise the gas
tax very modest increase by four cents
if it had my way I would have done
increased it higher but we got that
through and that has benefit our our
state eventually
immensely and if we pass this bill it's
going to have a lot of unintended
consequences for the bondholders and and
for our state and until we finish this I
I wouldn't even think of entertaining
this lowering or eliminating the Gap
until we get done our commission report
and we Implement an alternative way to
fund our roads and bridges but I think
that's going to take several years and
so I think it would be irresponsible to
pass House Bill 62 and are we willing to
to I'll get up on the house floor and
say why and take the consequences good
or bad thank you
thank you um and I and I look forward to
seeing you up there
representative Jack uh thank you if I
could just add two things uh having to
mess with the Tiffy alone is a bad idea
which we'd have to do if we pass this
and the second thing is having to depend
on General funds being available every
single year for a number of bienniums is
a bad idea and unlike what was said is
not Revenue neutral it deprives the
general fund of those funds and it
doesn't replace them with other Revenue
thank you for the comment
yes please representative
they said I know we heard a lot about
who's subsidizing who but this bill
would basically take a user fee
reduce the amount that's paid by the
users which isn't even enough to cover
the system and make other taxpayers in
the state pay that cost I just think
the fairness of that ought to be enough
to to kill it
thank you anyone else
I just say if you want to make it
exciting instead
John's motion we should amend it to
extend for 20 years to cover the
Concrete Expansion
you're going to have fun let's have fun
okay I um I am well it sounds like fun
for a different day yeah
the uh I will say that I was here in the
house when we did pass that and there
were a lot of slings and arrows for
republicans and anyone else that stood
on that committee to even raise that bar
and I would agree I would agree with you
I'd agree with John we were on actually
unwanted posters on some sites so yeah
so with that I think we've talked that
out and we want to go home so Clark
would you call the roll please yes sir
on the motion of itl on House Bill 62.
representative Cloutier yes
representative Mills votes yes
representative fadolfi yes
yes representative Newton yeah
Kaczynski representative Bowden yes
representative Boyd boy
representative Melvin yes representative
bogert yes representative Connor
representative Jack yes representative
Abbott yes representative Edgar
aye representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman
yes representative Eaton yeah
representative Peterson yes
representative vallone yes
representative Juris yes
chairman McConkey chairman votes eye
share an emotion itl passes 1901
consent calendar
no it's not a
is it because when there's a financial
note to it is there a financial note to
it yeah
that I was Revenue neutral all right
never mind well that was a claim thank
you and it's nice to have you all back
at 19-0 so I thank you I recognize you
that always can happen but it is a
Hallmark many times of our committee so
we have no business uh before us for
next week that I'm aware of for
committee so enjoy your week off
all right
representative Newman I believe there's
a car warming up for you outside wow
if only we didn't all get one
thank you
okay I'm missing one thank you
in a few weeks